Hallo Stefan.
Sag mal, genau gesehen warst du schon wieder beim Friseur?
Ja.
Dann hat dich Merkel gelassen. Ja, sie hat gelassen. Warum? Muss man jetzt, hast du gedacht, bevor der nächste Lockdown kommt? Profilaktisch.
Ja, ich bin meinem Friseur so dankbar, denn da ist es ganz, ganz schwierig, Termine zu bekommen. Und ich hatte einen Termin, aber der wäre auf den Samstag gefallen. Und da hätten wir ja Ruhetag gehabt, wie wir auch diesen Donnerstag als Ruhetag gehabt hätten. Und als das bekannt gegeben wurde, wurde ich sofort morgens dann von meinem Friseur kontaktiert, ob wir das vorziehen wollen, um ein paar Tage. Und so war ich dann vorgestern wieder beim Friseur. Und der hat mir dann mal erzählt, was an dem Tag passiert ist. Also die haben ja dann Termine gemacht. Und natürlich ist jetzt noch ganz viel, was nachgeholt wird. Montag haben die getagt bis in die Nacht hinein. Und dann war das Dienstagmorgen klar. Und dann müssen die halt 250, 300 Termine ändern. Also diese Leute müssen kontaktiert werden. Das ist ein größerer Salon. Da müssen richtig viele Leute kontaktiert werden. Dann muss das alles umgelegt werden. Und so haben sie das dann gemacht, dass sie montags öffnen, was sie sonst nicht machen, damit sie die alle irgendwie abgefertigt bekommen, haben dann zwölf Stunden und mehr gearbeitet. Und da kann man mal wieder sehen, was dann so kleinen Unternehmern aufgehalts wird. Die müssen dann reagieren. Und die haben auch keine Möglichkeit, sich dazu beschweren. Der kann dann nicht anrufen im Kanzleramt. So geht es ja nicht. Entschuldigen Sie sich mal dafür. Aber wenn die 30 DAX-Konzerne da mal sagen, also wir haben da auch eigentlich eine Lieferung zu erwarten und das können wir jetzt nicht, dann muss Merkel selbstverständlich sich entschuldigen. Ich fand das so interessant, dass das auch noch mal so rezipiert wurde als Fehlerkultur und all das. Nein, Merkel hat eigentlich gesagt, ich habe noch mal mit den DAX-Konzernen Rücksprache gehalten. Und Sie wissen ja, wie gut es dem DAX gerade geht. Jetzt hat er ja die 15.000er Marke geknackt. Und ja, und da kann ich jetzt nicht einfach mit so einem Ruhetag daherkommen. Das hätte ich länger planen müssen und denen irgendwie sagen müssen, dass sie auch ja einen Ausgleich dafür bekommen. Während natürlich kleine Unternehmer da einfach mitziehen müssen und keine Chance haben, es anders zu machen. Und da sieht man noch einmal dieses große Ungleichgewicht in der Corona-Krise.
Absolut, da hat sich es richtig durchgeschlagen. Wolfgang Bichal hat ja auf Twitter relativ früh darauf hingewiesen, dass da wahrscheinlich die Automobilindustrie allen voran so intervenierte. Und Merkel dann wahrscheinlich auch, um ein bisschen abzulenken von der Gesamtlage, dann wirklich mal so den, wie soll man sagen, den roten Mandel in der Manege kurz aufgemacht hat, damit sich die ganzen Stiere auf sie stürzen. Weil ihr kann es ja eh egal sein und warum nicht noch mal mit so einem Tagesthemen-Kommentar hinsichtlich, das wird in die Geschichtsbücher eingehen.
Ich frage mich, was denn? Was hat sie denn da gemacht? Sie hat einen Tag zurückgenommen. Also das ist doch lachhaft. Hast du denn schon die Petitionen unterschrieben, damit wir jetzt wieder einen Lockdown bekommen? Denn du weißt, das ist jetzt wirklich der aller, allerletzte Lockdown. Da steht also da drin, dass das der letzte Lockdown ist. Ich muss ja dazu sagen, meine gute Freundin Samira El-Wassil ist daran beteiligt. Ich konnte sie nicht davon abhalten, aber ich nutze natürlich die Gelegenheit, um jetzt darüber zu lästern. Denn das ist schon ein Kracher, dass man da im Prinzip der Bundesregierung so einen Plankoscheck noch mal ausstellen will, hier, bitte unterschreibt mal, wir sind hier für den Lockdown. Vergessen Sie für einen Moment Armin Laschet. Und was mich dann sehr ärgert, ist, dass in so einer Petition nicht drin steht, dass man auch in der Zeit einfach mal dann den finanziellen Ausgleich zahlt. Dann bekommt halt jeder Bürger mal 500 Euro. Das könnte man reinschreiben. Man könnte aber auch gleich sagen, warum soll das eigentlich der letzte Lockdown sein? Denn das Personal wird ja nicht danach ausgetauscht, sondern da wird ja dann immer noch ein Armin Laschet sagen, ja, jetzt machen wir mal wieder auf und ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob wir irgendjemandem Masken vorschreiben können und so weiter und so fort. Also da finde ich, einfach muss man das schon mit was verknüpfen, wenn man überhaupt glaubt, dass eine Petition da was bewirken kann. Es sind halt die 30 DAX-Konzerne, die was bewirken könnten, wenn sie wollten. Aber das ist schon eine sehr eigenartige Geschichte.
Ich weiß noch, wie ich im November im Presseklub saß und dort noch mal anfügte, naja, der erste Lockdown, da war Zeit das Problem. Das war eine Notfallmaßnahme. Da musste die Politik sagen, und zwar auch auf sich selbst bezogen, wir können jetzt gar keine politische Entscheidung treffen, wir müssen jetzt einfach mal runterfahren im Sinne von. Kein Spielraum für politische Maßnahmen. Dass wir das im November noch mal machen mussten, weil keine Tests, weil keine Schulkonzepte, weil überhaupt gar nichts. Und die Zahlen wieder hochgingen und wir es nicht gelernt haben, mit der Virusgefahr zu leben, fand ich schon dramatisch. Beim dritten Mal finde ich es absurd. Es ist wirklich absurd. Vor allem wie man es öffentlich, medial und auch in der Privatmeinung, die bei vielen ja bei Twitter heute so auftaucht, wie es begleitet wird, dass man nämlich einfach akzeptiert, dass die Regierung jetzt sagt, wir müssen das jetzt wieder machen, ohne dass man, wie du es eben schon angedeutet hast, von der Regierung eine Gegenleistung bekommt. Also dieser viel gelobte britische Lockdown, den man da jetzt gemacht hat, nachdem die, wie wir im ersten Lockdown, wirklich eine Notfallmaßnahme machen mussten, weil diese Variante neu, die plötzlich so veransteckender war, da haben die einfach gesagt, junge Leute, geht mal bitte nach Hause, bleibt dort, wir zahlen euch 500 Pfund. Wo sind eigentlich meine 500 Pfund? Also ich finde, dieser Lockdown sollte jetzt von mir abgekauft werden. Dann bin ich auch motiviert, das mitzumachen. Auf der anderen Seite unterscheidet sich der Lockdown noch mal so sehr von dem, was wir eh machen. Also bei mir nicht. Meine Kinder sind in der Schule, es gab dann dieses kleine ja, Donnerstag keine Schule, die Elterngruppen bei WhatsApp explodierten hinsichtlich der Frage jetzt, wo gerade sich eingespielt hat, dass die Kantinen zu sind in der Schule, weil es sich nicht lohnt, für die halbe Schule jeweils zu kochen, sondern deswegen dann so Mittagstütchen ausgeteilt werden, wo irgendwie ein Brötchen und ein Obst und ein Joghurt drin ist. Und dann die Frage aufkam, ja, was sind denn mit dem Donnerstag? Kriegen wir die 2, 50 Euro dann wieder oder nicht? Das sind so die Fragen, die dann die Eltern da beschäftigen. All das wurde überhaupt nicht thematisiert. Merkel hat tatsächlich die Spannbreite der Effekte ihrer Ansage nicht bedacht. Wie es zustande kam, diese Entscheidung, ist nochmal für sich klamm. Auch da sollte man auch mit einem Drehbuch das nochmal nachschärfen, damit das wirklich jeder versteht, wie diese Verhandlungsnacht ablief, wenn der Bodo Ramelow irgendwie sechs Stunden vorm Bildschirm sitzt, Scherze macht mit Rainer Hasselhoff und Peter Tschentscher auch noch da ist.
Ja, und weil sie nur gesagt bekommen haben, die Kanzlerin ist in 15 Minuten zurück, ich muss mich mal ausruhen oder was weiß ich oder anderweitig besprechen und dann klingt sie sich einfach sechs Stunden aus.
Ja, dann waren es einfach 400 Minuten, statt 15. Und sie ist dann einfach nicht da.
So kennt man sie halt.
Malu Dreyer führt schon eine Telefonkonferenz nebenher, vergisst aber Tschentscher und Bodo Ramelow mit dazu zu holen, sondern die scherzen weiter darüber rum, dass ja Rainer Hasseldorf hinter sich das Bild ausgetauscht hat, das er in der Videokonferenz benutzt, benutzt hat. Und dann so aussah, als würde er in der Elbe versinken. Also es ist grotesk. Und dieser dritte Lockdown, der, sagen wir mal so, der ist alternativlos, weil wir ja viel verpennt haben. Er ist trotzdem nicht einfach so zu akzeptieren. Denn ich will ja nochmal, wir haben jetzt ein Jahr Corona hinter uns. Und es gibt hier einen Clip, der ist jetzt 238 Tage alt. Und ich will ihn einfach nochmal so kalt reinspielen im Sinne von, könnte man auch jetzt einfach spielen und sagen, wäre vielleicht eine Chance für in einem halben Jahr oder so. Aber nein, dieser Clip ist schon fast ein Jahr alt. Der ist vom 5. August 2020.
Hier im Abwasser der Kläranlagen. Auch hier sind Coronaviren zu finden. Und daraus will Prof. Jörg Dreves ein Frühwarnsystem entwickeln, wo sich Infektionen häufen. Dazu untersucht er die DNA des neuartigen Coronavirus im Abwasser.
Ja, es ist relativ früh, dass es tatsächlich anfängt, im Stuhlgang dann aufzutreten, wenn die Symptome sich auch nicht ganz entwickelt haben.
Für die Studie sammelt er aus 6 Kläranlagen in Bayern Abwasserproben.
Gestern ist der Probenehmer aufgestellt worden. Und ist eingestellt worden, dass er viertelstündlich Proben zieht. Und dann haben wir eine 24-Stunden-Mischprobe. Zeitproportional.
Und wenn tatsächlich dort ein Trend sichtbar wird, dass sich was ändert, dann können wir natürlich auch näher hinschauen. Wir können in die Kanalisation gehen, wir können es rückverfolgen, bis in einzelne Straßenzüge oder Stadtbezirke und schauen, ob das ein lokaler Herd ist, der dort greift oder ob es eine flächendeckende Infektion ist.
Die Wissenschaftler wollen derzeit herausfinden, wie sich das neuartige Virus abbaut in der Kanalisation. Mit den Erkenntnissen könnte man auch eine Prognose von Infektionszahlen erstellen. Vorteil, das Ganze ginge viel schneller, als wenn ein Patient mit Symptomen zum Arzt geht, ein Corona-Test ausgewertet wird und die Infektion dann bei den Behörden erfasst wird.
Und wir erfassen natürlich auch die Gesamtheit aller Ausscheider oder Patienten, auch die, die asymptomatische Symptome haben, die normalerweise gar nicht zum Arzt gehen würden und sich nicht testen lassen. Die werden auch erfasst.
Die Studie dauert noch einige Wochen. Möglicherweise können die Verfahren dann flächendeckend angewendet werden.
So, das ist ja nur ein Beispiel, wie man so ein Screening Straßenzügeweise irgendwie macht oder Altenheime dann besonders mal hier drauf screenen. Ja, taucht da irgendwie ein Virus auf im Abwasser. Zack, sofort reingehen. Antigen-Tests alle jeden Tag morgens, abends und so weiter und so fort. Als wir das im November, Oktober irgendwie, als ich es anbahnte, dass es wieder nach oben geht und Merkel ihre tolle Rechnung, Merkels Beitrag war ja diese tolle Rechnung, du weißt noch. Wenn sie noch doppelt so und so weit, dann alle mal zwei und so weiter. Mathematik, zweite Klasse, wir waren alle aus dem Häuschen. Da habe ich ja gedacht, na ja, es kommt jetzt die Winterwelle. Wir werden ja wohl bis Weihnachten alle Antigen-Tests zu Hause neben der Zahnbürste im Bad liegen haben, oder? Und wenn es heißt, deine Corona-App schlägt an, dann wirst du dich ja in dem Moment selber testen und dann wird sich ja wohl das Cluster ganz einfach durchscreenen lassen, das davon betroffen ist. Nichts davon. Wir haben heute keine verfügbaren Antigen-Tests in den Badezimmern, die da einfach so rumliegen. Es gibt keine Antigen-Tests, Geschenke an irgendwen, alles muss gekauft werden. Wir haben diese Masken-Misere mit diesen 2 Milliarden Extra-Kosten, weil der Bund irgendwie meinte, das muss alles erst in der Bundesdruckerei ausgedruckt werden, während man für die 2 Milliarden Euro Masken hätte kaufen können, womit wir das Problem zumindest schon mal gelöst hätten. Aber nichts davon. Wir haben heute Schulen offen, ohne dass es die eigentlich verfügbaren medizinischen Masken mal in Kindergröße gibt. Daran hat die Bundesregierung noch gar nicht gedacht.
Ja, das wundert mich auch, dass man nicht da... Also die Kinder sind ja sowieso die vollkommen Vergessenen. Also man geht ja schon mit allen Marginalisierten und an denen nicht viel Einkommen zuteil wird schlimm um, aber die Kinder werden ja eigentlich gänzlich ignoriert und dort freigegeben zum Abschuss, wenn man so möchte. Und man kann nur dann hoffen, dass es nicht irgendwie schlimm wird für Kinder, dass nicht auch noch irgendwelche Symptome sich einstellen könnten, von denen man jetzt noch nichts weiß. Also das ist so desaströs und das ärgert mich dann auch extrem, dass die Kanzlerin dann einfach nur eine bunte Bühne geboten bekommt bei Anne Will, sitzt da sonntags. Und Anne Will tut so, als wäre sie kritisch. Das ist so eine interessante pseudokritische Pose, die sie einnimmt. Gibt es nicht auch andere Dinge, für die sie sich hätten entschuldigen können? Haben sie nicht auch bei anderen Dingen? Und so kommt immer diese Frage, dann denkt man, oh, sie stichelt aber jetzt, jetzt ärgert sie. Aber was antwortet man auf eine solche Frage? Wenn ich jetzt sage, davon hast du dich aber nicht auch in der Vergangenheit mal geört, dann wirst du sagen, ja, es ist immer ein Kompromiss, es ist immer eine Komplexität aus Wissen und so. Aber wenn ich dir einfach mal genau nachweise, wo hast du Fehler gemacht? Wenn ich genau sage, warum ist das denn jetzt noch immer so? Dann kommt man wirklich in einen kritischen Modus. Das andere ist nur so eine Stichelei. Und mein Gott, Merkel hat mit Putin, mit Trump, mit allen Möglichen es aufgenommen. Da wird sie es auch noch mit Anne Will fertigbringen.
Ja, vor allem Anne Will hat ja wirklich einmal explizit in dem Gespräch gesagt, ich will hier nicht einfach nur die Gegenposition einnehmen, wo ich dachte, warum denn nicht? Es muss doch jetzt mal jemand die Gegenposition einnehmen. Oder man sagt, liebe Frau Merkel, ich habe gar keine Fragen vorbereitet. Ich habe mir gedacht, sie kommen bestimmt hier, um jetzt ihren Plan darzustellen. Sie haben jetzt eine Stunde Zeit, ihren Plan darzustellen. Stattdessen liefert sie einen Dialog ab, bei dem dann viele Journalisten im Nachhinein so raunen und ganz beliebt Twitter-Threads schreiben, wo alles noch mal dargeboten wird, wie sie so feststellen, dass Merkel sehr klug und zuweilen auch direkt mit den Ministerpräsidenten eigentlich sprach. Und gar nicht mit uns. Da frage ich mich, ist es zwar eine tolle Erkenntnis, wenn man das so raus analysiert in seiner ganzen journalistischen Qualität, die man da rein investiert in so einen Erkenntnisprozess, den man da ableistet, aber wenn man feststellt, Merkel hatte eigentlich mit dem Ministerpräsidenten gesprochen, dann muss man sich doch eine oder andere Frage stellen, wenn wir als zusehendes Publikum nur noch so Schwungmasse sind, damit Politiker untereinander mal Gewichtsverhältnisse miteinander klären.
Damit Laschet mal ein bisschen nervöser wird beim nächsten Auftritt. Deshalb wird es dann gemacht. Und das ist tatsächlich eine Degradierung des Bürgers zum reinen Publikum, was da stattfindet. Man fragt sich auch bei Anne Will, ich meine, was wird sie bekommen für so eine Sendung?
40.000 Euro.
Ach, 40.000 Euro.
Also die Produktion sind irgendwo über 100.000 Euro für die Stunde. Da geht natürlich viel für die Produktion selbst drauf, aber das reine Moderationshonora sind ungefähr 40.000 Euro.
Ja, jetzt würde ich sagen können, na, sie bekommt 40.000 Euro, da kann sie doch auch mal eine kritische Frage für stellen. Aber vielleicht ist es umgekehrt. Man bekommt 40.000 Euro, damit man keine kritische Frage mehr stellt.
Das ist die Rätselfrage, die können wir natürlich jetzt hier offen lassen.
Die lassen wir offen. Genauso wie wir offen lassen, wie sinnvoll das wäre, wenn wir jetzt ganz harte Ausgangssperren haben und dass das ganz schlimm ist, wenn Menschen in der Sonne oder so rumlaufen. Das wundert mich dann auch ein bisschen bei dem, was ich so Vogue-Twitter nenne oder bei Gesamt bei der Vogue-Bubble, was man dann auch in Online-Artikeln lesen kann, in Zeitungen ein bisschen weniger, dass man im vergangenen Sommer noch diese große Debatte hatte, struktureller Rassismus bei der Polizei. Dann hat man gesagt, der Seehofer soll unbedingt jetzt mal diese Studienauftrag geben. Dann gab es diesen Slogan, All Cops are Busters, all diese Geschichten. Und jetzt fordert man Ausgangssperren, schärfere Kontrollen in Parks. Und wir wissen ja, wenn wir das ernst nehmen, was wir da im Sommer alle gehört und gesagt haben, wer da besonders kontrolliert wird. Und wir hatten ja schon beim ersten Lockdown, also März, April letztes Jahr, Fälle von racial profiling. Also ich will da mal sagen, diese Wolken sind ziemlich verlogen, weil sie jetzt eigentlich nach der Polizei rufen und das dann auch noch großartig finden, wenn Lauterbach bei Stern TV, bei RTL sagt, ne, ne, das ist aber auch schon gut, dass da Leute in Düsseldorf von der Parkbank vertrieben wurden. Da merkt man dann schon einfach, wie furchtbar verlogen das ist. Und bei Lauterbach kann ich es auch nicht mehr so ganz nachvollziehen, dass man auf der einen Seite so hart für den Lockdown immer plädiert und jetzt noch strikter und all das. Und dann Lauterbach aber selbst nicht nur in Polit-Talkshows auftritt. Da kann ich ja noch sagen, gut, er will da informieren. Da kann man sich auch zuschalten lassen, aber lassen wir das mal dahingestellt. Aber wenn man dann auch noch jetzt Unterhaltungsformate besucht, wie RTL exklusiv mit Frauke Ludewig, übrigens da auch auf der Parkbank sitzt, wenn man zu Kurt Krömer geht, dann werde ich auch langsam ärgerlich. Denn es war jetzt so, dass Ole und ich zwei Lesungen in Luxemburg abgesagt haben, weil es uns zu riskant war, dort in einem Saal aufzutreten, bei dem doch viele Leute da sind. Die tragen zwar Masken, wir tragen keine. Da sind ein paar hundert Euro weg, natürlich auch weniger Bücher verkauft. Ja, das machen wir dann alles. Und dann zugleich sehe ich dann den großen Lockdown-Apologeten, der jetzt auch schon in Unterhaltungsshows rumgeistert.
Ja, das passt alles nicht mehr zusammen. Es ist sowieso viel Verlogenheit im Spiel. Da will ich ganz explizit, weil auf Twitter immer so, ja, haben die sich überworfen. Also wenn Tilo Jung die ganze Zeit eine No-Covid-Strategie fährt und dann noch ganz so viel Sand und die Konzerne sollen sich jetzt plötzlich auch mal beteiligen und wollen dann nicht, während er selber als Wirtschaftsbetrieb natürlich alle zu sich einlädt und dann freitestet und gleichzeitig noch niemals Homeoffice gemacht hat und die Bundespressekonferenz, die das ja durchaus anbietet, da wahrzunehmen, dann passt alles nicht mehr zusammen. Das Lauterbach, da du hast mit den Klipper geschickt, mit Frauke Ludewig plötzlich über die Straße läuft und da ihr seinen Kaffee trinkt, während er davon erzählt, dass er ja solo ist, aber sich schon freuen würde, nochmal eine Frau kennenzulernen, das passt da alles nicht ins Bild. Meine Arbeitshypothese ist so ein bisschen der Lockdown Nummer 1, das hat Ranga Yogeshwar in seinem Video damals gezeigt. Der hat ja vor allem funktioniert, weil die Leute Angst hatten. Das, was auch in Portugal jetzt wieder funktioniert hat, ist ja wirklich gut dokumentiert. Die Leute haben die Zahlen gesehen, haben gesehen, was passiert, dass es dann auch wirklich Leute betrifft, die man kennt, haben Angst und bleiben zu Hause. Wir hatten alle Angst im März 2020. Jetzt haben wir keine Angst mehr, denn Angst verbraucht sich. Das haben wir die Angstforscher auch dargestellt. Irgendwann schaltet der Kopf einfach um. Man kann nicht ein Jahr lang in Angst leben. Das Gefühl, was diesmal nicht dargestellt wird, und zwar vor allem, weil wir so viel an ganz neutralen Zahlen, sinnlosen Modellierungen, Politiker, Konflikten usw. das lenkt alles ab von dem eigentlichen Potenzial, das jetzt noch da wäre, nämlich über Betroffenheit, das zu machen. Dass man zwar sagt, ich weiß, du bist 25 und weiblich, und wahrscheinlich ist für dich die AstraZeneca-Impfung tatsächlich gefährlicher als die Corona-Krankheit. Aber schau es dir doch an hier, was auf der Intensivstation los ist. In diesen großen Zentren liegen ja mittlerweile, dadurch, dass die Inzidenzen höher sind, aber die Alten dann doch relativ geschützt, jüngere Leute auf den Intensivstationen. Und da liegen auch 30-Jährige, 20-Jährige, die dann beatmet werden müssen, die irgendwie die harte Dosis abbekommen haben, weil sie dann doch mal Shisha-Bar-mäßig direkt in die Lunge inhaliert haben. Und dann setzt sie das Virus eben gleich da an, wo es eigentlich erst später hinkommen sollte, nämlich direkt in der Lunge. Und das sind wirklich schlimme Krankheitsverläufe. Wir haben hier eine Babysitterin in der Nachbarschaft, U30, weiblich, die zwei Monate später immer noch mit einer mobilen EKG rumrennt, weil das einfach ständig beobachtet werden muss, was das so mit dem Körper noch nach sich zieht. Und in deren Sicht, und das findet aber nirgendwo statt. In Amerika findet bei PBS zum Beispiel jeden Freitag die letzten fünf Minuten der Nachrichten sind, da werden Schicksale dargestellt. Fünf Todesfälle, die Betroffenen selbst, die Familien schicken Bilder, schicken die Geschichten, die Nachrichtensprecher lesen das vor. So zur Musik drunter gelegt, da wird einfach klar, okay, es ist eine Krankheit, es kann jeden betreffen, und wenn es einen betrifft, dann kann man auch sterben usw. Und das findet alles nicht statt. In England zum Beispiel, die englischen Nachrichten von der BBC, die behandeln Covid fast gar nicht mehr. Sondern wenn Covid, dann richtig Covid. Aber nicht in diesem ständig hier nochmal alle Talkshows drehen sich darum. Ja, das ist Hyposensibilisierung, würde man das in der Medizin ja eigentlich nennen. Man hat irgendeinen Mittel, irgendeinen Stoff, man ist allergisch, man möchte die Allergie ein bisschen austreiben. Also überlastet man den Körper, kontrolliert ständig damit. Und so ist das hier auch. Wer sich für Corona interessiert, kriegt das ganze politische Schauspiel jeden Abend geboten. Aber man sieht nicht einen Patienten. Man sieht nicht einen Patienten, der mal in der konkreten Lage... Und es ist, glaube ich, heute immer noch so, dass Leute den Bescheid kriegen, Corona positiv, und sie nicht wissen, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Was sie jetzt machen müssen und so weiter. Ja, sondern da dann völlig haltlos, hilflos, völlig im Stich gelassen, so wie man auch noch niemals in den Tagesthemen, im heutigen Journal oder in irgendeiner Politik-Talkshow, obwohl die stundenlang senden, mal gezeigt bekommen hat, wie ein Antigen-Test funktioniert.
Ja, oder wie man eine FFP2-Maske vernünftig anzieht. Oder das ist ja etwas, was einfach aus einem Unwissen auch entsteht. Also natürlich gibt es Leute, die da die Nase oben raushängen lassen. Da ist das schon mutwillig, würde ich sagen. Aber Leute, die die FFP2-Maske sich einfach lose auf die Nase setzen und atmen dann fröhlich daran vorbei, da muss man sagen, nee, dann lass er auch ganz aus, weil kannst du es gleich sein lassen. Und das hätte man aber auch mal zeigen können. Ich verstehe das nicht, warum man sowas auch nicht zum Beispiel in den Tagesthemen einmal zeigt. Also sonst ist doch Klaus Kleber oder was immer für irgendeinen Scherz zu haben. Ach nee, das ist heute schon alt. Aber das kann man ja alles dort mal machen. Das kann man dort mal zeigen, wie es funktioniert. Und genauso auch mit diesen Antigen-Tests. Ich habe jetzt auch mal einen gemacht und das funktioniert ja ganz problemlos. Man muss es mal ganz kurz durchlesen, wie es geht. Und dann funktioniert das. Und das kann jeder verstehen. Und wenn ich sehe, was Diabetiker alles leisten müssen, dann ist ja ein Schnelltest gar nichts dagegen. Aber Diabetiker bekommen das natürlich auch irgendwann mal erklärt. Die bekommen nicht einfach da mal Insulin geschickt und spritzen und sie zu, sondern die bekommen das schon mal erzählt und warum das wichtig ist. Und das könnte man eigentlich leisten, gerade auch als öffentlich-rechtliches Fernsehen. Müsste man sich das leisten. Und dann könnte man diese ganzen Personalspielchen mal außen vor lassen. Denn das nutzt jetzt auch gar nichts, ob jetzt gerade Laschet noch schlechter dasteht und Söder ein bisschen besser dasteht und so. Was soll das jetzt alles? Die werden das Spiel noch ein bisschen weiter so treiben, solange wird zumindest noch über die Union gesprochen. Über die SPD hört man viel weniger, weil die Kandidatenentscheidungen schon längst gefällt haben.
Ja, ich formuliere eine klare Forderung. Bei Anne Will, sie sagt zwar immer wieder, wir lassen uns ja auch alle hier testen. Macht die Sendung zwei Minuten länger, testet euch am Anfang. Zeigt euch, zeigt uns, wie ihr testet. Denn dieses Gejammere darüber, dass sich ja im Supermarkt auch schon wieder alle so verhalten, als wäre nichts gewesen. Ja, im Fernsehen auch. Im Fernsehen sieht man nichts von Corona-Maßnahmen. Da sitzt man ein bisschen weiter auseinander, da trägt keiner eine Maske, da macht keiner einen sichtbaren Antigen-Test, da zeigt auch keiner sein Ergebnis hoch, kann man ja mal machen. So wie man es übrigens, und deswegen heißt das in Österreich, der Wohnzimmertest. Das können wir ja jetzt, bevor wir nochmal kurz über die Astra-Impfung reden, das kann man ja nochmal kurz sagen. Die Ärzte sind mittlerweile eigentlich alle einig, dass es mit der Corona-Bekämpfung ziemlich einfach ist. Es mangelt an Therapie-Treue, aber nicht an Therapie-Wissen. Das ist sowieso ein ganz wichtiger Unterschied bei den Ärzten. Warum sagen wir in der Rentner-Publik immer, es ist ganz wichtig, dass jeder einen Hausarzt hat? Weil der Hausarzt einem sagt, dass das wichtig ist, was im Beipackzettel steht. Dass man damit keinen Schabernack treibt und dass man es nicht auf die leichte Schulter nehmen soll. Und dass das alles mal ordentlich eingestellt werden muss. Und dass man sich dann eben compliance-mäßig, therapietreu auch immer an die Sachen hält. Und diese Bille Katzenstein, die selber 2700 Covid-Patienten in ihrer Praxis hatte mit 15 Mitarbeitern, kam mit null Infektion raus, indem sie einfach nur konsequent alle FFP2-Masken getragen haben. So wie hier in Frankfurt die Klinik-Chefs ihren Mitarbeitern immer wieder sagen, Leute, der Alltag ist schwer. Es betrifft die Ärzte und die Pfleger. Es macht dann doch auch nochmal, das muss man auch mal ganz deutlich sagen, einen großen Unterschied für das Klinikpersonal, ob da jemand mit 85 Jahren an der Beatmungsanlage liegt oder mit 35. Umso jünger, umso betroffener ist auch das Klinikpersonal. Und die Ansage ist dann Masken, Masken, Masken tragen. Maske, Maske, Maske. Die Maske, wenn zwei Leute eine LFP2-Maske tragen und sich indoor miteinander unterhalten, findet überhaupt keine Übertragung von irgendwas statt. Aber man muss sie halt tragen. Umso mehr wir Lockdown machen, umso mehr entwöhnen wir uns von der Maske. Denn wir schaffen, wir machen dann genau die Räume auf, in denen wir ach, wir können doch jetzt keine Maske tragen. Das ist doch irgendwie, wäre doch Quatsch oder wir haben doch kein Corona. Wo man sich genau in dieser falschen Sicherheit wiegt. Deswegen geht der Lockdown mit einem falschen Beipackzettel einher. Und mein Appell an alle, tragt immer indoor, außer wenn ihr bei euch zu Hause seid, Masken und lasst niemand sonst zu euch nach Hause. Trefft euch draußen. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Tipp. Trefft euch draußen.
Wir machen das ja auch nicht. Also wir sehen uns ja auch immer nur noch jetzt hier über Webcam. Das ist sehr schade. Ich hoffe, dass wir im Sommer geimpft sind und dass das dann anders möglich ist, dass es dann Schnitzel gibt. Und ja, wir werden dann wahrscheinlich nicht mit Astra geimpft sein. Das war ja nicht nur ein deutsches Thema, sondern auch ein Thema in Österreich selbstverständlich. Und ich will nur einen humoristischen Clip einmal vorspielen. Also hier geht es um Sebastian Kurz und seine Impfung. Denn er will sich doch eigentlich mit Astra impfen lassen.
Kann man sich Ihrer Meinung nach auf das Urteil der EMA verlassen?
Ja, also das ist gar keine Frage. Selbstverständlich auch der Bevölkerung die Angst vor AstraZeneca zu nehmen, werde ich mich jetzt live hier in Ihrer Sendung mit AstraZeneca impfen lassen.
So, Herr Bundeskanzler, jetzt geben wir es an.
Meine Güte, das tut mir leid. Aber wir haben noch eine Reserve, wenn ich richtig informiert bin. Das ist bedauerlich. Jetzt kann ich mich nur mal mit einem BioNTech-Impfstoff impfen lassen. Da möchte ich sagen, nicht man bringe den Spritz rein, sondern man bringe die Spritz rein. Wer war das?
Johannes Häferle war das. Das ist ein Junge, der ist, glaube ich, sogar noch Schüler oder so. Und der kann Sebastian Kurz grandios nachmachen, denn Kurz spricht ja immer so ein bisschen wie Jungs, die noch im Stimmbruch sind. Und er hatte auch mehrere Videos, Kochshows mit Sebastian Kurz und all das. Und hier, das war jetzt ein Auftritt bei Willkommen Österreich. Und da fällt dann zufälligerweise die Astra-Spritze runter.
Naja, also der Astra-Seneca-Impfstoff hat sich einmal komplett gewandelt. Die Ständige Impfkommission hat jetzt empfohlen, nur noch Ü60 zu impfen, statt wie vorher nur Ü55. Das ist natürlich zum einen irgendwie witzig, zum anderen auch leicht zu erklären, denn am Anfang gab es keine Daten für die Älteren. Jetzt gibt es Daten für die Jüngeren. Es gab neun Todesfälle bei zwei Millionen Verimpften. Das kann man natürlich sagen, ist ja statistisch kaum auffällig, aber trotzdem vermeidbar. Es ist ein bisschen wie beim Lockdown. Wir wissen, wie wir es vermeiden können, also machen wir es auch. Klar, der Lockdown, es sind nur 0, 4 Prozent der Deutschen gerade infektiös und trotzdem müssen 99, 6 Prozent Lockdown mitmachen. Und genauso werden jetzt alle nicht geimpft, die halt ins Beuteschema von dieser komischen Trombose im Gehirn darf fallen. Ist es jetzt ein Impfstoff zweiter Klasse deswegen, ich finde weiter der Kikole-Spruch, es gibt gute und sehr gute Impfungen, zeigt sich mal wieder umso mehr, denn wir haben von BioNTech nur Erfolgsmeldungen durch die Bank. Man spritzt ihn, man hat keine großen Nebeneffekte im Sinne von Impfwirkungen, im Sinne von das Immunsystem spricht an, es funktioniert. Wir haben nicht nur eine Verhinderung von allen Krankheitsfällen und vor allem Schwere und Tod, sondern wir haben auch eine totale Unterbindung von Infektiosität, das ist ja das größte, wichtigste Ziel. Klar, man kann sich individuell schützen mit einer Impfung, man will ja dann auch Herdenimmunität herstellen, für viele, die nicht impfbar sind, da gibt es ja einige. Es gibt zum Beispiel, habe ich bei Dreißart Kulturzeit gesehen, einen ganz interessanten künstlerischen Ansatz, das Archiv der lebenden Toten. Da sind drei junge Theatermacher, die sich mal mit den jungen Risikogruppen befassen und die einfach mal so eine Ich-Botschaft auf Video aufnehmen lassen. Das kann man sich dann gesammelt angucken. Da fallen auch viele darunter, die gar nicht geimpft werden können, die gar kein Immunsystem haben zum Beispiel. Sehr viele Therapien gehen ja heute immer noch einher mit, wir schalten das Immunsystem aus. Das kannte man früher von Aids-Therapien, heute immer noch bei vielen Krebstherapien usw. Dass man einfach das Immunsystem wirklich mal ausschaltet, damit es sich nicht wehrt gegen den Körper und die Therapie akzeptiert. Nur dann wird halt alles akzeptiert. Und da gibt es dann auch nichts zu aktivieren mit einer Impfung. Also in der Hinsicht ganz viele dramatische Fälle. Und diese RNA-Sachen sind, na klar, irgendwie eine divine Intervention. Das ist wirklich göttliche Fügung, muss man irgendwie so sagen. Das hätte es vor zehn Jahren so noch nicht gegeben. Jetzt ist es da.
Jetzt erstmalig Gewinn schreiben. Gestern haben die ja die Bilanzen veröffentlicht. Jetzt haben sie mal 16 Millionen oder so Gewinn hier in Mainz. Und davor waren das noch 180, 280 Millionen Verlust im vergangenen Jahr. Und da ist man jetzt sehr froh und hofft vor allem, dass das jetzt über diese Corona-Bewältigung hinaus ein Wirkstoff oder eine Technik sein wird, mit der man dann Krebs bekämpfen kann, effektiv bekämpfen kann, sich schnell anpassen kann. Denn das zeigt sich ja gerade bei dieser Frage erster, zweiter Klasse, was denn nun? Ja, erster Klasse auch deshalb, weil es so wunderbar anpassbar ist und schnell anpassbar ist, dieser mRNA-Impfstoff. Und deswegen kann man natürlich sich jetzt da heroisch geben und sagen, ne, ne, das ist aber doch Astra. Aber da sind ja jetzt auch, als das dann nun rauskam, wie heikel das vielleicht dann doch ist mit dieser Hirntrombose, da sind dann doch auch die, die sich geprustet haben damit, ja, also ich würde mir das ja dreimal spritzen, das ist so ein bisschen ruhiger geworden.
Genau, Astra, Sputnik, Johnson & Johnson, das bedeutet, wir spritzen Viren. Und das ist jetzt vermeidbar. Klar, man tauscht die wirklich krank machenden Viren, die man kämpfen will gegen irgendwelche etwas günstigeren Andenoviren oder wie auch immer aus. Aber problematisch, unproblematisch ist das alles nicht. RNA-Impfstoffe heißt, wir spritzen tatsächlich keine Viren, sondern einfach nur die Information. Sie ist ständig updatable. Der Körper baut keine Resistenz dagegen auf. Das ist nochmal, das ist vielleicht, Sputnik V gilt ja auch deswegen als so überzeugend, weil sich das Forscherteam gedacht hat, wir nehmen zwei verschiedene Trägerviren. Bei der ersten Impfung gibt es eine andere als beim zweiten, sodass beim ersten der Körper schon eine Resistenz gegen das Trägervirus ausbaut und beim zweiten wird er nochmal überlistet. Das kann man nochmal als, das ist ja eine tolle Idee, Magic und so weiter, aber das war jetzt hoffentlich das letzte Mal. Demnächst keine Trägerviren mehr. BioNTech plant dieses Jahr insgesamt 2, 5 Milliarden Impfungen herzustellen. CureVec will 300 Millionen herstellen. 2022 finde ich nur noch RNA. Das wäre auch so ein Traum, dass wir dann, wenn die südkoreanische und diese P1-Variante dann hier nochmal, dass man dann noch einmal, hat ja Drosten gestern an seinem Podcast gesagt, dass man noch einmal ein Update bekommt für die folgenden Coronaviren und wir dann einfach durch sind. Und für den Fall, dass es mal wieder auftritt, haben wir dann schon eine Basis, den Text haben wir am Salon gelesen. Und dann muss nicht nochmal das Trägervirus durchgetestet werden ein Jahr lang, sondern dann wird einfach der RNA-Strang auf seine Wirksamkeit getestet. Das dauert zwei Monate. Danach wird Impfstoff produziert, geimpft und fertig ist die Soße. Und dann schafft man, das ist da wirklich der Quantensprung. Also quanten im Sinne von groß. Der Sprung in die Zukunft, dass man das dann wirklich bewältigt, so eine Pandemie.
Und dann kann es auch Lesungen vor großem Publikum geben.
Richtig. Ich möchte euch herzlich gratulieren zu eurem Buch. Du siehst es hinter mir liegen von einem Krokodil, wird es gerade verschlungen.
Es ist kein echtes Krokodil, müssen wir dem Publikum dazu sagen. Es ist ein Stofftier. Und das hat jetzt das Influencer Buch im Maul. Was immer du heißen mag, was immer du uns damit sagen magst.
Das lag einfach und ich habe es kombiniert.
Das Krokodil ist ja kein übliches Influencer Accessoire, sondern man hat so pinke Flamingos und mit denen posiert man sehr gerne. Im Infinity Pool, darüber schreiben wir zum Beispiel.
Ich halte mal in die Kamera meinen kleinen Influencer hier.
Oh, was ist das?
Das ist ein Überraschungsei Krokodil mit Futterbrat in der Hand.
Sehr schön, ja.
Einer der frühesten. Und Achtung, noch eins. Die muss man jetzt kombinieren. Das eine Krokodil sitzt auf einem Bücherstapel und das andere hat ein Futterbrat in der Hand. Das sind sozusagen die Bücherverschlinger. Ich bin noch nicht dazu gekommen zu lesen. Ich habe die Salonlektüren auch noch nicht richtig gelesen, aber ich verbringe ja Ostern bei der Großfamilie, die allerdings schon geimpft ist. Und werde dort dann ausführlich, da ich da nur ein Sofa habe, kein Computer, kein Nichts, was mich ablenkt, alles verschlingen, so wie dieses Krokodil. Das heißt, ich bin noch unbefleckt, was Influencer angeht. Ich habe aber schon gesehen, dass ihr schon die große Runde gemacht habt. Ihr wurdet schon im Kanon aufgenommen, würde ich sagen.
Das könnte sein, ja. Wir sind auch in der Spiegel Bestsellerliste jetzt damit. Und ja, es macht großen Spaß. Wir haben viele, viele Interviews gegeben. Und gestern war dann noch was ganz Aktuelles. Und zwar hat sich ja Bibi die Brüste machen lassen, vergrößern lassen und die Nase in Anführungszeichen korrigieren lassen. Das Korrigieren bedeutet immer, dass was falsch ist. Man kann auch sagen, ja, Nasen können anders aussehen.
Es geht aber auch um einen Unfall oder so zurück bei ihr, oder?
Ja, so mutmaßt sie wohl. Und na ja, dazu wurde ich dann auch gefragt, ob ich dann mich dazu äußern könnte. Und mit Bibi war ich selbstverständlich ganz gut vertraut. Das ist ja nun eine der größten Influencerinnen und da. Und der Untertitel des Buches ist ja die Ideologie der Werbekörper. Und da kann man es eigentlich wieder so gut sehen, wie auch so ein Werbekörper ständig optimiert werden muss. Und ja, was interessant war übrigens so, das wäre auch nochmal ein Thema so generell, wie Amazon eigentlich so funktioniert. Also Amazon, denkt man ja, die sind ja logistisch so fantastisch, dass die ja sofort reagieren können, wenn die merken, okay, die Nachfrage steigt. Also man konnte es überall in den Buchhandlungen haben, und das hat über die Kursisten wohl alles wunderbar gehabt, aber Amazon hat aus irgendwelchen Gründen in den ersten Tagen es vollkommen versäumt nachzuordern. Die mussten dann immer über Thalia gehen und so. Und wir sprechen ja jetzt nicht, da sind jetzt nicht 100.000 Bücher verkauft worden. Also aber die haben dann irgendwie so Mini-Pakete immer nur gekauft, und dann waren das in den ersten Tagen immer bei Amazon vergriffen oder lieferbar in zwei bis drei Wochen. Ganz eigenartig, obwohl die Bücher da waren. Also man hätte sie sowohl beim Kursisten als auch bei Verlag bestellen können. Und Amazon hat echt lange gebraucht, bis die sagten, oh, das scheint wohl ein Buch zu sein, das gefragt ist, das legen wir uns mal hier auf Lager. Ganz eigenartig. Und ich fragte dann noch jemand vom Verlag und dann sagt, ja, das ist eine große Blackbox. Manchmal haben die, ordern die schon ganz viel vorher, wo man selbst als Verlag sich wundert, ach, dass die das schon alle haben wollen. Und dann gibt es aber auch Punkte, wo man eigentlich denkt, na ja, das ist ja jetzt schon nach oben gerückt und es gibt eine hohe Nachfrage. Und trotzdem haben die noch nicht reagiert. Also die größte Angst von Amazon ist, dass sie irgendwo ein Buch zu viel im Lager liegen haben, weil das ja kostet. Und dann haben die sich das so ausgerechnet, dass das dann für sie besser ist. Sie verkaufen es lieber nicht oder erst später, als dass sie es so auf dem Lager rumliegen haben, obwohl ich mir das auch nicht so logistisch ganz erklären kann.
Ja, das ist alles schwierig. Ich hab damals, also ich kannte das auch, aber es waren nur so ein, zwei Tage, dass dann einfach steht, Buch nicht verfügbar, wo ich dachte, klar, das ist verfügbar, aber nicht bei Amazon. Na gut. Dann ist das halt so, es gibt ja ganz, ich als E-Book-Verfechter bin ja auch der Meinung, man sollte durchaus mal einen Rückkanal von Kindle aus haben, im Sinne von, was unterstreichen da die Leute, und vor allem feiern ihnen da irgendwelche Fehler auf, Rechtschreibfehler oder so, dass man das irgendwie, aber nee, da gibt es gar nichts. Also man kann zwar immer wieder Buchupdates an Amazon schicken, aber da kommt nie irgendwas zurück, während die selber halt diese Mega-Datenauswertung von irgendwas machen.
Also jetzt hieß du mal wieder gedruckt, das ist doch schön.
Das erste Mal.
Wie ist das zu ermuntern, weil das Cover so schön geworden ist, deswegen sagst du dir, da passe ich es mal an.
Ich finde auch vom Format, das ist wirklich gut. Also es ist ein wirklich schönes Format. Es ist halt genau die richtige Biege, Dings und so. Ich werde es tatsächlich auf Papier lesen. Ich weiß allerdings noch nicht genau, wie ich dann damit umgehe, wenn ich mir was unterstreichen will und so, ja. Dann ist das da auf dem Papier und dann mache ich den Foto von, oder was? Und schmeichel mir das in einer Cloud, oder? Also das ist mir noch ein bisschen unklar, wie ich damit umgehe, aber gut, das werde ich mich mal...
Ich sag mal so, die letzten 2500 Jahre ging das ja auch ganz gut mit den Büchern so.
Ja, aber mir tun die Leute schon leid, die das so machen mussten. Ich will ja am Ende einfach sozusagen...
Obwohl 2500 vielleicht auch ein bisschen hochgemessen ist. Also die Bücher der Antike sahen doch etwas anders aus als unsere Bücher. Also sagen wir mit dem Buchdruck, aber ist es doch so in den Alltag übergegangen? Dass man ein Buch anstreichen kann. Also ich bin ja jemand, der im Buch anstreicht, nicht mit Lineal oder so, sondern anstreich und Dinge umkreist. Und dann schreibe ich auf den ersten Seiten des Buchs, schreibe ich immer dann unter Stichpunkten auf, was da steht. Und so habe ich dann immer die Seitenzahl da. Und dann kann ich da irgendwie nachvollziehen. Aha, Julia Friedrichs schreibt hier über die Lindenstraße. Und dann weiß ich direkt nicht ab.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist ja wirklich Mittelalter, was du mir erklärst. Also, wenn ich ein Buch lese, dann digital, dann mache ich da Unterstreichungen in verschiedenen Facettenfarben, wie auch immer, und füge dann auch meine Notizen da dazu, direkt an die Stelle. Und wenn ich das Buch fertig habe, sage ich bitte einmal diesen Gedankenapparat exportieren. Dann bekomme ich eine E-Mail. Und dann ist das alles und zwar nicht als PDF oder so, sondern schön HTML, sodass ich das dann gesammelt vor mir habe und dann noch einfach suchen kann, statt vorne selber Zeile zu Zeile durch meine Notizen gehe. Und das werde ich dann wahrscheinlich nicht so in dieser...
Mein Gott, jetzt merke ich aber wirklich, wie altbacken das ist, was ich mache. Aber na ja, ich bleibe jetzt mal dabei. Man wird sehen. Apropos altbacken, um mal auf die Wahlen noch ganz kurz zu sprechen, zu kommen im März, es wurde gewählt. Bei uns bleibt es in Rheinland-Pfalz Malo Dreier, was schon mal sehr gut ist, dass es nicht die CDU geworden ist. Ich hatte da im Januar Befürchtungen. Das sah mal kurz so aus. Gott sei Dank nicht. Die CDU Rheinland-Pfalz ist nämlich besonders furchtbar. Julia Klöckner und auch ihr Kollege Christian Baldorf. Dann haben wir auch hier nochmal einen Direktkandidaten, der noch Bäumchen gepflanzt hat mit Julia Klöckner. Also es ist alles sehr furchtbar. Und das ist dann, Gott sei Dank, nicht passiert. Und dann in Baden-Württemberg bleibt auch alles beim Alten, insofern das alles beim Alten bleibt, bei Winfried Kretschmann. Und hast du gesehen, dass Harald Schmidt in der ARD das kommentiert hat? Ja, da habe ich einen Clip mitgebracht. Und zwar wurde Harald Schmidt von Herrn Frey plötzlich da mal zugeschaltet, denn der kommt ja aus Nürtingen. Da hat man sich gedacht, da kann doch Harald Schmidt mal gerade die Wahl kommentieren.
Ich glaube, wenn man einen Schwarzwälder Schnitzer beauftragen würde, den idealen Baden-Württemberger zu schnitzen, dann käme Winfried Kretschmann raus. Er bringt alles mit, was sich die Baden-Württemberger-Innen wünschen.
Wie wird denn bei Ihrer Mutter beispielsweise, um ein bisschen indiskret zu sein, welchen Stellenwert genießt denn der Ministerpräsident dort?
Verehrung. Ich muss es so sagen. Ich bin gerade zu Besuch bei meiner Mutter, deswegen bin ich hier noch vorbeigekommen, um die Fahrtkosten mitzunehmen. Wir jungen Leute sind verrückt nach der Ministerpräsidenten.
Ja, so wird eine Retropublik gewählt. Das ist immer noch die richtigste Beschreibung von allem, was ich am Wahlabend sah. Hier in Frankfurt wurde auch gewählt, Kommunalwahl. Durch die Bank ist Frankfurt eine grüne Stadt, so wie alle urbanen Zentren wirklich grün werden jetzt. Wir wissen, dass die urbanen Zentren wachsen. Das ist ganz erstaunlich. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob es so eine Revolution von unten nach oben gibt.
Hier denke ich, ist aber der Faktor Rentnerrepublik ganz eindeutig bei Menschmann. Man kann das auch anhand eines Briefs lesen, den ich eingelesen habe. Und zwar habe ich mir erlaubt, einen Brief von Franz Josef Wagner einzulesen. Das ist der von der Bildzeitung. Und der Mann ist 77 Jahre alt. Das möchte ich dazu sagen. Und jetzt hören wir uns mal, wie er die Baden-Württemberg Wahl kommentiert. Alle lieben Kretschmann. Ich auch. Er ist unser aller Großvater. Weißhaarig, bald 73. Seit 46 Jahren mit Großmama Gerlinde verheiratet. Zwei Enkelkinder. Er liebt das Wandern und das Heimwerken. Er spricht behutsam. Er ist Katholik. Er steckt Opferkerzen in Kirchen an. Er hat zum dritten Mal mit überragender Mehrheit die Wahl in Baden-Württemberg gewonnen. Warum ist er so beliebt, unser grüner Opa? Als unser Opa jung war, gab es noch Forellen im Bach. Gab es Bienen überall. Unser Opa hat das alles noch miterlebt, die Schönheit der Natur. Unser Opa ist ein Grüner geworden. Grün bedeutet mehr als eine Partei. Grün bedeutet ein guter Menschsein. Der zweifache Großvater sitzt zurzeit am Krankenbett seiner Frau. Sie hat Brustkrebs. Der Wahlsieger von Baden-Württemberg ist ein Mensch, der Schönes und Schlimmes erlebt hat. Ja, er ist alt. 73 bald. Wissen Sie was? Ich wünsche mir einen Großvater für Deutschland. Sein Name ist Kretschmann. Herzlichst, Ihr Franz Josef Wagner.
Und das trifft so den Zeitgeist, dass er das schreibt und so wie du es vorliest.
Es ist absolut so und ich finde es auch schon, dass es eine Wiederholung drin ist, dass er zweimal darauf hinweist, dass Kretschmann bald 73 ist, weil man es ja dann schon wieder vergessen hat. Also das ist auch für Demenzkranke noch lesbar. Wunderbar.
Man, man, man, wenn es wenigstens, und da tease ich schon mal für später nachher, wenn es wenigstens alte Männer wie Joe Biden wären, die dann so einen richtigen Dunst- und Handlungskreis um sich schaffen, der auch wirklich mal was bewegt. Aber nein, das schlägt sich ja hier nieder. Das ist ja wirklich die ganze Staatskanzlei einfach alt. Na ja, ich wollte einen Scherz noch machen.
Ja, mach noch einen Scherz.
Um dann zu den Themen zu kommen. Es lag eigentlich auf der Hand, aber ich hab's gestern dann erst im David McWilliams Podcast gehört, dass man nämlich diese ganze Misere am Suezkanal mit der Ever Given, die da quer lag, was eigentlich ein Megathema ist. Ich hab auch gedacht, ihr macht vielleicht noch einen Wohlstand für alle dazu, weil diese 8 Milliarden, die da jeden Tag verloren gingen, allein, dass die Schiffe da nicht durchfahren. Und es sind irgendwie, also da fahren ja jeden Tag 100 Schiffe. 12% des Welthandels. Jeden Tag 100 Schiffe mit im Schnitt 10.000 Containern. Nur die Durchfahrt kostet 250.000 Dollar. Was das so bedeutet. Allein die Mehrkosten tanken um Afrika drum herum. Kostet irgendwie dreimal so viel. Also da werden einfach Millionen pro Schiff verpulvert, nur durch Treibstoff. Und gestern im David McWilliams-Podcast haben sie von einer Herzattacke der Globalisierung gesprochen. Und dann fiel es mir wie Schuppen von den Augen. Na klar, das ist eine Thrombose. Das war eine Thrombose der Globalisierung. So ein kleines Klümpchen, das alles ins Wanken bringt. Also das soll man ja tatsächlich auch im Supermarkt bei uns merken irgendwann. Dass es da jetzt zu Verzückung kam und dass sie das jetzt auch noch eine Woche brauchen, um das wieder aufzuholen. Und dass dann, wenn auch kein Mangel, zumindest Preisunterschiede am Supermarkt darauf zurückzuführen sind. Also in deren Sicht haben wir doch hier eine ganz interessante Verschränkung von Thrombosen im Gehirn und Thrombosen im Welthandel.
Ja, und so wie zum Beispiel mal die Lieferketten werden jetzt alle ganz kurz und wir werden jetzt alle wieder regional. Also solche ersten Prognosen beim ersten Lockdown. Nein, natürlich bleibt der Handel unglaublich global und man sieht schon, wie komplex das wird, wenn da nun mal das Kurz verstopft ist. Denn man kann ja sagen, naja, ist ja noch genug in den Regalen. Aber nein, das hat schon große Auswirkungen und produziert enorme Kosten.
Ja, vor allem bei, es gibt ja die Mikroökonomien auch noch als Wirtschaftspodcast. Da hat der Marco das auch mal aufgedröselt, wie Welthandel eigentlich funktioniert, dass man nämlich die Lieferpapiere selber als Handelsscheine benutzt. Also in dem Moment, wo der Lieferant, der ja selber dann erst mal mit dem Schiff ewig unterwegs ist, dir die Ware abgenommen hat, gibt es schon andere Akteure, Banken, die dir dann das bezahlen, bevor die Ware ankommt, bei dem, in dem dir die Ware eigentlich abkauft. Also in dem Moment, wo sie auf dem Schiff ist, gehört sie weder dem Verkäufer noch dem Käufer, sondern hat sie noch meinen eigenen Besitzstand, damit beide ihre Bilanzen für diesen Moment schön schreiben können, weil da nämlich diese Verluste in dem Moment nicht drinstehen. Und das ist wirklich grotesk, was da mittlerweile abläuft. Und in deren Sicht kann man sich ja auch die Finanzströme nochmal angucken, was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn die Dinger dann länger unterwegs sind. Und dadurch vielleicht auch in einem anderen Zustand, was Wert angeht, ankommen, als sie losgeschickt wurden. Und da zahlt auch gerade jemand drauf, so richtig, der mit diesem Ding nicht gerechnet hat, dass das so als Problem mal aufkäme. Weil wer, das muss man sich auch mal überlegen. Das sind Schiffe, die haben Milliardenwerte. Und da kalkuliert man nicht damit, dass die sich irgendwie verzögern. Außerplanmäßig eine Woche später. Also da arbeiten Militärs dafür, damit das nicht passiert. Am Suezkanal steigen Militärs mit in die Touristenschiffe, damit da nicht einer vom Rand mal kurz rüber springt und die alle ausraubt. Plötzlich gibt es aber solche Verzögerungen, gegen die man nichts machen kann. Selbst wenn man jetzt gesagt hätte, ich zahle 5 Milliarden, das Schiff hätte trotzdem noch 3 Tage länger festgesteckt. Also man konnte sich da mal nicht freikaufen. Und in deren Sicht mussten da jetzt auch Preise gezahlt werden, von irgendwem an irgendwem. Und das ist alles dann doch sehr interessant, wenn man sich es mal so im Detail anschaut. Thema Nummer eins.
Die Demokratie. Bürgerrätedemokratie. Die Demokratie, muss man eigentlich sagen. Wir haben jetzt schon gehört, in Baden-Württemberg, da ist der Grüne Oper. Und das ist doch alles so schön, wenn das so operhaft da läuft. Aber man könnte ja auch sagen, muss die Demokratie nicht einmal eine Verjüngungskur jetzt durchmachen. Und dann gibt es ja immer wieder diese Vorschläge der direkten Demokratie. Und da gab es jetzt im Monat März den Vorschlag von der AfD, direkte Demokratie. Und wir hören da mal rein, was Roman Reusch von der AfD, von Demokratie so versteht.
Wir wollen mit unserem Gesetzentwurf dem Volk die Mittel geben, diese Macht, die es haben sollte, auch auszuüben. Im Kern unseres Entwurfs steht, dass der geäußerte Wille des Volkes das oberste Gesetz sein muss.
Die Voluntärgeneral, schon immer missverstanden, auch bei der AfD wieder sehr gut.
Ja, beziehungsweise sie wurde so interpretiert, wie sie in den Zwanzigerjahren mitunter interpretiert wurde, zum Beispiel von Karl Schmidt, der sagt, die Voluntärgeneral, die kann auch einer ganz alleine vertreten. Der kann auch den gesamten Willen des Volkes vertreten. Das k culminiert dann bis dazu, dass Karl Schmidt irgendwann diesen Aufsatz schreibt, der Führerschutz das Recht. Und dann sagt man, das ist auch Demokratie, wenn das einer macht und man ermächtigt ihn dazu, dass er das macht. Bei Ernst Jünger gibt es nach 1945 die Äußerung, nie mehr Demokratie. Und das verwundert uns immer so ein bisschen, weil wenn wir irgendwelche Gedenktage haben, dann sagen wir, ja, die großartige Demokratie, und die müssen wir schützen und all das. Und Ernst Jünger zieht eigentlich aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg diesen Schluss bzw. aus dem Dritten Reich den Schluss, nee, Demokratie, das ist was ganz schön Gefährliches auch. Und diese identitäre Auslegung der Volontär-General, die gefällt jetzt AfD-Leuten ganz gut. Man muss vielleicht noch der Fairness halber eines hinzufügen, also diese Volontär-General-Idee, dass die auch von einer kleinen Gruppe und nicht von einer Mehrheit vertreten werden kann. Die hat durchaus auch ein Widerstandspotenzial, nämlich beim französischen Widerstand, bei der Resistance, die sich gegen Deutschland richteten, die also nicht paktierten mit den Nazis. Die haben gesagt, wir sind das wahre Frankreich. Also die kleine Gruppe Chateaugol usw. die haben gesagt, wir sind das wahre Frankreich. Und da haben sie eigentlich auch so einen Volontär-General-Begriff, der fast identitär ist, aber man kann das eben auch nutzen, um dann Widerstand gegen eine solche Okkupation zu haben.
Lass mich auch noch anfügen, es gibt in Amerika immer wieder eine Diskussion, für wen der Präsident eigentlich arbeitet. Und im No Agenda Podcast, der nun aus vielen Gründen so ein bisschen quatschig ist und abzulehnen ist, aber die weisen immer wieder drauf hin, wenn irgendwer kommt, meistens sind die Präsidenten selber, ja, das gibt Zitate von Obama, von Trump und von Biden, wird es ihnen auch geben, dass die oberste Aufgabe des amerikanischen Präsidenten ist, das amerikanische Volk zu beschützen. Deswegen dieses ganze America first und so weiter. Die weisen dann immer wieder drauf hin. Nein, der Eid wird natürlich auf die Verfassung geschworen. Und Alexander Thiele, ich habe sein Buch leider nicht gelesen, aber wenn ich ihn nicht falsch verstehe, zumindest hat er auf Twitter sich mal so geäußert, in Deutschland ist es auch so, dass das Grundgesetz im Kern von allem steht. Und in diesem Grundgesetz, das regelt dann, wie Wahlen funktionieren usw. da gibt es dann Details, Gesetze. Aber diese Annahme von der AfD, dass das Volk sozusagen ein besonderer Akteur im Verfassungsgefüge ist, dem widerspricht er einfach. Da sagt er, wir haben eine repräsentative Vertretung, wir haben einen Bundespräsidenten und wir haben ein Wahlvolk. Da hat aber keiner davon Primat, sondern die wirken einfach alle miteinander und zirkulär. Und da gibt es diese Vormachtstellung des Volkes so gar nicht. Soziologisch wollte man eh von dem Publikum sprechen, dem Publikum, das Publikum der Politik, das sich dann eben über Wahlen nach verfassungsgemäßen Vorgaben äußert. Aber diese Grundannahme, das Volk, dieses herrliche Volk, von dem aus die Entscheidung ausgeht, das ist immer schwierig und lässt sich, und Alexander Thiel ist eben Verfassungsrechtler, auch in den Texten, auf die wir uns da beziehen, und die dann auch gelten, so nicht finden. Sondern da muss man schon so eine AfD-Vorstellung von irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was haben, dann kann man das so argumentieren.
Auch natürlich in einem sehr homogenen Volk. Und jetzt wird mal von Roman Reusch gesagt, warum das denn so eine tolle Idee ist, jetzt mit der direkten Demokratie.
Schließlich soll die Bundesregierung die Möglichkeit erhalten, durch Veranstaltung einer Volksbefragung den Volkswillen in Erfahrung zu bringen. Brexit lässt grüßen, wird da eine oder andere sehen, man kann auch mit diesem Instrument sehr viel bewegen, wie das Beispiel zeigt. Insgesamt bei Verwirklichung dieser Vorstellungen wäre die Macht der Hinterzimmer mindestens deutlich reduziert.
Das ist eine schöne Illusion, die ja vielleicht sogar ein bisschen glaubt, nämlich dass es beim Brexit keine Hinterzimmer gegeben hat, sondern man hat einfach mal so eine Wahl gehabt. Seid ihr dann jetzt dafür oder dagegen? Kreuz bitte an. Und wir wissen ja, was da eigentlich, du hattest ja auch schon mal im Salon diesen langen Text, glaube ich, aus dem Guardian vorgestellt, was eigentlich in Hinterzimmer gelaufen ist, wer da eigentlich die Strippen gezogen hat und dass man eigentlich versucht hat, dieses Volk, wenn man jetzt mal von diesen Volksbegriffe ausgeht, in eine gewisse Richtung zu manipulieren. Und da geht es nicht darum, dass man eine Diskursivität zulässt, wo dann wirklich über Pro und Contras abgestimmt wird.
Genau, also wir hatten den Guardian-Text gelesen, wo jemand sich mal hingesetzt hat und alle Blogtexte von Dominic Cummings gelesen und für uns noch mal zusammengefasst hat, wo dieses Denkgebäude zurückkam. Man kann aber auch diesen Film noch mal mit Cumberbatch empfehlen, wo auch noch mal gut dargestellt wird, wie das Volk da einfach verarscht wird. Also wie da auch einfach Sachen nicht gesagt wurden. Und diese Hinterzimmeridee, die ist natürlich, die funktioniert immer ganz gut. Aber gerade beim Brexit, ja, beim Brexit ist man ja heute schon der Ansicht, die Abstimmung wäre natürlich anders verlaufen, wenn man den Leuten nicht gesagt hätte, die Alternative ist hier rein in die EU, raus ist die EU, sondern ihn einfach wirklich darlegen. Das Szenario, das danach erst in Verträgen, dass man wirklich erst den Vertrag mit der Europäischen Union aushandelt, wie ein Brexit aussieht und den dann zur Abstimmung stellt. Dann wäre es wahrscheinlich anders ausgegangen. Das ist übrigens auch bei diesen ganzen Lockdown. Jeder kann jetzt eine Position schreiben unter einen Lockdown. Nur, und da auch wieder die Modellierer, die jetzt gerade so toll gehandelt werden. Die Modellierer werden immer reduziert, gerade auf Corona-Prognotisten, die uns noch mal darlegen, wenn es so weitergeht wie jetzt, dann ist es in zwei Wochen so. Aber dafür brauchen wir keine Modellierer, sondern das ist eine Exponentialfunktion. Die können wir selber in die Zukunft rechnen, so weit, wie es dann halt trägt. Da sagen die Modellierer auch, nach vier Wochen ist der Schluss. Was wir von den Modellierern eigentlich verlangen könnte, wäre zu sagen, mach ein Modell von der Gesellschaft. Das ist ja der eigentliche Sinn. Man dupliziert durch Abstraktion und verwandelt eine reale Gesellschaft in ein analytisches Modell, bei dem man plötzlich die Variablen unter Kontrolle hat. Und dann sagt man so, wir wollen jetzt ein R von 0, 2. Was bedeutet das? Und dann braucht man ein Modell, das einem das darlegt, wo auch alles einbezogen wird, inklusive Compliance. Wenn die Therapietreue nicht entsprechend ist, wir wollen trotzdem auf 0, 2, dann muss in so ein Modell geschrieben werden, wie lang die Nägel sind, mit dem man die Haustüren zunagelt. Das kennen wir aus Wuhan. Da hat man die Haustüren tatsächlich einfach vernagelt. Da wurde auch nicht nur verplombt, im Sinne von, damit wir gucken können, ob jemand die Quarantäne gebrochen hat, sondern da wurde die Quarantäne physisch unmöglich brechbar gemacht. Da hat man einfach die Türen zugenagelt. Und das muss in solchen Modellen vorkommen. Und die kann man dann zur Abstimmung stellen. Dann kann man sich in der Petition genau angucken. Okay, wir wollen eine R von 0, 3, damit es in einem Monat durch ist. Dann zeigt uns genau, wie diese Gesellschaft aussieht für diesen Monat. Und dann stimmen wir darüber ab. Und dann sähe das auch anders aus, als wenn jetzt jeder einfach kommt und sagt, wir brauchen einen Lockdown jetzt. Also wenn es nur Hashtag Lockdown jetzt ist, dann kann man dann zwar direkt demokratisch und das Volk hat entschieden, aber dann führt das nicht sehr viel weiter als so ein, Dietmar Dat hat das immer Partizipationstheater genannt, was die AfD da jetzt anstrebt.
Warum ist eine repräsentative Demokratie vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht? Das sagt hier Sandra Bubendorfer Licht von der FDP.
Bei einem Volksentscheid besteht die Gefahr, dass sich die Mehrheit über die Minderheit hinwegsetzt. Das ist natürlich demokratisch theoretisch so gewollt, aber es bedeutet auch, dass diese Minderheiten quasi kein Gehör finden würden.
Minderheitenschutz, also eine wichtige Sache. Und jetzt kommt eine Grüne, Tanan Bayran. Sie sagt, na ja, wir haben ja durchaus auch andere Formen als nur gerade diese parlamentarische Demokratie. Denn vielleicht ist das noch anzufügen. Diese Bezugnahmen auf die Demokratie, die sind immer so ein bisschen unscharf. Und ich mag das auch nicht, wenn immer das so hochgehalten wird. Ja, die Demokratie, die Demokratie gibt es nicht. Eigentlich, was da gefeiert wird an den Gedenktagen, ist eine parlamentarische Demokratie. Und eine parlamentarische Demokratie ist etwas, was von dem schon genannten Karl Schmidt zum Beispiel so hart angegangen wurde. Der sprach da von der Quasselbude. Da haben wir auch schon mal erwähnt in seinem Buch Die geistesgeschichtliche Lage des Parlamentarismus. Der sagt, das bedeutet nur ewige Diskussionen. Das kommt nie zu einer Entscheidung. Und das sei doch das Wichtige, dass man entscheidet. Und diese Ablehnung des Parlamentarismus, das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was wir momentan auf globaler Ebene sehr gut erleben mit den neuen autoritären Personen, die dort auftreten, die genau immer darauf aus sind, das Parlament zu entmachten. Und Bayram stellt jetzt mal hier heraus, dass es durchaus ja auch noch andere Möglichkeiten der Partizipation gibt.
Wir Grünen sind für Demokratie in all ihren wunderschönen Formen und damit auch für die direkte Demokratie. Das kann ich schon mal vorwegschicken. Und wir sind nicht nur für die direkte Demokratie, sondern in meinem Wahlkreis Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg wird auf Landesebene heute ein direktdemokratisches Volksbegehren vorgestellt, die Deutsche wohnen und ähnliche große Wohnungsbaugesellschaften gemäß Artikel 15 des Grundgesetzes zu vergesellschaften.
Da ist ja die AfD dann auch dafür, wenn es da die Mehrheit gibt.
Da ist sie natürlich nicht dafür. Bayram ist hier nicht ganz ehrlich, was diese direkte Demokratie anbelangt, denn das ist rausgeflogen bei den Grünen. Das wurde bisweilen auch kritisiert. Also die Grünen haben nicht mehr in ihrem Programm jetzt, dass sie direkte Demokratie wollen, sondern sie sagen dann, es muss andere Möglichkeiten geben, Bürgerräte, zu denen wir jetzt kommen werden. Das ist etwas, was sie jetzt stark machen. Also sie wollen schon mit den Bürgern Stelka in den Dialog treten und all das. Aber diese vorher wohl sehr klar benannte Idee der direkten Demokratie ist jetzt erstmal rausgeflogen. Vielleicht auch, weil man erkannt hat, dass man damit vielleicht nicht auf so sicherem Boden steht oder dass das auch von anderer Seite sehr gut benutzt werden kann. Ja, Bürgerrat, das war das große Thema im März. Und jetzt werden sich viele fragen, ach ja, habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Und dann würde ich sagen, ja, so geht es wohl den meisten. Ich habe da Videos bei YouTube gesehen mit Schäuble und Co. und die hatten dann 300 Aufrufe. Und das waren schon die Erfolgreichen. Also das soll das große Thema sein, interessiert aber gar nicht. Und interessant ist aber, dass alle Politiker, gerade Bürgerräte, ein bisschen toll finden. Und ich glaube, wir sollten deshalb mal besonders kritisch darauf schauen. Und da ist jetzt noch mal aus dieser von der AfD angeregten Debatte im Bundestag spricht jetzt Lars Castellucci von der SPD, der sagt, er sei nicht für direkte Demokratie. Aber da gibt es doch ein anderes Konzept, den Bürgerrat.
Ich sage Ihnen mal, was eine gute Idee gewesen wäre, die Pandemiepolitik durch einen Bürgerinnenrat begleiten zu lassen. Das hätte zu einer Vertrauensbildung für unsere Politik beigetragen.
Bloß nicht, sage ich da schon mal. Aber es gibt diese Idee und sie wurde zum Teil auch umgesetzt. Wir hören jetzt mal die Bundespressekonferenz mit Clodine Niet. Die saß da neben Schäuble. Und Clodine Niet ist von dem Verein Mehr Demokratie, die das jetzt organisieren, den großen bundesweiten Bürgerrat. Und was soll dieser Bürgerrat entscheiden? Die Rolle Deutschlands in der Welt.
Aber sagen wir uns noch mal, welche Rolle hat Schäuble da als? Also der war der Bundespräsident, ist dann irgendwie so Schirmherr von...
Genau, Schäuble hat das angeregt mit den Bürgerräten. Er ist ja da auch einen engen Austausch mit Winfried Kretschmann und hat das angeregt, dass es doch sowas geben soll. Ein Bürgerrat. Und dann hat der Ältestenrat dann über ein Thema nachgedacht oder auch der Bundestag hat nachgedacht. Und dann haben sie sich was ganz Kleines ausgesucht, nämlich Deutschlands Rolle in der Welt. Na ja, also da sollte jetzt dann der Bürgerrat tagen. Und kommen wir aber erst noch mal zu dieser Idee Corona-Rat. Da spricht jetzt Claudine Niet folgende Worte.
Momentan sind wir tatsächlich auf dem Gebiet, dass Bürgerräte Empfehlungen erarbeiten und keine Forderungen. Ich fände das aber durchaus sinnvoll, wenn wir zum Beispiel die Kombination mit direkter Demokratie in den Bundesländern mal erproben. Denn da wäre es ja genau die Situation, die Landesregierung, ich glaube Baden-Württemberg hat zum Beispiel jetzt einen Bürgerrat eingesetzt, um sich in der Corona-Politik über 12 Monate beraten zu lassen. Und in Baden-Württemberg wäre es zum Beispiel möglich, dass wenn die Ergebnisse nicht übernommen werden, dass sich eine Initiative aus dem Volk bildet und ein Volksbegehren dazu macht.
Wie schief gewickelt muss man eigentlich sein, wenn man jetzt sagt, das wäre doch toll, wir haben einen Bürgerrat, und die machen dann Vorschläge, und wenn die Politik sich nicht daran hält, dann machen wir noch einen Volksbegehren. Also wir merken ja gerade, wie wenig Zeit wir haben. Man diskutiert jetzt darüber, darf Merkel noch drei Tage länger warten, oder muss da eigentlich jetzt schon vorgestern der Lockdown gewesen sein? All das wird gerade diskutiert. Und jetzt stelle ich mir das vor, wie das mit so einem Bürgerrat geht. Und dann können wir 2024 mal zur Abstimmung über das Ganze kommen. Ob das sinnvoll ist, doch vielleicht keine Schnelltests bei Kindern durchzuführen, oder was auch immer.
Ja, das ist ja auch das Denkgebäude von der AfD. Die haben ja Themen, die sie beschäftigen, weshalb sie auch auf die Straße gehen, da irgendwas organisieren, bei denen sie gerne mitentscheiden würden. Nur wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, dann öffnen wir jetzt die Demokratie im Sinne von Beteiligung. Dann arbeiten wir mal eine Tagesordnung aus und legen die dann vor. Da würden ja viele Demoten sich das mal angucken, die 50 Seiten mal durchgehen. Ich meine, der Bundestag entscheidet so viel. Da wird so viel thematisch verhandelt. Das ergibt sich sowieso von selbst, dass es die Demokratieform, die wir da haben, aus Zeitgründen gibt, um überhaupt entscheidungsfähig zu sein. Und das ist halt so dieses Cherry-Picker-Modell der direkten Demokratie, die da irgendwie so vorherrscht.
Ja, es gab aber einen Corona-Bürgerrat, wusste ich dann auch nicht. Hätte ich auch besser nicht gewusst, nämlich in Baden-Württemberg. Und da spricht jetzt Gisela Erler. Sie ist von den Grünen. Sie ist mit Kretschmann seit eh und je befreundet. Und sie leitet jetzt diese Bürgerratsgeschichten dort in Baden-Württemberg. Und sie stellt jetzt mal vor, was dieser Corona-Bürgerrat so zum Thema Impfen sich ausgedacht hat.
Sie sind so verunsichert. Und das geben sie sehr stark auch als, naja, die Medien. Viele von denen lesen ja keine Zeitungen mehr, sondern sie konsumieren halt soziale Medien und so weiter. Und dann Talkshows und sie sagen halt, was von den Medien, was sie mitkriegen, ist nur Verunsicherung. Und nicht irgendwie, sie haben nicht das Gefühl, dass sie informiert werden. Da sind wir jetzt alle ein bisschen ratlos, weil dann sagt das Sozialministerium, lest doch unsere FAQs, Frequently Asked Questions. Und das ist natürlich viel zu unübersichtlich. Und kein Mensch sucht beim Sozialministerium die FAQs, außer es ist schon jemand, der gut informiert ist. Aber so, da aus Freudenstadt der Mann mit Migrationshintergrund geht entschieden nicht auf die FAQ-Seite vom Sozialministerium. Ja, also es war ganz wichtig nochmal zu sagen, wie kann man die Kommunikation nochmal für solche Menschen breiter verobjektivieren. Und es gibt ja schon auch beim SWR und so weiter ganz ordentliche Infos. Aber die Aufnahmekanäle sind so unterbrochen. Sie haben dann gesagt, bitte, geht doch über Influencer. Jetzt reizen wir also über welche Influencer wir unsere Impfbotschaften absetzen können. Das ist der Corona-Bürgerrat.
Bloß nicht, also das ist ja das Stimmste. Aber die Bundesregierung hat ja solche Ideen auch schon. Influencer, also da werden dann diese ohnehin schon viel zu reichen Leute nochmal mit Steuergeldern ausgestattet, damit sie Werbung für sich und das Impfen noch nebenher machen können. Also totaler Unsinn, da merkt man einfach, nee, da wäre auch mal besser, man würde keinen Bürgerrat abhalten. Und wer sich jetzt da informieren will.
Du hast uns ja auch schon die Clips gezeigt von Florida TV oder wie sie heißen, diese Bleib zu Hause Kampagne und so weiter. Wäre ja auch denkbar, dass man jetzt einfach, dass eben auch in dieses Format steckt.
Ja, dass ich halte das für durchaus möglich, dass das kommen wird. Also ganz klar, auch Marlo Dreyer hat sich ja auch mit Influencern getroffen. Oder ich fand das auch so amüsant, dass dann so ein Duell war. Und dann haben CDU und SPD gesagt, da brauchen wir mal junge Leute, die jetzt das auch danach kommentieren und einordnen. Das war dann auch zwar Wolfgang Bosbach zu Gast, aber man braucht jetzt auch mal für die Jungen. Und das wird dann im SWR übertragen. Und wer war da? Diana Kindert, die mit dem Hütchen und Lilli Plautzun. Und ich weiß ganz genau, wie das SWR Publikum darauf reagiert. Die gucken, wundern sich ein bisschen und sagen, was machen denn Beatrice Ekeli und Udo Lindenberg da? Also das ist für die überhaupt keine Kategorie. Und jetzt mit diesen Influencern anzukommen, ja im Gegenteil. Also ich würde sagen, wenn ich jetzt noch sehen würde, dass irgendeine Influencerin irgendeine Diana zu löwen oder was mir Astra unterjubeln will, dann würde ich sagen, gut, dann auf keinen Fall. Dann nehme ich lieber den Strick.
Die Kindert muss ich ja ein bisschen in Schutz nehmen, denn die kümmert sich, seitdem sie jetzt immer Hut und nicht mehr Baseball-Cappy schief aufsetzt, sehr um die Generationen fragen, und zwar gar nicht so schlecht.
Ach.
Und ich glaube, es liegt eine Chance für die politischen Verantwortlichen darin, zu sagen, wir machen das mit den Influencern, weil es die Bürger in den Räten so empfohlen haben. Also, dass man sozusagen die Entscheidungsgewalt darüber abgibt und darüber dann die Möglichkeit schafft, das zu machen.
Ich würde einfach drastisch sagen, da saßen wohl Deppen im Bürgerrat. Aber kommen wir mal zu Baden-Württemberg. Also, das ist das Bürgerratsland überhaupt. Und das liegt an Gisela Erler, die das ganz großartig findet. Und das muss man sich jetzt vorstellen. YouTube gibt es ein Video, dort stellt sie das jetzt vor. Und eigentlich soll das eine Diskussion sein unter vier Leuten. Da ist Gisela Erler, da ist ein Abgeordneter Martin Krath, auch Grüne. Dann gibt es dort einen jungen Mann, der denen den Stream eingerichtet hat. Heißt es auch, der muss ja immer stundenlang da arbeiten, bis der Stream eingerichtet ist. Naja, so viel Ahnung von Technik hat man dann dort. Und Martin Krath um die 60, Gisela Erler über 70. Und jetzt hat man einmal diesen jungen Mann, der den Stream einrichtet. Und dann hat Gisela Erler auch noch eine Assistentin, die immer die Folien weiterklickt. Die Schieler, die muss immer die Folien weiterklicken. Wer glaubst du, dann kommt er überhaupt zu Wort? Natürlich nicht der junge Mann, natürlich nicht die junge Frau. Die darf eine einzige Frage vorlesen. Und sonst spricht Gisela Erler wie ein Wasserfall ohne Punkt und Komma, was diese Bürgerräte alles können. Und am Ende spricht auch dann nochmal Martin Kratz. Und wir sollten da mal reinhören, um mal ein bisschen diese Argumentationswege, warum jetzt Bürgerräte so toll sind, nachzuvollziehen. Und da wird auch ins Ausland gepflegt. Allerdings sagt man nicht Brexit war doch so ein schönes Beispiel, sondern man schaut nach Irland.
Ein Bürgerrat hat, so war es in Irland, steht da oben rechts Citizens Assembly. Die haben einen großen Bürgerrat gemacht zu zwei ganz, ganz, ganz heftig umstrittenen Themen. Einmal die Abtreibung und einmal die homosexuellen Ehe. Und in beiden Fragen war die Bevölkerung und waren die Teilnehmer vorher ganz skeptisch. Und dann haben die ein Jahr lang getagt und haben dann gehört zur Abtreibung zum Beispiel erst mal die Zahlen. Man macht immer einen objektiven Input. Und dann haben sie aber auch gehört, die katholische Kirche und die Lebensschützer konnten dann erklären, warum sie dagegen sind. Dann haben sie aber auch Frauen gehört, die nach England gefahren zur Abtreibung.
Ja, das ist ja eh so ein ganz beliebtes Thema. Diese Irländischen Samples, die es da gab, die sind ja auch ganz gut dokumentiert, wo man aber dazu sagen muss, ja thematisch, das ist einfach thematisch dort wirklich ausschlaggebend gewesen. Denn bei der Ehe für alle, da trafen ja wirklich Boomer, die Angst um ihr Leben hatten, wenn sie auf einen Homosexuellen trafen. Das erste Mal in ihrem Leben auf einen schwulen Mann, wurden in ein Gespräch verwickelt und wie verzaubert kamen sie aus diesem Gespräch wieder raus. Wenn man sich diese Storys dazu anhört, gibt es auch gute deutsche Podcasts für Geschichten vom Hass oder so heißt das eine. Dann kann man sich ja auch fragen, musste es ein Bürgerrat hinsichtlich, hier wird aber auch entschieden sein, oder hätte man diese Treppe nicht anders organisieren können? Also hier wird so eins plus eins gerechnet und dann so zwei draus geschrieben. Aber das zeigt zum einen, da gab es diese Gespräche vorher nicht. Und wenn man es dann nur in so ein Gespräch schafft, die Leute zu motivieren, indem man ihnen sagt, du darfst aber auch mitentscheiden, du darfst auch ein bisschen mächtig sein, dann klappt das bei solchen Themen. Aber damit kann man ja nicht so dauerhaft auf Struktur setzen, sondern das sind dann Events, die dann einfach abgehandelt werden.
Das hat aber offenbar Kretschmann vor. Er sagt Folgendes. Wir hören da mal rein.
Der Winfried verkündet jetzt, Zukunft wird es kein großes Projekt mehr ohne Bürgerräte geben. Ja, das ist ein großes Wort. Und es wird wahrscheinlich noch nicht ganz so umgesetzt. Aber das ist schon im Kern so, dass wenn du was wie ein Hasbin-Gefängnis oder die Opernsanierung oder andere große Bauprojekte, wo auch die Kosten immer sehr strittig sind, dass man dann einen Bürgerrat macht, der sich sehr genau informiert.
Ja, klar, man kann sich die Themen, die man will, raussuchen. Und dann sagen, dazu machen wir jetzt einen Bürgerrat. Und die anderen, da lässt man die Politik wieder im Stich. Das wäre schon richtig.
Das ist sehr schön. Man will das jetzt bei diesen Projekten machen und will sich eigentlich damit legitimieren. Man möchte nicht noch mal so ein Fiasco haben wie mit Stuttgart 21. Und dann spielt man ein bisschen Demokratie und sagt, na ja, guckt, ihr habt es doch gewollt. Und ich weiß auch gar nicht, wer soll da jetzt zusammensitzen und entscheiden, ob es ein Opernhaus gibt. Das ist eben eine relativ kleine Gruppe, die sich dafür generell interessiert. Und Opern, darüber kann man auch nicht mehrheitlich abstimmen. Also das ist einfach eine ganz, ganz komische Idee, dass man immer glaubt, dass man dort jetzt mal gucken muss, ob da auch alle dafür sind. Also das ist vollkommen illusorisch. Also das erinnert mich immer so daran an Leute bei Twitter, die auch so ein bisschen aufzeigen jetzt gerade, was sollte man jetzt machen während Corona und was nicht? Und dann spottet man immer so gerne über die Hobbys der anderen. Das merkt man so bei Twitter. Und da muss ich einfach sagen, ne, das kann man halt nicht machen. Also man kann jetzt nicht da alle immer darüber diskutieren lassen, was jetzt gerade sinnvoll ist. Die einen fahren gerne Inlineskates, die anderen essen Eis oder sonst was. Also die Leute wollen ja gar nicht wissen, was ich von irgendwas halte. Und das halte ich auch einfach zurück. Das kann man den Leuten nicht zumuten. Ich kann hier unter uns sagen, ich werde in meinem Leben nie mehr auf ein Fahrrad steigen. Dass sie wissen nicht, was passieren soll, dass das passiert. Aber ich finde es einfach so so so so idiotisch, dass man jetzt glaubt, die stimmen jetzt auch mal ab darüber, ob ein Opernhaus gebaut wird oder saniert wird.
Also wenn man die Details gerade kostenmäßig von Opernhäusern kennen würde und das dann dem Volk zur Abstimmung vorlegt, vielleicht noch mit so einer Auflistung, was man stattdessen kaufen könnte.
Kindergärten und so was.
Kein Opernhaus überleben in Deutschland.
Ganz genau, das hat man ja auch mal in Bonn so gemacht. Das ist also ganz desaströs, wenn man so anfängt. Na ja, jetzt bringt sie hier so ein Beispiel wirklich mal aus der regionalen Ebene. Was kann man dann als Bürgerrat machen? Und ich glaube, so auf einer regionalen oder lokalen Ebene mag es sinnvoll sein, wenn Politiker sich auch ein Rat holen von Leuten, die damit was zu tun haben. Also hier ist ein Beispiel jetzt mal.
Schwarzwald ist es so, da haben wir die Planung der Wege mit der Bevölkerung so gemacht, dass die Landkarten auch virtuell, die wurden alle aufgeschlagen. Und dann ging es darum, hier ist ein alter Weg. Wo muss der jetzt laufen? Oder auch alte Wege, die durch den Nationalpark gehen, bitte entscheidet mit uns, welche können wir zumachen? Das ist ein ganz heikles Thema. Wie schaffst du es, dass deine Bevölkerung mitmacht, alte Wege zu schließen, weil man einen Nationalpark hat? Das haben wir hingekriegt.
Ja, auf der Ebene kann man das machen. Man kann es auch vielleicht lassen, aber hin und wieder wäre es günstig. Ich weiß hier auch um einen Weg für Fußgänger und Fahrradfahrer am Rhein entlang. Da hat sich die Politik nicht beraten lassen oder falsch beraten lassen, zumindest nicht von Bürgern beraten lassen. Und das sieht jetzt so aus, dass man irgendeinen semifesten Kiesweg dort hat, der aber, sobald es einmal geregnet hat, so aufgeschwemmt ist, dass man eine Woche dort nicht hergehen kann, ohne sich die Schuhe einzusauen oder mit dem Fahrrad stecken zu bleiben. Da wäre es wahrscheinlich sinnvoll. Man hätte einfach mal fünf Fahrradfahrer gefragt, was ist denn ein guter Weg für euch? Aber ja, das ist aber auch jetzt auf der ganz kleinen lokalen Ebene. Wir müssen uns das jetzt so vorstellen, also sie redet und redet und redet eine Stunde. Diese jungen Leute sitzen dabei, müssen irgendwie höflichen Gesicht machen, dürfen eine einzige Frage stellen. Und jetzt könnte man sagen, komm denn jetzt, wenn sie nach einer Stunde fertig ist, mal die jungen Leute, denn man darf auch nicht länger machen. Man weiß nie warum, aber es sei dann YouTube sonst voll. Und nein, dann ergreift natürlich nochmal Martin Krat das Wort und fasst jetzt seine Idee von Pürgerath nochmal zusammen und hebt es auf die Unternehmer-Ebene.
Nur, wer es schafft, seine Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiterinnen zu Mitunternehmerinnen und Mitunternehmern zu machen, wird langfristig erfolgreich sein. Das war schon immer meine These. So habe ich übrigens meinen Betrieb geführt, in dem ich immer nur Mitunternehmer hatte und keine Mitarbeiter.
Ja, das ist natürlich reinste Verarsche, denn Mitunternehmer ist man nur, wenn man dann auch wirklich beteiligt ist. Dann ist man mit Eigentümern. Und alles andere ist einfach nur der Versuch, jegliche Kritik und jeglichen Arbeitskampf abzuwürgen. Und diesen Eindruck hat man bei vielen Bürgerräten, dass man sagt, wir nehmen euch mit rein, dann könnt ihr uns auch nicht mehr gefährlich werden.
Diese Idee, Mitarbeiter zu Mitunternehmern zu machen, ist sehr beliebt, auch in DAX-Konzernen. Viele kennen ja, die in so großen Strukturen arbeiten, diese Parallelstruktur zum Management, über Vertrauensleute und Betriebsräte usw. Und die Betriebsräte sind ja in der Pflicht, ihren Mitgliedern zu sagen, was sie so gemacht haben. Also gibt es da immer eine Betriebsversammlung, da hat man dann auch arbeitsfrei in der Zeit, das ist alles geregelt, das muss dann das Unternehmen hinnehmen, dass da einfach ein bisschen Geld verloren geht dafür, dass sich die Belegschaft organisiert. Und sehr viele Unternehmen haben dann einfach gesagt, wir machen jetzt auch einen Mitarbeiter-Tag. Was? Bei der Betriebsversammlung gibt es immer keine Würstchen und es dauert doch alles ewig und ihr müsst da so in den Stuhl reinsitzen usw. Also wenn wir den Mitarbeiter-Tag machen, wird der von Thomas Gottschalk moderiert und dann tritt da irgendwer auf und so. Und das findet ihr natürlich nicht hier im Foyer-Stadt oder so, sondern wir haben natürlich die Stadthalle gemietet. Und so werden auch in Deutschland sehr viele Mitarbeiter zu Mitunternehmern gemacht, die nämlich dann mal so richtig mit dem Chef auch mal ein hartes Wort. Da kommt dann der Chef ohne Krawatte und trinkt nochmal ein Bier mit dir und so. Muss man sich natürlich trauen, mit sich an den Tisch zu stellen. Und diese Ideologie, die da dahinter steckt, ist eben nicht über Eigentumsrecht oder sowas zu machen, sondern wirklich einfach zu sagen, wir spielen es mal. Wir tun so als ob. Wir spielen es jetzt mal vor. Wir schaffen für einen Tag, weil auch der Unternehmer möchte, dass die Mitarbeiter da arbeiten. Mitarbeiten und nicht irgendwas unternehmen. Das ist eine sehr beliebte Taktik, um auch Betriebsräder oder sowas ein bisschen zu delegitimieren. Weil den kann man dann auch terminlich die Woche vorherlegen und dann die Stimmung schon mal anheizen, die Urlaubsregelung ein bisschen anders gestalten, wenn dann die Betriebsratversammlung tagt. Und am Ende entscheidet das Budget darüber, wo mehr Leute hingehen. Also in der Ansicht, gerade in Baden-Württemberg sowas zu hören, wo die Unternehmer schafft nun wirklich sehr gut, es geschafft hat, ihre Belegschaft auszunehmen. Das ist natürlich toll.
Ganz toll und ich habe dann gedacht, jetzt gebe ich es mir mal richtig. Baden-Württemberg hat mir noch nicht gereicht. Ich blicke noch nach Aachen. Also ich dachte, man muss jetzt mal ein bisschen schauen, wo gibt es dann so Bürgerräte? Und Aachen möchte auch einen Bürgerrat haben. Und die hatten dann dort eine unglaublich lange Zoom-Konferenz, die aber sehr professionell aufgezogen war. Viel professioneller als das, was die Bundesregierung bzw. der Bundesbürgerrat auf die Beine gestellt hat. Und da hören wir jetzt, ich glaube, eine SPD oder Grünen-Politikerin, die erstmal sagt, was sie so toll findet am Bürgerrat in Aachen.
Gut gefallen tut mir daran, dass da ein sehr starkes Interesse aus der Bürgerschaft kommt und auch dieses positive Bild, was damit verbunden ist. Also auch so ein Stück gute Laune, sich einzulassen auf einen politischen Diskurs auf Teilhabe in unserer Gesellschaft. Und dieses positive Bild, finde ich, ist für die Partizipation sehr, sehr wichtig.
Ja, neunhundertvierzig Aufrufe, große Beteiligung natürlich. Und na ja, auf lokaler Ebene kann man vielleicht das eine oder andere machen. Aber gibt es ja die Frage, wie ist denn das bei so einem Bürgerrat? Man setzt hier nicht einfach zusammen, sondern da kommen ja auch Experten dazu. Und da wird hier nochmal gesagt von einem, der diese Bürgerräte organisiert und der sich das jetzt auch auf die Fahne geschrieben hat, das verahren tun zu wollen, wie das mit der Auswahl der Experten so gemeint ist.
Menschen eine hohe Neutralität erwarten vom Bürgerrat, dass auf keinen Fall der Eindruck entsteht, es wird etwas gesteuert. Ganz besonders wird immer wieder die Expertenfrage angesprochen. Insbesondere, wie werden die Experten, die letztendlich den Bürgerrat begleiten, ausgewählt? Wissenschaftlich orientiert zu machen. Ganz wichtig, dass dies neutral ist.
Das ist doch eine schöne Idee, die es selbstverständlich nicht geben kann. Das finde ich auch so erstaunlich, dass wenn das Leute sind, die sich mit Bürgerräten schon länger beschäftigen, dass das nicht mitreflektiert wird. Man kann das ja einfach sagen, natürlich gibt es keine Neutralität, aber wir bemühen uns um dies und das, um eine gewisse Vielfalt. Aber diese Idee der Neutralität, und das ist auch, was sonst immer wieder in anderen Bürgerratsdiskussionen aufkommt, ist natürlich eine reine Illusion. Und das ist so diese Illusion wie reine Wissenschaft. Wir haben eine reine Wissenschaft und diese Wissenschaft, die macht dann die Politik. Das wäre doch schön. Dann haben wir mal eine neutrale Politik, nicht immer diese diese Politik, die so verzankt ist miteinander. Und naja, also Neutralität und gute Laune, wie es sich in Aachen gehört, wieder den tierischen Ernst. Und ich wusste auch gar nicht, die Aachener nennen sich wohl nicht Aachener, sondern Öcher. Wusstest du das?
Ne, das heißt Öcher.
Öcher für die Politik. Öcher für die Politik. So jetzt ist da wieder ein Bürgerratsexperte, der sagt jetzt, warum er überhaupt Bürgerräte so wichtig findet. Der hat nämlich Zeitung gelesen.
Ich habe im Grunde genommen über viel Zeitungslesen rausgefunden, dass die Gesellschaft sich immer weiter individualisiert und auch ein Stück weit auseinander lebt dadurch. Und wenn man die Leserbriefe in Zeitungen sieht, dann denkt man, was ist da los? Wo steckt diese Energie im Alltag? Weil da hauen teilweise Menschen mit so einer Kraft aufeinander ein auf das Thema, worum es geht, dass ich mir gedacht habe, das wäre doch mal interessant, diese Energie zu bündeln.
Also das ist an Humor kaum zu überbieten. Üblicherweise sagt man ja, die Leute machen nur noch Twitter und so weiter. Die sollten mal wieder Zeitung lesen, gemeinsam Grund finden. Jetzt stellt er fest, das ist in der Zeitung. Twitter kennt er wahrscheinlich nicht. Der muss ja aus allen Wolken fallen, wenn er da mal weitergeht in die Richtung.
Ja, gegen den Hass. Da sagt der andere Experte, das sei auch für ihn der Antrieb, das zu machen.
Und zwar ist es auch eine Geschichte von Bastian Bärbner. Und zwar hat er von einem Deutschland bekannten Neonazi erzählt. Und zwar ist das Sven Krüger. Ein schwerer Junge, der mehrmals im Knast gesessen hat. Und der hat im Knast als Nazi sich angefreundet mit einem Moslem. Die Frage ist, wie kann das denn sein? Wie kann denn ein Nazi sich im Knast mit einem Moslem anfreunden? Und Sven Krüger, der wirklich überzeugte Nationalsozialist, hat Folgendes geantwortet. Und das ist in einem Chat, in dem Buch zu lesen. Da gibt es einen Podcast zu, der wirklich sehr, sehr hörenswert ist. Sehr, sehr spannend. Und die Aussage war, wenn man sich kennenlernt, kann man sich nicht mehr hassen. Und diese Aussage von jemandem, der aus meiner Sicht auf einer ganz anderen Ebene unterwegs ist, wenn der sagt, wenn ich Leute kennenlerne, kann ich sie nicht mehr hassen, ist das so eine aus meiner Sicht starke Aussage, dass wir sagen, genau das müssen wir institutionalisieren, dass Menschen miteinander ins Gespräch kommen.
Ja, also der Podcast heißt 180 Grad Geschichten gegen den Hass. Da wird diese Irlandsache dargestellt, da wird das dargestellt, was er eben meinte. Ja, genau. Das stimmt, aber man kann ihm einfach sagen, klar, kommen die miteinander, klar, wenn es dann auf persönlicher Ebene hinhaut. Nur wir sehen, in Deutschland haben wir auch eine große Geschichte von Nachbarschaftsstreits, wo es genau nicht funktioniert, dass Leute sich begegnen und darüber dann große Freundschaften herstellen.
Auch Erich Fried hat ja einen Briefwechsel geführt mit einem Neonazi. Und ich bin doch sehr skeptisch gegenüber dieser Form des Dialogs, dass man sagt, da begegnen die sich von Mensch zu Mensch. Und ich dachte im Moment, den Satz, den habe ich aber doch mal noch wo gehört. Und mir war dann klar, ach, das ist ja dieser Sven Krüger, der auch in dieser Doku, die auf Dreisatmat zu sehen war, auftauchte über dieses Nazidorf. Da ist er ja quasi der Oberanführer des Nazidorfs. Und dort geht es dann auch diese Frage des deutsch-iranischen Journalisten Michel Abdullahi. Wie ist denn das, wenn jetzt hier arme Leute kämen mit einem Migrationshintergrund, die wären in Not, dann würdest du doch auch helfen. Und da sagt er diesen Satz wieder.
Mein Problem ist, ich kann ihm nicht alle Ausländer vorstellen, damit er sie nicht hasst.
Genau. Und das ist diese entscheidende Sache. Natürlich funktioniert das dann mal auf der zwischenmenschlichen Ebene kurz. Und ja, es gibt Rechtsradikale, die werden in der Lage sein, noch einen Döner zu bestellen. Da laufen die nicht gleich mit der Waffe immer rein. Aber das bedeutet ja nicht, dass sie dadurch ihren Hass überwinden. Und gerade ist, wenn Krüger ein ganz falscher Fall, also da ist ja nicht, was danach passiert. Das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass er jetzt der große Aussteiger ist. Der war dann mal wieder im Knast, hat dann einen Verlag gegründet. Dort werden große SA-Persönlichkeiten porträtiert in Büchern. Also das ist ja jetzt nicht so eine tolle Erfolgsgeschichte. Also worauf möchte man da hinaus? Was soll dieser Dialog? Und dann sehe ich diese Doku mir nochmal an mit diesem Sven Krüger. Und dann geht es darum, dass man doch dieses Dorf immer wieder verschönert. Und da gibt es so ein Wandbild. Und da überlegt man, ob man da, nachdem man jetzt so ein deutsches Mädel dort gemalt hat, vor einigen Jahren, ob man da nicht mal eine Erneuerung vornehmen will. Und da sagt er Folgendes.
Wir beraten gerade über ein neues Bild. Das ist jetzt, ich glaube, sieben Jahre alt. Oder sechs Jahre alt, weiß ich nicht genau.
Und zwar?
Ist noch nicht abgeschlossen. Bei uns ist das ein Findungsprozess, weil alle Leute haben so eine Idee. Und dann wird das Beste draus gemacht. Bei uns ist direkte Demokratie.
Da steht er drauf irgendwie, ne?
Weil diese jetzt, die andere, die parlamentarische, funktioniert ja gar nicht, denk ich.
Ja, da haben wir es nochmal. Also Vorsicht, Vorsicht mit diesem Demokratiebegriff. Und in Aachen wird nochmal deutlich auch, was du jetzt schon so wunderbar zusammengefasst hast mit dieser Frage. Naja, die Mitunternehmer, Mitarbeiter, was macht man eigentlich da mit den Mitarbeitern? Also nimmt man da nicht eigentlich die Kraft und auch den Arbeitskampf raus aus der Sache? Und hier wird das eigentlich ziemlich klar gesagt, wohin das geht.
Und ich kann demonstrieren gehen, meine Meinung sagen. Ich kann aber auch durch Losverfahren sagen, okay, ich möchte es nicht so aufgeheizt und aufgeladen über eine Demonstration oder über einen Streiks oder was auch immer oder über auf Baum klettern, meine Meinung tun, sondern ich möchte es auch in einer ruhigeren, gesitterteren, sage ich jetzt mal, ohne das jetzt irgendwie werten zu wollen, Runde zu haben. Und dann treffen sich Bürger, die der Souverän sind und diskutieren und einen Vorschlag machen.
Ja, was da immer ausgeblendet wird, ist ja die Machtkonstellation. Also es wird ein bisschen so getan, als seien Streiks und Demonstrationen einfach so da, weil man nicht in der Lage war, einen schönen Artikel in der Zeitung zu schreiben oder sich mal an einen runden Tisch zu setzen. Sondern gerade diese Formen der Machtdemonstration bzw. das Auf-sich-aufmerksam-Machens sind ja entscheidend, damit sich politisch etwas bewegt. Also wenn Fridays for Future von Anfang an gesagt hat, so wir reden jetzt mal mit ein paar Politikern über Klima, gehen aber nie auf die Straße, dann bewirkt man nichts. Also das ist so ein ganz, ganz albernes Verständnis von Demokratie, als würde noch so Wissen fehlen, als hätte man noch nicht den Rat der Bürger geholt. Sonst würde man das ja ganz anders machen, wenn man das schon getan hätte. Nein, gerade bei der CDU-Politik der letzten Jahre kann man das ja sehr gut sehen, was Investitionen anbelangt. Wieder besseres Wissen macht man das, weil man irgendwie glaubt, man unterstützt lieber DAX-Konzerne. Es ist nicht so, dass man sagt, ach ja, stimmt, hätte ich da mal auf ein paar Bürger noch gehört, sondern die wissen an das alles sehr gut, die machen es trotzdem anders.
Ja, es gibt sowieso, wie soll man sagen, es ist ja auch ein bisschen Beschäftigungstherapie. Man will halt was tun, da fragt man sich, wie denn eigentlich? Und dann, wie man es so häufig findet, hat man nicht ganz die Geduld, sich mit der Realität auseinanderzusetzen. Und das steigert sich das manchmal so, dass man beispielsweise bei diesem Sturm auf dem Bundestag damals im August, September, als das war, da haben wir im Fernsehpodcast auch mal drüber gesprochen, es gab dann eine Auseinandersetzung oder ein Gespräch darüber von den Organisatoren mit beispielsweise Jürgen Elsässer und Oliver Janich. Oliver Janich sitzt irgendwo im Ausland, muss ich...
In den Philippinen oder irgendwas, oder?
In den Philippinen oder so absitzen. Und Jürgen Elsässer, das geht ja so als der Hintergrundpublikist der AfD. Und die beiden haben dann auch so überlegt, was machen wir jetzt? Wir haben in Berlin so viele Leute auf die Straße gekriegt und es waren ja Millionen oder mehr Millionen und fast werden die in den Bundestag gerannt und pipapo. Und dann, also es dokumentiert, ja, dass sie, das sind dann so Videos, die gucken dann Hunderttausende bei Samuel Eckert publiziert, wo die darüber reden, ja, jetzt müssen wir den Schwung nutzen und die Leute in eine verfassungsgebende Versammlung organisieren. Mein Vorschlag ist, und ich zitiere jetzt so ein bisschen, also ich rezitiere jetzt so ein bisschen Jürgen Elsässer, der immer so als der kluge Publizist und so weiter geht, der dann Oliver Janich sagt, ne, du musst jetzt den Schwung nutzen, den du hast. Und in jedem Bundesland organisieren sich die Leute und schicken dann so 15 Leute. Und die treffen sich dann in Berlin. Und dann machen die da verfassungsgebende Versammlung. Und wenn die einen Beschluss fassen, dann können wir damit die Bundesregierung übernehmen. Wo man sich denkt, also du willst es in Bundesländer aufteilen und dort sollen repräsentiert für das ganze Bundesland Leute entsandt, also abgeordnet werden nach Berlin und die treffen dann eine Entscheidung. Na ja, haben wir da nicht irgendwie so ein Modell? Ist das nicht das deutsche Verfassungsmodell, mit dem man sich dann auseinandersetzen könnte? Und wir haben ja, und das muss man auch diesen ganzen Baden-Württembergern da sagen, wir haben in Deutschland ein ganz großes Problem, nämlich niemand will mehr auf der kommunalen Ebene Bürgermeister werden. Es mangelt dort an Partizipationen, nicht im Sinne von Partizipationswille, weil man sich irgendein Thema ausgesucht hat und dann gegen irgendeine Stromleitung oder so ist natürlich jeder schnell organisiert. Nur für alles, was ein Bürgermeister abends so mitbringt, da hat dann wieder keiner Lust drauf.
Stadtratssitzungen, also Sachen, hast du Leute, da habe ich früher dann, als man noch in Bars ging, gesprochen, mit 80-Jährigen, die einem sagen, ja, ich will ja eigentlich nicht mehr, aber es ist niemand da, der es macht. Und da haben sie mich nochmal gefragt, ja, aber es ist jetzt wirklich das letzte Mal, weil niemand Junges kommt.
Genau, und wenn die Idee vorherrscht, nee, man will sich nicht in der Parteipolitik verbrennen. Wer einmal so etwas auf kommunalpolitischer Ebene mitgemacht oder nur gesehen hat, weiß, da verbrennt man sich nicht die Finger. Nur weil man bei den Linken, bei den Grünen oder für die CDU da sitzt, da kann man auch genauso parteilos sitzen. Das spielt da alles gar keine Rolle, man muss es nur machen einfach. Und in deren Sicht ist das, und das Wort muss ich dann dafür verwenden, das ist alles Slapstick. Alles, was man dazu sieht, diese ganzen Versuche, dass sich Schäuble nochmal dafür hergibt, der nun weiß, wie man Kalkül ausspielt, im Sinne von auch mal eine Beruhigungspille. Irgendwie, ja gut, dann mach ich halt eure Scheumherrschaft. Eine Stunde BBK überstehe ich auch. Dass man dann irgendwie so sagt, okay, zur allgemeinen Beruhigung. Gerade hier in Baden-Württemberg, er als Baden-Württemberger usw. Und wir kennen ja auch so ein bisschen die Mentalität, wie es in Baden-Württemberg so zugeht. Ja, dass man dann da so einen Weg findet, das irgendwie zu organisieren. Aber es ist Partizipationstheater, wie Dietmar Daert sagte. Das ist einfach Slapstick.
Und wir gucken noch weiter. Jetzt gehen wir auf die ganz große Bühne. Jetzt gehen wir auf die Bundesbühne, also Bürgerrat. Rolle Deutschlands in der Welt, wie sieht sie aus, die Rolle? Wir hören jetzt erstmal, was Claudine Nietz sich davon verspricht. Also hier geht es auch wieder darum, bitte keinen politischen Kampf.
Und ich verstehe vor allem jetzt, was für Dilemma das ist, oft gibt in der Aushandlung von demokratischen politischen Positionen. Und das ist glaube ich tatsächlich wirklich etwas, da entsteht eine Nähe aus der Kluft, aus der Spaltung, ihr da oben, wir da unten, Freund, Feind, sondern da entsteht ein Verständnis füreinander. Und das ist ein Gewinn.
Nein, es gibt widerstreitende Interessen in der Politik. Und das ist nicht eine Frage von einem schönen runden Tisch, sondern Frau Klatten wird immer möglichst viel verdienen wollen und sehen wollen, dass sie möglichst wenig Steuern zahlen, möglichst wenig ihren Angestellten zahlen muss. Und das ist ein Interessenkonflikt, der ist nicht an einem runden Tisch zu lösen, sondern der ist mit Kräfteverhältnissen im Parlament und so weiter mit starken Gewerkschaften, schwachen Gewerkschaften, all das ist entscheidend. Und genauso sieht man ja auch sehr schön jetzt gerade an dieser Initiative, die Bayram angesprochen hat, Deutsche Wohnen und Co. enteignen, was das für ein mühsamer Prozess ist, Leute zu aktivieren und auch dafür deutlich zu machen, was es eigentlich bedeutet, wenn da deutsche Wohnen enteignen wird. Also viele haben dann Angst um ihre Mietshäuser. Also die haben ein Miethaus mit zwei, drei Parteien und denken, oh Gott, verliere ich das jetzt? Nee, wenn man mehr als 3000 Wohnungen hat, dann geht es einem an den Kragen und so. Aber was das für eine Detailarbeit ist, die man da leisten muss, und das hat nichts mit runden Tisch zu tun, da sitzen wir mal alle und reden mal, wie das dann mit den Mieten schön wäre, bald.
Ja, vor allem, du hast ja dieses Gespräch geführt da mit den beiden Vertretern in Wohlstand für alle. Da kommt ja auch der Begriff Blitz her, aus dem Organizing der Blitz. Und man denkt ja immer, Bürgerräte ist so, na, da gehe ich halt hin, dann sitzen wir zusammen und reden halt darüber. Aber Bürgerbeteiligung heißt ja, nee, dann wählen wir uns selber aus als diejenigen, die dann zu den Bürgern hingehen, die also nicht hier im Kreis sitzen und ein Selbstgespräch führen, sondern die klingeln dann im Stock sieben bei Familie Schmidt und versuchen, die dann ein Gespräch zu verwickeln. Und darauf hat niemand von denen Lust, die da jetzt dieses ganze Bürgerräte-Ding irgendwie durchdiskutieren. Wettig, ja. Also da, wenn es um diesen Selektionsprozess geht, ja, wer geht denn jetzt raus und überzeugt die Bürger? Weil wir wollen ja mit den Bürgern, das ist ja Bürgerrat. Ja, dann, nee, dann doch nicht.
Nee, man macht das nämlich anders. Man versendet Driefe übrigens.
Genau, so was.
Es gibt Einladungen und 5% dieser Einladungen werden angenommen. Das habe ich jetzt von mehreren gehört. Also 5% scheint wohl immer so die Quote zu sein. Und jetzt erzählt Clodinit, wie das dann jetzt ist, wie so ein Bürgerrat ausgelost wird.
In einem losbasierten Bürgerrat trifft sich das ganze Land an einem Tisch. Der Querschnitt der Bevölkerung kommt zusammen. Wir haben 169 Bürgerinnen und Bürger bundesweit aus den Einwohnermelderegistern per Zufallsalgorithmus genost. Die Jüngste ist 16, der Älteste ist 90 Jahre alt.
Ja, und dann hat man noch andere Kategorien mit eingeführt, dass man es halbwegs divers hat. Und die haben sich jetzt nun getroffen. Du hast jetzt eben schon das Wort Beschäftigungstherapie gesagt. Und dann denkt man, oh, das ist aber böse. Na ja, wir hören uns jetzt an bei der Präsentation. Das war jetzt die Vorstellung. Bürgerrat kommt jetzt. Im März war die Präsentation. Hier sind die Ergebnisse. Jetzt hören wir uns mal an, wie jetzt dieser Arbeitsprozess gelaufen ist. Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Man hat ja nicht nur Experten, die zu einem sprechen. Maya Göpel waren dabei. Also die Promi-Experten waren natürlich eingeladen. Und jetzt wird aber dann auch gearbeitet miteinander. Das sieht dann so aus.
Für die Ausarbeitung der Leitbilder gab es öfter mal Stillarbeit, welches von wunderschönerm Piano-Musik begleitet wurde. In dieser Stillarbeit sollten die Bürgerräte ihr eigenes Bild von Deutschlands Rolle in der Welt erarbeiten. Dazu haben sie skizzieren können, malen können oder auch einfach Worte aufschreiben.
Wie alt ist dein jüngstes Kind? Und macht das sowas noch oder habt ihr nicht alle?
Mein Kind macht jetzt gerade erzwungener Maßen Stillarbeit, denn diese Woche ist sie wieder zu Hause, die Älteste. Und erzwungener Maßen im Sinne von, ja, das ist eine Schule, die ansonsten auch, es gibt ja kein Frontalunterricht mehr. Das ist immer wieder, in Deutschland ist das noch nicht so durchdrungen. Das glauben immer noch alle, das ist so preußische Schule. Aber nein, die deutschen Schulen sind im Grunde von der Frontalunterricht weg. Und sie würde eigentlich jetzt lieber in Gruppenarbeit das irgendwie machen. Aber nein, es ist für alle Stillarbeit zu Hause angeordnet. Wobei sie mir gerade eine Nachricht schrieb, sie macht sich jetzt Mittagessen. Prima, prima. Aber ja, Stillarbeit ist tatsächlich 6. Klasse.
Super. Und jetzt hören wir uns aber die Ergebnisse an. Jetzt werden einige vorgestellt. Ich habe jetzt mal so einen Auszug. Auch was uns so interessiert, Ökologie. Was ist jetzt dabei rausgekommen?
Ich werde jetzt drei Reisegruppen vorstellen, unter anderem nachhaltige Entwicklung. Deutschland muss sich innerhalb und mit der EU dafür einsetzen, dass die Agrarpolitik durch Achtung und Erhaltung der natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen von Mensch, Tier und Umwelt weltweit unter das Prinzip der Nachhaltigkeit gestellt wird. Dann habe ich noch die Wirtschaft und Handel. Dort haben wir uns eine Empfehlung rausgesucht, die heißt, Deutschland soll sich durch Fairness, Menschenwürde, Transparenz und Nachhaltigkeit im internationalen Handel einsetzen. In der Reisegruppe, in der ich war, das war Frieden und Sicherheit. Friedenssichernde Einsätze sollen gründlich geplant und evaluiert werden. Die Abstimmung zwischen den beteiligten deutschen Ministerien als auch den internationalen Partnern soll verbessert werden.
Jetzt denkt man, dass es eigentlich wie bei einer Fürbitte ist. Wir wissen, sonst werden militärische Interventionen einfach mal so auf Teufelcom rausgemacht. Da geht dann heute Mittag noch irgendein Schießbefehl raus. Aber jetzt soll man doch erst mal ein bisschen sich abstimmen, darüber nachdenken. Es gibt dann noch weitere, da kommt dann ein Herr, der das ähnlich vorstellt. Noch mal ein paar andere Aspekte. Danach dürfen noch mal Politiker darüber diskutieren. Und dann gibt es die AfD, die sagt, dass sie doch eine Sache gut am Bürgerrat findet, dass der Bürgerrat entschieden hat, dass man doch ein bisschen mehr auf Russland zugehen sollte und da nicht zu sehr in so einem starken Kontrast zu stehen sollte.
Es gibt ja zwei Formen des Decessionismus. Also der einfach sagt, die Entscheidung zählt. Das eine ist, diese 100 Jahre alte Idee einfach entscheiden. Egal wer, egal wann, einfach machen, machen, machen, machen. So und dann gibt es halt die andere Seite, die weiß, das ist eigentlich aussichtslos. Eigentlich müssen wir jetzt uns in eine Partei reinwirbeln, dann uns dort an den Widerstanden abarbeiten, dass die nämlich sagen, klar können wir jetzt an dem Tisch hier irgendwie unsere Wünsche aufschreiben, aber am Ende muss das halt eine Mehrheit beim Parteitag finden. Wir haben da genau sieben Minuten Zeit, die Leute zu überzeugen davon und die werden das nicht lesen, das tausendseitige Antragsbuch. Und am Ende ist dann immer noch fragwürdig, wie trägt das unsere Partei dann wirklich in die Parlamente? Und die Fraktionen haben ja eigentlich Mitglieder, die ihrem Gewissen und nicht ihrer Partei verpflichtet sind. Und dann ist es eh die Bundesregierung, die entscheidet, weil wir sind ja Opposition und so weiter. Und das ist ja der eigentliche Weg der Skalierung. Wenn man ein Ziel wirklich umgesetzt haben will, führt da kein Weg dran vorbei. Ansonsten hat man diesen Dezessionismus. Ja, wir haben doch jetzt entschieden, dass wir für Frieden sind an diesem Tisch. Na dann gute Nacht. Und dann verabschieden sich alle und dann war's das. Das ist dann sozusagen die folgenlose Beschäftigung mit einem Thema. Natürlich, man will es ja nicht auch an sich selber verschwenden. Entscheidet man zumindest für sich, also für alle Anwesenden, legt man dann fest, dass man für den Frieden ist und geht. Und dass wir nicht das Problem haben, nicht zu Entscheidungen zu kommen. Also wir haben ja nicht das Problem, zu Entscheidungen zu kommen. Wir wissen ja alle, was gut und richtig und wahr und so weiter ist. Nur die kollektive Bindung ist die Aufgabe der Politik. Das Wissen, also wenn Wissen das Problem wäre, dann können wir es an die Wissenschaft übertragen. Aber die Politik löst eben nicht das Wissensproblem. Alle wissen, wie Lockdown funktioniert. Sondern man muss es eben kollektiv bindend. Und dazu gehört dann auch, wenn man eine kollektive Bindung für eine Entscheidung herstellen will, wie Lockdown, muss man sich auch damit beschäftigen, dass es in Deutschland nur 250.000 Polizisten gibt, von denen man nur zwei Drittel wirklich auf die Straße schicken kann. Und es bleiben trotzdem 80 Millionen Bundesbürger. Also am Ende kommt auf einen Polizisten irgendwie 500 Bundesbürger, die zu überwachen sind bei einem Lockdown, der dann auch wirklich hart ist, also nicht intrinsisch motiviert mitgetragen wird. Aber das kann man alles ausblenden, indem man einfach ans Tisch sitzt und sagt, wir haben es jetzt entschieden, das ist sehr gut. Gleich ist unsere Vorstellungsrunde, dann tragen wir die Themen alle nochmal vor mit unseren Zielen, was wir entschieden haben. Dann applaudieren wir uns alle dafür, dass wir die Guten sind.
Ja, ja, es ist eine sehr schöne Simulation. Aber Marianne Birtler ist auch mit von der Partie gewesen bei diesen Bürgerretten, hat das mit angestoßen, ist jetzt auch bei der Präsentation anwesend von den Grünen, hat ja aus ihrer DDR-Vergangenheit gesagt, jetzt müssen wir nicht nur sagen, wir sind glücklich, dass wir wieder vereinigt sind, dass wir da jetzt eine Demokratie haben, sondern auch an dieser Demokratie muss gearbeitet werden. Deswegen finden sie Bürgerrette natürlich ganz toll. Jetzt hat sie diese Ergebnisse und versucht, das mal einzuordnen. Was macht man jetzt mit diesen Ergebnissen?
Dennoch bleibt das Gefühl, zwar einen Einblick gewonnen zu haben, aber noch lange keinen Überblick über das Thema. Natürlich rechnet jetzt niemand damit, dass die Bundestagsabgeordneten bei der einen oder anderen Empfehlung laut ausrufen, wunderbar, was für eine tolle Idee, warum sind wir da noch nicht draufgekommen. Darum geht es wohl auch nicht. Die Stärke des Gutachtens liegt vielmehr darin, dass es ein Meinungsbild vermittelt.
Ein Meinungsbild, da hätte man aber auch einfach mal Allensbach fragen können, ob die mal Telefonumfrage machen, wie die Leute eigentlich so zum Frieden stehen. Und das ist ja auch allgemein bekannt, dass es eine große Mehrheit gibt, die jetzt, zwar Putin nicht liebt, aber sagt, wir müssen da in irgendeiner Weise kooperativ bleiben, weil wir Angst haben davor, dass es sonst mal krachen könnte. Und dann haben wir das direkt vor der Haustür. Da brauche ich jetzt keinen Bürgerrat. Das ist allgemein bekannt. Aber es sind interessante Fantasien, die da verknüpft sind, was jetzt mit diesem Bürgerrat passiert. Das wie gesagt, so ein paar hundert Aufrufe bei YouTube. Aber Marianne Börtler ist sich da sicher, dass wir das jetzt im Blick behalten werden.
Die Öffentlichkeit wird das hoffentlich genau beobachten.
Ja, das ist der Stolperstein. Es wird sie nicht. Und genau deswegen funktioniert es auch nicht. Man interessiert sich nicht dafür.
Und das Parlament interessiert sich eigentlich auch nicht dafür. Das ist jetzt irgendein SPD-Abgeordneter, ich habe es vergessen, der jetzt nochmal sagt, wie das einzuordnen ist und wie jetzt die Profipolitik auf diese Expertise reagieren soll, dieses Meinungsbild.
Das ist notwendig angesichts der Mühe, angesichts der Vorschläge. Und wenn wir wirklich Bürgerräte und deliberative Demokratie ernst nehmen, dann müssen wir das machen. Ansonsten würden wir zeigen, dass wir es nicht hinreichend ernst nehmen. Deshalb aus meiner Perspektive nachdrücklich die Forderung, dass wir die Ergebnisse einspeisen ins parlamentarische Verfahren und mit einer Debatte und auch Ausschussdebatten auch ein Zeichen des Respekts. Und der Ernsthaftigkeit abgeben.
Ja, aber es soll eigentlich nur noch ein Zeichen abgegeben werden. Es soll also eigentlich jetzt kann man nicht sagen, wir stecken es gleich in die Schublade, aber irgendwas muss man nochmal machen. Irgendein Signal muss gesendet werden, aber mehr dann auch nicht. Und ja, das ist eigentlich ganz deprimierend. Und mich wundert es auch, dass man sich da so lang dran machen kann. Also man sieht dann, da ist die Robert-Bosch-Stiftung ist da mit drin. Und mehr Demokratie und dann die Open Society und all diese ganzen Stiftungen. Und ich glaube, da wird dann ein bisschen Geld mit verdient, dass man dann so Bürgerräte, so ein Theater aufführt. Aber dass man das immer so ernsthaft dann auch vortragen kann, ist eigentlich bewundernswert. Also ich möchte es nicht machen. Das hat so ein bisschen was von den Influencern. Immer wieder selbst überzeugt sein müssen von dem Produkt. Es ist, glaube ich, ziemlich anstrengend.
Also wenn sich jeder ehrlich mit sich selber befasst und sich fragt, wofür interessiere ich mich eigentlich, wenn ich nach Berlin schaue, ins politische Berlin, dann sind es nicht die Themen, nicht die Sachentscheidungen. Denn da könnte man ja wirklich einfach die klugen Bücher dazu nachlesen. Jedes nichtpolitische Sachbuch zu einem Thema ist klüger als das politische Buch oder die politische Auseinandersetzung, das parlamentarische Verfahren, wie auch immer. Wenn man was über Lieferketten lernen will, dann liest man die Bücher der Ökonomen dazu. Und die politische Diskussion spielt dann halt auch eine Rolle, weil man will ja dann mal was vielleicht verändern an der Realität. Aber die Realität, das Wissen, die Fakten, die stecken nicht in der Politik. Und wenn wir vom politischen Fernsehen sprechen, dann geht es doch ehrlicherweise immer nur um eins, und das wird ja auch weiterhin kritisiert, nämlich nur um Machtfragen. Die Grünen zum Beispiel. Solange die Grünen nicht entscheiden, wer von ihnen beiden Kanzlerkandidat wird, sind sie weiter im Gespräch. Weil man sich für diese Frage interessiert. Deswegen ist die SPD gerade nicht im Gespräch. Weil er hat schon entschieden, dass es Olaf Scholz ist. Solange es die CDU noch schafft, es offen zu halten, und da muss sich Laschet jetzt sehr anstrengen, damit es nicht für jeden sichtbar ist, dass es nichts wird. Solange es Laschet noch schafft, auch neben Söder noch Kandidatenkandidat zu sein, so lange bleiben die auch Thema. Und sobald leichte Verbesserungen in der Corona-Lage sind, weil so ein Lockdown dann vielleicht mal Ende April irgendwie so ein bisschen wirkt, oder die Impfungen so weit fortgeschritten sind, dass es im Gesundheitssystem nicht mehr zu allen großen Problemen, dann ist das Thema sofort zurück. Dann ist die erste Frage an Laschet wieder, wann verkünden sie es, wollen sie noch? Dann wird analysiert, hat er noch den Biss in der Phoenix-Runde, wurde jetzt schon diskutiert. Die Biografin von Söder sagt, es wird wahrscheinlich Söder, denn ich habe vor zwei Wochen gesehen bei Instagram, wie er sich einen Hund angeschafft hat, der mit ihm in die Kamera licheln kann. Also es sind die Machtfragen in der Politik. Und um diese Machtfragen schlängelt sich dieser Bürgerrad drumrum. Ich kriege das jetzt hier selber mit bei der Frage, in meinem Stadtviertel gibt es so ein paar Probleme mit dem Verkehr, keine großen gravierenden, wenn man sich Berliner Fahrradprobleme anguckt. Aber den einen oder anderen Schulwegabschnitt möge man doch mal ein bisschen anders regeln. Was klärt man also in so einer Bürgerinitiative? Natürlich nicht das Verkehrskonzept die ganze Zeit. Das hat man ja einmal entwickelt und dann will man das durchboxen. Man klärt die Frage, was bedeuten jetzt die Kommunalwahlen? Wen müssen wir jetzt hier im Ortsbeirat ansprechen? Man geht hin, wo die Macht ist und guckt, wie man da sich einbringen kann. Diese Bürgerräte haben alle, und da haben wir ganz häufig diese Phänomene, wir kommen auch gleich auf so ein Megathema, das genau darunter leidet, vielleicht auch nicht, dass man sagt, es ist der erste Aufschlag. Die Pionierarbeit, die rüttelt alle durch. Schon beim zweiten Mal, beim dritten Mal langweilig, beim vierten Mal ach, fand statt, beim fünften Mal, es interessiert mich nicht. Also bei NFTs zum Beispiel. Man kann einmal ein Kunstwerk für 69 Millionen verkaufen, ob es das nächste Jahr noch mal so gibt, wenn dann die Welle durchgelaufen ist. Verschlüsselungsdateien sind eigentlich von Datenmüll nicht zu unterscheiden.
Und ich will auch hoffen, dass wir über Bürgerräte hier nicht mehr sprechen müssen. Ich habe das hier nur einmal der Chronistenpflicht halber getan.
Genau, man kann das einmal machen in Irland, man kann das einmal machen als EU-Beiratskonvent, wie auch immer. Diese Art von Motivation und Organisationspower, die ja da ohne Zweifel drinsteckt, mal kurz abzukrasen. Oder, und das fand ich nämlich sehr gut, Annalena Baerbock hat einmal auch kurz über Bürgerräte gesprochen in ihrer Programmvorstellung. Und diese halbe Minute hören wir uns mal kurz an, denn sie hatten ein ganz besonderes Modell für Bürgerräte.
Dann kann es auch sein, dass man feststellt auf dem Weg des Aufbruchs, Mensch, wir hätten es noch besser machen können, wenn wir diese eine Maßnahme noch ein bisschen mehr angeschärft hätten. Und daher ist für uns ein zukunftsfähiges Regieren, ein modernes Regieren auch immer die Bereitschaft, selbstkritisch zu reflektieren. War das jetzt das Allerbeste? Hätten wir es auch anders machen können, deswegen laden wir ein, unterschiedliche Akteure, zum Beispiel über Formen wie Bürgerräte, an diesem Prozess mitzumachen und haben eine Bereitschaft, immer wieder auch zu sagen, der andere könnte vielleicht auch mal Recht haben.
Was hat sie hier vorgestellt? Das ist diese europäische Erfahrung. Dass man nämlich sagt, wir an der Politik, wir entscheiden erstmal. Und wenn dann Enttäuschung aufkommt, dann kanalisieren wir sie. Also dann gibt es Ausschusssitzungen, in denen dann Vertreter von Bürgerräten tatsächlich vor Ort sind. Weil dann kann man den Bürgerräten auch sagen, hört mal zu, wir haben ja eigentlich schon entschieden und die Budgets sind schon verteilt, aber wir sind durchaus revisionsfähig, wenn denn die Gründe trifftig sind. Und dann beteiligt man die Bürger im Sinne von, ihr könnt bei der Revision mithelfen. Das ist ein ganz konkretes Ziel. Man hat einen ganz konkreten Ansprechpartner, eine Adresse, nämlich in dem Fall die Bundesregierung, die dann einfach sagt, ach so, bei dem Thema gab es so viel Ärger, dann müssen wir hier mal Plan B nochmal durchlaufen lassen mit Bürgerräten. Und so wie die Ausschusssitzung im Vorfeld ganz abgeschottet, jeder macht es für sich, jeder lädt seine Experten ein, es interessiert niemanden, es wird zwar live übertragen, aber es gucken dann wirklich Leute bei Phoenix auf der Webseite oder so. Ja, aber wenn es schief geht, als Korrektiv, dann kann man die Bürgerräte reinholen und dann ist aber klar, erstens, wen kann man hier erreichen und zweitens, womit? Und damit muss ich die Bürger, also daran kann die Bürgerinitiative, die Bürgerräte selber scheitern. Ja, dass sie einfach sozusagen vorbei an dem wissenschaftlichen Prozess, der zu dieser Entscheidung führte, irgendwas, ja, da kann man dann nicht mehr den Großen wünschen, da muss dann Realismus zählen und in deren Sicht, wer weiß, scheint das mir hier eine gute Idee zu sein, aber dieses einfach mal, weil es offen ist, weil es nicht die schmutzige Politik ist und so weiter, Bürgerräte veranstalten, das ist dann, also da kann man auch einfach sagen, macht man halt eine Yoga-Stunde und redet da halt danach noch über Politik oder so.
Ganz genau, und das findet ja im privaten Kreise auch statt. Genau. Deswegen schauen wir noch einmal auf die richtig schmutzige Politik und da habe ich jetzt mal ganz beispielhaft etwas rausgesucht von Böhmermann. Böhmermann hat ja sich viel stärker politisiert, macht eigentlich jetzt ein fast journalistisches Format mit Comedy-Elementen und er nimmt sich dann pro Sendung immer so ein Thema vor. Und hier geht es darum, wie war denn das eigentlich? Warum konnten die Fußballer so schnell wieder spielen, wo alle noch im Lockdown saßen, war da doch sehr schnell eine Entscheidung gefallen. Und er vollzieht das jetzt mal ein bisschen nach und hatte auch schon mal den Eid-al-Alinen oder anderen Ausschnitt aus der Springer-Bildzeitungs-Doku von Amazon mit dabei und hat das alles mal so ausgewertet und kommt da zu einem interessanten Schluss. Also jedenfalls wurde da glaube ich kein Bürgerrat gefragt.
Aber wenn der DFL-Chef Profifußball mit der Autoindustrie oder der Lufthansa vergleicht, dann ist das schon ein kleines bisschen...
Arrogan.
Denn die deutsche Autoindustrie hatte vor der Pandemie einen jährlichen Umsatz von 436 Milliarden Euro. Lufthansa allein 36 Milliarden. Die DFL liegt gerade mal bei 4, 8 Milliarden Euro. Und klar, man kann jetzt sagen, aber der Fußball ist so viel mehr als ein Geschäft. Der ist Kultur, der bereitet uns ein wenig Freude in der Pandemie. Spielt Profifußball dann nicht eher wirtschaftlich in der Liga mit Theater- oder Konzertveranstaltern? Nein, denn deutsche Theater- und Konzertveranstalter hatten vor Corona einen Jahresumsatz von etwa 9 Milliarden Euro. Knapp doppelt so viel wie der Profifußball. Aber trotzdem sind die Kinos, Theater- und Konzertsäle zu.
Ja, die deutschen Theater müssten ihre Assembles wie in einer Liga organisieren, den Dachverband dann auch entsprechend gründen und ihn mit politischer Key-Account-Management-Position ausstatten, der in Berlin vorstellig wird. Und dann wäre das auch gelungen, glaube ich.
Und jetzt strampelt jeder Intern dann für sich so ein bisschen rum, muss sich irgendwie auch mit der Stadt gut halten und im Fernsehen vertreten, ist dann nur jemand, der gar nicht zum richtigen Stadttheaterbetrieb gehört, nämlich Dieter Hallervorn als Intendanten. Und der wird auch nur deshalb genommen, weil wir noch sagen, Pallim, Pallim. Den können wir noch aus anderen Zulammen hängen.
Bekannt aus Ruck und Fernsehen.
Ja, aber auffällig, beim Fußball ging das alles ratzfatz. Warum denn nur?
Im deutschen Profifußball sitzt die BILD-Zeitung nicht auf der Pressetribüne, steht auch nicht an der Seitenlinie, sondern spielt mit auf dem Feld.
Da hatte ich schon das Gefühl, dass das ein historischer Moment war, als wir Gesundheitsminister Jens Spahn, die Chefs der Vereine Borussia Dortmund und Bayern München zu einem Hintergrundgespräch hier in den Verlag eingeladen haben.
Ah, so, so. Also nicht die DFL-Zentrale von Bundesligaretta Christian Seifert, sondern quasi neutrales Terrain bei der BILD-Zeitung. Politik und Wirtschaft verhandeln Sonderregeln für Deutschlands nervigste Lobbygruppe in den Räumlichkeiten von BILD. Und keine Journalisten weit und breit, die darüber berichten könnten.
BILD am Sonntag besteht zu über der Hälfte aus Fußball.
Und hier ist wirklich mal das Hinterzimmer. Und dann hat Böhmermann mal nachfragen lassen, wie ist denn das, haben die sich da bei BILD getroffen? Weil das wurde ja dann unwesentlich später veröffentlicht, dass das nun jetzt wieder möglich ist mit den Spielen. Und ein paar Tage vorher waren wir noch bei BILD.
Sechs Tage nach diesem Jahr, was ist es denn jetzt? Redaktionelles Vorgespräch, Geschäftsessen, Geheimgipfel, Lobbyisten-Meeting bei BILD. Dann der überraschende Durchbruch. Die Ministerpräsidenten von Bayern München und Borussia Dortmund verkünden am 20. April, an Führers Geburtstag, exklusiv bei BILD live dem offenen Kanal des Axel-Springer-Verlages Deutschland darf wieder schießen. Wir haben mal nachgefragt. Bei BILD, in den Staatskanzleien von NRW und Bayern, bei der DFL und im Bundesgesundheitsministerium haben die beiden reichsten Bundesliga-Vereine BVB und FCB, der Bundesgesundheitsminister und BILD, gemeinsam unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit die Fortsetzung der Bundesliga organisiert?
Herr Ministerpräsident Dr. Söder hat am 20. April 2020 auf Anfrage von BILD live ein Interview gegeben. Im Vorfeld dazu fand, wie bei verschiedenen Medien üblich, ein redaktionelles Vorgespräch statt.
So, so, ein redaktionelles Vorgespräch. Und bei Armin Laschet auch, ja?
Ministerpräsident Armin Laschet hat BILD live, wie in ihrer Anfrage erwähnt, am 20. April 2020 ein Interview gegeben und ist damit eine Anfrage des Mediums einschließlich der Bitte um ein redaktionelles Vorgespräch nachgekommen.
Ja, in dieser Video gibt es natürlich kein redaktionelles Vorgespräch, sondern die sagen einfach, ich gebe ein Interview und dann geben die das Interview und man weiß selbstverständlich, was da eigentlich bei diesem redaktionellen Vorgespräch gelaufen ist. Und das sollten sich die Bürgerräte vielleicht mal komplett ansehen, diese Böhmermann-Geschichte und dann mal darüber nachdenken, ob sie da so weiterkommen mit ihrem Politikverständnis. Ich würde sagen nein. Und da kann man sehen, wo es eigentlich im Argen liegt.
Wer fällt alles hinten runter, wenn Corona-Politik gemacht wird, wie beim Fußball beispielsweise? Beim Fußball haben wir ausschließlich reiche Leute, das sagen, auf dem Feld, abseits des Feldes. Und dann haben relativ zügig die nicht so reichen im Publikum festgestellt, wir werden im Stadion ja gar nicht benötigt. Sondern es ist ja das Fernsehpublikum. Das Fernsehpublikum hält automatisch Abstand. Da werden Corona-Regeln eingehalten. Beziehungsweise, und das ist ja auch mal so ein Punkt, den man sich mal wieder anschauen muss, ist eigentlich der Fußball dafür verantwortlich, wie auf der anderen Seite des Kabels ferngesehen wird. Also wenn es heißt, bitte keine Versammlung im privaten Bereich. Und dann ist aber plötzlich ein Fußballspiel und die Leute treffen sich natürlich zum Fußballschauen. Wer trägt dann dafür eigentlich die Verantwortung? Oder kann man die Motivation eigentlich irgendwie mit einkalkulieren? Denn politische Kalküle, die man auch hat, sind ja alles so Fragen. Und dann gibt es eine Gruppe, die findet so gar nicht statt. Gar nicht. Und es ist ganz erstaunlich, wenn man beim RKI selber nachliest, kann man vielleicht, also so als Frage formuliert, gibt es vielleicht einen Zusammenhang zwischen, wie wohnen Menschen, wenn sie sich infizieren? Das kennen wir ja von der Arbeit. Die reichen Leute, die Vermögenden schaffen es natürlich alles, den ganzen Service an ihrer Wohnungstür entgegenzunehmen. Also da wird geliefert von Amazon, von Lieferando, von wem auch immer.
Gorilla-App, das habe ich jetzt gehört, das wird jetzt in Berlin-Mitte dann gerne verwendet. Das ist so eine App, da kann man dann irgendwelche armen Studenten los schicken, die bringen dir innerhalb von 10 Minuten deine Einkäufe. Ich finde das ja immer so ein bisschen würdelos, als wenn man, ich kenne ja Leute, die das machen, die auch Geld haben, also die reich sind in Berlin und die das dann machen, das finde ich halt ein bisschen nivellos. Also ich finde, wenn man, wenn man vermögend ist und man hat kein Bock mehr einzukaufen, dann soll man sich eine Haus, eine Haushaltshilfe nehmen und die ordentlich bezahlen und die geht dann auch für einen einkaufen. Aber dass man irgendwelche Leute da sich kaputt tremeln lässt, damit man irgendwie billig an die Einkäufe kommt, das ist schon ein bisschen sehr nivellos.
Genau, also da gibt es auf jeden Fall, sieht man so angelegt, Menschen müssen sozusagen entschieden sein. Ich schütze mich jetzt vor der Gesellschaft, die so infektiös ist und ich mache das über den Weg, der mir ermöglicht wird, durch Geld, das mir zur Verfügung steht, um ein Mittagessen für 10 Euro an meine Zimmertür liefern zu lassen oder eben sowieso alles zu bestellen. Während, da hat ja Sarah Wagenknecht darauf hingewiesen, klar, wir gehen jetzt nicht mehr in den Laden und infizieren uns dort. Dafür infizieren sich die Amazon-Mitarbeiter untereinander, weil die halt das erledigen müssen, dass es dann auch wirklich bei uns ankommt. Und erstaunlicherweise gibt es in Deutschland überhaupt eine Diskussion, so gar nicht, obwohl das RKI einmal darauf hinwies, und ich lese jetzt von der RKI-Webseite, also von Robert Koch-Institut selbst, Überschrift, soziale Unterschiede in der Covid-19 Sterblichkeit während der zweiten Infektionswelle in Deutschland, also die Weihnachtswelle November bis Januar, wie sie gedauert hat. Kernaussagen, und es sind alles Zitate vom RKI, während der zweiten Infektionswelle im Herbst und Winter 2021 stieg die Covid-19 Sterblichkeit in Deutschland stark an und erreichte im Dezember und Januar einen Höchststand. Nach den Meldungen der Gesundheitsämter sind im Dezember und Januar mehr als 42.000 Personen, bei denen Covid-19 festgestellt wurde, verstorben. Davon waren etwa 90 Prozent im Alter von 70 Jahren und älter, also das kennen wir, das Altersding. Der Anstieg der Covid-19-Todesfälle fiel in sozial benachteiligten Regionen Deutschlands am stärksten aus, sowohl bei Männern als auch bei Frauen. Im Dezember und Januar lag die Covid-19-Sterblichkeit in sozial stark benachteiligten Regionen um rund 50 bis 70 Prozent höher als in Regionen mit geringer sozialer Benachteiligung. Das ist also der ganz normale Vergleich. Hier in Frankfurt wäre das Westend und dann halt die Wohnsiedlungen, keine Ahnung wie sie heißen, wo die dreizehnstöckigen Häuser stehen und migrantische Familien auf viel zu engen Raum und so weiter miteinander leben. Und wir haben uns immer diese Prozentzahlen. Die britische Variante ist 50 Prozent ansteckender. Ja, Armut macht Corona auch 50 Prozent ansteckender, wie wir hier sehen.
Das sind dann die Leute, die dann aus diesen engen Verhältnissen mal rausgehen, irgendwo im Park sitzen und dann von irgendwelchen Journalisten noch abfotografiert werden und bei Twitter ausgestellt werden. Guckt mal hier, da tummen sie sich wieder alle. Wo man dann sagen kann, ja, wenn ich natürlich einen riesengroßen Garten habe, am besten noch mit Pool, dann würde ich auch in keinen Park mehr gehen.
Genau, die Grillparty im Garten kann nicht unterbunden werden, war sie nie, egal was, Lockdown und so weiter, das ist Garten. Klar, die berufliche Dimension gibt es noch dazu, dass einfach in Unternehmen sowieso stattfindet, was stattfindet. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, was bedeutet jetzt benachteiligte Region? Also das RKI bezieht sich hier selbst auf den German Index of Socio-Economic Deprivation, also Deprivation, das heißt ja schon, dir fehlt irgendwas, sozio-ögonomischer Mangel. Und das ist ein Datenbestand, der die 401 Landkreise und kreisfreien Städte in Deutschland verknüpft. Und zwar die sozio-ögonomische Deprivation der Bevölkerung in diesen Regionen wird von diesem GISD ermittelt. Und der wurde dann von RKI mit dem Corona-Infektionszahlen einfach mal gemapt. Und da wurde geschaut, wo infizieren sich denn die Leute? Und da stellt man fest, ach so, in diesen Regionen, die von diesem GISD als sozio-ögonomisch schwach dargestellt werden, wo also Leute auf zu engem Raum wohnen, wo sie an Arbeitsstellen zu tun haben, dieser ganze Servicebereich und so weiter, wo es kein Homeoffice gibt und wo man Schulter an Schulter arbeitet, wo zwar nochmal arbeitsrechtlich gesagt werden kann, aber setz bitte eine Maske auf und dann weiß man, der Chef guckt da eh nicht hin. Also steht man nebeneinander. Also der typische Fall ist, glaube ich, das Wohnhaus in Göttingen damals, was sehr für, als nirgendwo Corona gab, da war plötzlich dieses Göttinger Wohnhaus oder die Arbeitszusammenhänge bei Tönnies. Wir wissen, auch die Wohnensituation dort war schwierig, aber die war nicht ausschlaggebend, wie die Studien später zeigten, sondern es war dieses Arbeiten zu Tausenden in den Kantinen setzen, die ganze Zeit bei 5 Grad, keiner kümmert sich um, also Luftzirkulation, ja, aber nicht um Luftaustausch und so weiter, und die Viren gehen einfach durch, sodass da 1900 Leute auf einmal infiziert sind und so weiter. So, und das gibt es nur in, also das hat mit Armut, das korreliert einfach eins zu eins mit Armut. Das im Homeoffice bei dem Lieferdienst, der nur noch mit Maske in der Hand das Ding auf die Stufe stellt und dann zurücktritt, der infiziert dich nicht. So, und diesen Weg wurde in Deutschland nie nachgegangen, als hätte man Angst vor diesem Thema, als wollte man sich damit nicht beschäftigen, als wäre das so, ach nee, die Arme wieder, haben uns schon bisher nicht interessiert, können uns jetzt auch nicht interessieren. Man kann ja mal vergleichen, so bei Twitter, wenn man die Appelle liest, wer gibt die Appelle ab, an wen richten sie sich und mit welchem inhaltlichen Duktus werden die so gemacht.
Das sind Leute, die halt morgen wieder in irgendeiner Talkshow rumsitzen oder irgendeinen Spotify-Podcast einsprechen, den keiner braucht.
Ganz klassische Klientel, von der wir wissen. Und jetzt gehen wir deswegen kurz nach England in Sheffield. Sheffield ist eine ganz normale britische Stadt. Und da würde ich sagen, wenn man sich die Zahlen anguckt, die das RKI hier ermittelt hat anhand des sozioökonomischen Zusammenhangs, gilt das für, was für Sheffield jetzt gilt, beispielsweise für alle Großstädte in Nordrhein-Westfalen. In Bayern vielleicht nicht so sehr, aber in Nordrhein-Westfalen. Also, Sheffield ist jetzt hier Schiffre für die großen Städte in Nordrhein-Westfalen.
So, wir sehen jetzt hier eine Karte von Sheffield.
Da werden gleich in roten und in weißen Punkten Corona-Fälle aufgezeigt. Und die roten sind die aktiven. Und es gibt einen Zeitverlauf, da taucht gleich ein ganz kleiner Kreis aus. Du beschreibst uns gleich, wie klein dieser Kreis ist. Das sind die Armviertel von Sheffield. Und die Punkteentwicklung stellst du uns gleich mal da.
Ja, dieser Kreis ist sehr klein. Ja, wir haben da nur ein Bruchteil von der Karte.
Fünf Prozent der Stadt ungefähr.
Vielleicht fünf Prozent, ja. Und dann sehen wir ja, es gibt auch drum herum Fälle, aber richtig rot wird es in diesem Kreis. Und in diesem Kreis ist man nicht wohlhabend.
Genau, es gibt diese Logik 80-20, irgendwann treten 20 Prozent der Corona-Fälle oder 80 Prozent der Corona-Fälle nur noch in 20 Prozent der Population auf. Und es ist wirklich erschreckend. Am Anfang ist Corona überall. Dann lernt man dazu und weiß, wie man sich schützen kann. Und dann in der zweiten Welle kristallisiert sich raus, wer sich nicht schützen kann, obwohl er eigentlich es besser weiß. Weil er in ökonomischen Zusammenhängen ist oder in Wohn-Zusammenhängen, wie auch immer, wo man einfach nicht rauskommt.
Oder auch keine häusliche Quarantäne machen. Ich hatte mit einem Paar kürzlich gesprochen, da hatte der eine Corona, der andere nicht. Und die wohnen in einer entsprechend großen Wohnung. Und da hat sie andere auch nicht bekommen dadurch. Denn man kann sich dann voneinander ganz gut abschotten. Das kann man nicht, wenn man in einer Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung lebt.
Genau. Corona ist auch in Deutschland eine Unterschichtenkrankheit geworden. Das korreliert hier extrem stark mit dem sozioökonomischen Status. Und es sind unüberwindbare Zwänge. Also wenn hier nicht der Befehl von Merkel kommt, die Bildtriebe stehen still, sind diese Corona-Fälle nicht zu vermeiden. Ja, es gibt immer noch diesen großen, auch privaten Bereich. Aber das hängt alles miteinander zusammen. Zu wenig Wohnraum, ungünstige Arbeitsbedingungen und so weiter. Die fördern Corona und die hängen einfach mit dieser sozioökonomischen Zusammenhängen zusammen. In England ist es natürlich noch mal krasser, weil wir da einfach eine andere soziale Lage haben. Aber jetzt kann man ja überlegen, wie weit sind wir davon eigentlich entfernt? Hier wird mal der an den sozioökonomischen Zustand angekoppelte Gesundheitszustand kurz dargelegt. Und zwar sozusagen auch prä-Corona.
Die Daten von Covid-Infektionen sind bereits auf die Existenz der Gesundheitsunrequalität in der Stadt gesetzt. Die Unterschiede in der gesundheitlichen Lebenswahrung kann so viel wie 20 Jahre sein.
Also 20 Jahre unterscheidet sich die Lebenserwartung schon allein durch den sozioökonomischen Unterschied. Und dann schlägt Corona noch mal zu, mit dieser extremen hohen Sterblichkeit.
Ich muss auch gerade dran denken, dass man sich sträubt, Hartz-IV-Empfängern Masken zu zahlen oder überhaupt Leuten, die Geringverdiener sind, Masken zu zahlen. Man sagt, na ja, aber die können ja auch dann mit der OP-Maske, das würde ja dann auch reichen statt mit einer FFP2-Maske. Und auch bei den FFP2-Masken gibt es ja Unterschiede. Eigentlich müssten die Leute, die wirklich an der Front sind, und anders kann man das ja nicht bezeichnen, auch die besten FFP2-Masken gestellt bekommen. Ich habe mir jetzt mal was gegönnt, nachdem ich sie bei Lauterbach und Joe Biden gesehen habe, nämlich Masken von 3M. Und wenn man diese FFP2-Masken anhat, dann denkt man, das ist ein ganz neues Lebensgefühl. Die sind so wunderbar dicht, da verrutscht auch gar nie irgendetwas. Und du kannst fast eins zu eins so atmen, als hättest du keine auf. Und das wäre eigentlich die Maske, die Leute brauchen, die wirklich am Arbeiten sind. Aber nein, die, wenn sie überhaupt eine FFP2-Maske bekommen, bekommen sie eine ziemlich schlechte und die drückt die ganze Zeit. Und ja, dann ist die mal schnell gelockert, gelöst und all das und schon ist ein Fall produziert wieder.
Genau, die Abhilfe ist so wahnsinnig einfach. Man braucht einfach nur eine ordentliche Maske. Und ich lese mal hier kurz SWR.de. SWR, das ist ja so deine Ecke da.
Ja, mein Sendegebiet.
Der Südwesten. Also wie geht es zu im Südwesten? Das Sozialgericht Speyer hat den Eilantrag eines Hartz-IV-Empfängers abgewiesen. Dieser hatte höhere Leistungen verlangt, da er mehr Ausgaben für Corona-Schutzmasken habe. Es sei dem Antragssteller zuzumuten, diese Kosten aus dem Hartz-IV-Regelsatz zu bestreiten, zumal die Menschen wegen Corona-Pandemie derzeit weniger Ausgaben hätten für Freizeitunterhaltung und Kultur. Dieser Beschluss des Sozialgerichts Speyer ist unanfechtbar. So lässt sich kein Corona besiegen. Und das ist auch die große Lehre in England.
Wenn man das nicht in eine Petition schreibt, dann kann man sich die Petition auch gleich übers Klo hängen.
Schenkt den Leuten die guten FFP2-Masken und gestaltet darum noch eine Kultur des Maskentragens, so dass sich niemand für blöd oder so blöd vorkommt, wenn er so eine Maske auf hat. Sondern die muss einfach getragen werden. Wir kennen alle noch früher, ja, wie lernt man Zähne putzen? Da kommt in die Schule so der Zahnarzt, der bringt dann diesen komischen Farbstift mit und zeigt dann, so sehen deine Zähne aus, wenn du sie geputzt hast, jetzt putzt man mal richtig. Und so muss man das hier auch mal machen. Man muss sich jetzt mal was einfallen lassen, denn Corona bleibt ja noch eine Weile, dass man diese Betriebe, die man nicht stilllegen will, wo Merkel und das war die, also das, was Merkel entschieden hat für den Donnerstag, wäre die richtige Entscheidung für zwei Wochen gewesen. Und sie konnte nicht mal einen Tag durchsetzen wegen des Widerstands aus der Wirtschaft. Und genau darum geht es, dass in dieser Wirtschaft, wenn denn schon gearbeitet wird, ordentlich gearbeitet wird. Die Masken müssen kostenlos sein, der Schnelltest muss kostenlos sein, der muss morgens vor deiner Haustür liegen, der darf dich nicht kognitiv belasten. Schon allein die Planung, wo gehe ich mir meinen kostenlosen Test abholen und der ganze Quatsch. Nein, das muss am Ende, wie in Schleswig-Holstein oder da in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, Briefkassen auf, drei Masken rein, Briefkassen zu, dann geht man zur nächsten. Die müssen, also diese Art von Verfügbarkeit ist notwendig, um diese vulnerablen Gruppen, hier die sozioökonomischen, die das Land am Laufen halten, weswegen es diesen Lockdown für die niemals gibt. Selbst wenn wir jetzt entscheiden, wir machen hier den totalen Lockdown, ja, es wird keinen Supermarkt-Lockdown geben und die Amazon-Dinger werden weiter betrieben und diese ganze Verpackung und der ganze Kram und es wird auch weiter Eis hergestellt in Deutschland und so weiter. Diese Lockdowns wird es in dieser Art nicht geben und deswegen brauchen wir hier andere Hilfen. Wir müssen dieses Abwasserscreen, wir brauchen diese Masken kostenlos und der ganze Kram. Und das einzige Mal, dass wir jetzt einen deutschen Politiker zum Thema soziale Unterschiede hören, ist Karl Lauterbach bei Lanz am 24.3. allerdings so ein bisschen verschätzt in der regionalen Dimension.
Die Leute haben da nicht den Platz, sie haben nicht die Masken. Nur den Einsatz, also die Aharl-Regeln spielen in ärmeren Ländern keine Rolle. Die können die nicht umsetzen, die leben auf engstem Raum, kriege ich das nicht wieder.
Ärmere Länder.
Ja, in der Kölner Eigentumswohnung geht es natürlich noch relativ gut mit den AHA-Regeln. Ja, was soll man dazu sagen? Das ist halt auch ein Politiker, der die Armut in Deutschland 20 Jahre lang geleugnet hat. Und wir haben eine Kanzlerin der sozialen Kälte, die jetzt eigentlich noch mal Bestätigung findet, indem man sagt, toll, jetzt hat sie es aber mal Laschet gezeigt. Und wenn wir sie jetzt noch mit einer Petition unterstützen, dann kann sie noch mal hier.
Ja, also wir haben hier ein echtes Problem mit Armut in Deutschland. Corona zeigt es uns auf. Wir wollen es nicht wahrhaben. Niemand thematisiert es. Und Karl-Alderbach, wenn er über Armut spricht, dann sind es die armen Länder, wo plötzlich Aha-Regeln nicht gelten. Ja, in Göttinger Wohnhäusern, hier in Frankfurt am Main, gibt es diese Gegenden, wo das nicht klappt. In Koblenz auch, in Berlin hat man es doch wirklich von der Nase. Aber irgendwie will man es nicht wahrhaben und nicht thematisieren. Und naja, deswegen müssen wir jetzt alle wieder Lockdown machen. Und er wird nichts bringen und er wird wieder zur Enttäuschung auf Twitter führen. Und die Realität wird dann wieder keine Rolle spielen. Aber es ist, wie es ist. Man kann es nur noch zynisch beobachten. Gut, kommen wir mal in, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das nennt, NFTs und sowas, ja. Blockchain. Was haben wir alle gelacht über die Blockchain-Lösung, die jetzt vorgestellt wird, um einen Impfstatus zum Beispiel darzustellen und überprüfbar zu machen. Die Europäische Union ist ja ganz interessiert daran, den Immunisierungszustand der Bevölkerung zu dokumentieren und nutzbar zu machen. Und es gibt zwei Prämissen, gegen die nicht hinderschritten wird, finde ich auch gut. Zum einen, es muss digital sein. Ja, zwingend finde ich. Wir können nicht immer nur von Digitalisierung träumen. Wir brauchen es dann mal, wenn wir es richtig haben. Also es muss digital sein. Smartphone oder wie auch immer. Es heißt nicht zwingend Smartphone. Man kann auch die Geräte, die man dann dafür braucht, die zum Beispiel ein Signal senden, die kann man auch einfach den Leuten dann schenken, wenn sie kein Smartphone haben. Aber es muss digital sein. Und zweitens, man darf nicht unterscheiden zwischen Immunisierung oder nicht infektiös durch echte Immunisierung, sei es durch Impfung oder durchgemachte Corona Krankheit und negativen Antigen-Tests, der auch zeigt, dass man nicht infektiös ist. Zwar nur für eine begrenzte Zeit, aber das ist sozusagen das Schwierigkeitsprofil, die Herausforderung. Eine Immunisierung oder eine Nicht-Infektiosität darstellen, die zum einen zeitlich begrenzt ist, zum anderen persönliche Daten, Gesundheitsdaten zu verarbeiten hat und so weiter. Und jetzt irgendwie digital, das lachen alle über Blockchain. Und auf der anderen Seite, das was du uns dann gleich zeigen, ist der Kunstmarkt jetzt aufgerüttelt worden von Blockchain. Menschen sind tatsächlich zum drittvermögensten lebendigsten Künstler der Welt geworden, nur weil sie Datenmüll verkauft haben. Muss man so sagen.
Ist da schon eine Wertung drin, Stefan?
Nö, erst einmal nur eine Funktionsbeschreibung im Sinne von die Dateien, die da verkauft werden, sind, und das ist ihre Qualität, von Zufall nicht zu unterscheiden, also von Datenmüll. Das ist ja der Sinn der Kryptographie.
Die Nähe von Kunst und Müll ist ja auch ein ganz eigenes Thema, das werden wir nicht heute noch mal aufgreifen, aber man könnte auch da assoziativ weiter denken.
Genau, und jetzt haben natürlich immer alle über die NFTs und die NFTs, und das ist ja auch wichtig, und wir machen es auch gleich. Und ich will aber einleiten mit dem Thema Ethereum, Ethereum, denn ja, es geht um eine Blockchain, aber es ist diesmal nicht Bitcoin, das ja ausschlaggebend ist, sondern dieser Deal, der da stattfand. Beeple hat sein Bild verkauft und hat dafür 69 Millionen Dollar bekommen, wurde immer gesagt, aber stimmt natürlich nicht ganz. Das Bild wurde in Ether bezahlt. Ether ist sozusagen der Bitcoin, das ist der Token, die Währung im Ethereum, also im Ether der anderen Blockchain, die es da noch gibt und die auch immer bekannter wird. Ich war immer ein bisschen betrübt, wenn es hieß, ach, Blockchain, fünf Blockchains, alle machen sich lustig, denn die Konzepte sind einfach zu faszinierend, um es zu sagen, die können doch nicht einfach in der Realität scheitern. Wo kehren wir denn dahin? Könnte ja mal alles scheitern lassen, aber nicht die Blockchains. Und es hat sich eben 2013 oder so jemand dieses Konzept von Ethereum ausgedacht. Der junge Mann heißt Vitalik Buterin und er schreibt es dann so, es gibt verschiedene Gespräche, wie er sagt, das war irgendwie eine komische Idee, die kam mir so und ich dachte, wo ist denn da der Fehler, oder ist das echt so toll, wie ich mir das ausgedacht habe. Und dann ist er nie auf Fehler gestoßen, wurde auch nie drauf hingewiesen, deswegen hat das sich so vor sich hin entwickelt. Und jetzt ist es eben dazu gekommen, dass eine Blockchain etwas ermöglicht hat, was ohne sie nicht möglich gewesen wäre, nämlich dieser Verkauf dieses, also das wirklich 70 Millionen Euro Dollar gezahlt worden für ein Kunstwerk, das rein digital ist. Und wir erinnern noch mal, das Problem am digitalen ist ja letztlich einfach kopieren, während analoge Kunst nun mal einzigartig ist. Das ist nun mal das Ding. Und sobald man jemanden dransetzt, der das kopiert, dann ist es gleich eine du, dann ist man gleich in gefährlichem Fahrwasser, wie Betracci oder wie er hieß. Veltraki, genau. Und die Blockchain hat jetzt etwas ermöglicht, was ohne Blockchain nicht möglich gewesen wäre. Und wir kennen aber Blockchain bisher nur vom Geld. Und da hören wir hier kurz Vatty Vitalik in dem Gespräch, schon vor Jahren, 2015 oder so, wie er noch mal sozusagen sich in so einem Halbsatz von Bitcoin emanzipiert.
Man baut die Wirtschaft als eine grundlegende Basis für das System und nicht als eine Nachdenkung.
So, es gab also lange die Idee der Blockchain, theoretisch, dann wurde sie von Satoshi, wer auch immer, Einzelperson oder Gruppe dahintersteckt, als Bitcoin erfunden wurde, die das dann mal umgesetzt haben, Blockchains zu machen und die haben Ökonomie schon direkt reingebaut, so sehr die Verschränkung ist so scharf, dass wir es gar nicht mehr unterscheiden. Ach so, Blockchains sind erstmal eine Technologie, das ist eigentlich gar kein Geld, sondern man hört immer nur Bitcoin und weiß sofort, ja das ist Geld. Also das ist mittlerweile dann doch eine ganz erstaunliche Verknüpfung, die man da hat. Aber man kann eben mehr mit Blockchain machen, es muss ja nicht nur Geld sein, denn am Wirtschaftsprozess nehmt ihr auch nicht nur Geld teil, sondern da gibt es ja auch Güter, Konsumenten, Produzenten und so weiter. Kriegt man die eigentlich auch alle in eine Blockchain eingebunden? Und hier hören wir Vitalik in einem jüngeren Gespräch, nämlich von vor einem Monat oder so, in der Tim Ferriss Show, wie er nochmal darstellt, was so alles mit Blockchain ginge oder in der Blockchain ginge.
Bitcoin baut ein Monatiersystem auf dem Topf, wie es heutzutage so heftig ist. zentrale finanzielle Kontraptionen, Erkennungsmarkt, non-fungible Token und all-sorten anderen Schemens, die Leute mitgekommen sind.
Und die NFTs hat er hier schon genannt, aber auch. Ja, genau. Aber eben auch Smart-Contracts, also Verträge, Kataloge, Domain Name Systems. Das könnte man auch alles damit abbilden. Und da wird es doch jetzt interessant, denn was und das finde ich so interessant, bevor wir auf die NFTs kommen, denn die sind sozusagen einer dieser Spezialfälle, die funktionieren mit Blockchain, wie wir jetzt gesehen haben. Also so überzeugend, dass es da Marktteilnehmer gibt, die darauf vertrauen, dass das schon alles seine Richtigkeit und Ordnung hat. Und da gibt es aber Smart-Contracts und die könnten hier auch eine Rolle spielen. Bevor wir also gleich auf den Kunstmarkt schauen, will ich uns immunisieren gegen den Einwand, naja Kunstmarkt ist das nicht eh schon immer im Jenseits, haben da nicht die Leute, also ist das überhaupt echtes Geld, ist das nicht sozusagen Spielgeld, haben die Leute das nicht übrig, reden wir überhaupt über was echtes und so. Will ich uns mal immunisieren, nein wir reden hier wirklich jetzt gleich über ganz harte Realität und das, was für NFTs gilt, gilt eben auch für Smart-Contracts. Das ist neu und das ist eine Sensation eigentlich so vom Konzept her. Wir hören uns hier mal in drei kleinen Clips an, was Smart-Contracts sind. Und da gibt es hier ein Erklärvideo von dem Kanal Krypto auf YouTube, da ist einfach Krypto, keine Ahnung. Sagen wir mal, wenn ich es nicht sehr viele, wenn ich es gucke, da sind so 3000 Leute oder so, ist jetzt kein mega erfolgreiches Video, aber hier wird ganz gut dargestellt am Beispiel von Kickstarter, wie ein Smart-Contract funktionieren könnte.
In diesem Video geht es um Smart-Contracts, also intelligente Verträge. Den Begriff Smart-Contract gibt es bereits seit 20 Jahren. Doch es jetzt mit dem Wachstum und den Möglichkeiten der Kryptowährungen und der Blockchain finden Smart-Contracts immer mehr Verwendung.
Smart-Contracts sind üblichen Verreden sehr ähnlich.
Es geht ebenfalls darum, dass zwei oder mehrere Parteien sich auf etwas einigen, zum Beispiel dem Austausch von Leistungen, Gütern oder Geld. Doch Smart-Contracts haben besondere Eigenschaften. Es handelt sich dabei um kleine Programme, die auf der Blockchain gespeichert und ausgeführt werden und für die Umsetzung der programmierten Bedingungen sorgen. Eines der großen Hauptziele, die damit erreicht werden soll, ist die Vermeidung von Mittelspersonen. Der Vertrag wird automatisch ausgeführt, ohne dass eine Drittpartei für die Umsetzung sorgen muss. Schauen wir uns am besten ein paar Beispiele an. Beim Crowdfunding zahlen Investoren Geld an eine Firma wie zum Beispiel Kickstarter. Nur wenn genügend Geld gesammelt wurde, um die Produkterstellung zu ermöglichen, wird dieses an das Team weitergeleitet. Zwischen den Investoren und dem Produktteam ist also eine Zwischenfirma, der beide Seiten vertrauen müssen und dir dafür auch Gebühren verlangt. Der Smart-Contract ersetzt nun diese Mittelsperson. Investoren können das Geld an den Smart-Contract zahlen, der das Geld beim Erreichen einer bestimmten Summe weiterleitet. Falls das Crowdfunding-Ziel in einem bestimmten Zeitraum nicht erreicht wird, sendet der Smart-Contract das Geld zurück an die Investoren. Der Smart-Contract verlangt hierfür fast keine Gebühren und man muss keiner Drittfirma vertrauen. Immer wenn eine bestimmte Bedingung und ein Ereignis definiert wird und dieses digitalisiert werden kann, kann ein Smart-Contract die Arbeit von Zwischenpersonen wie einem Notar, einem Anwalt, einer Behörde und vielem mehr ersetzen.
So, was hier beschrieben wird, ist, dass bei Vertragsverhandlungen, wo wir üblicherweise an zwei Vertragspartner denken, noch eine dritte Instanz und zwar richtig als Akteur.
Intermediär. Und das ist die Technologie der Disintermediation.
Richtig, genau. Wir hatten das letzte Mal auch schon das Zauberwort Dispersion. Kann man nicht Institutionen überspringen, wenn man sie nicht mehr braucht, weil man einen digitalen Prozess hat, der beispielsweise zwischen dem Produzenten im Hollywood-Omain-Wohnzimmer nicht mehr das Kino braucht, auf der anderen Seite der Stadt oder so. Und hier geht es ja wirklich ins Eingemachte, denn es ist ja nicht allzu schwer zu verstehen, dieses Kickstarter-Modell. Leute beteiligen sich an einem Projekt unter der Maßgabe, nur wenn sich ausreichend viele beteiligen, wird es realisiert. Sonst kriegt man sein Geld einfach wieder zurück und alle tun so, als wäre nichts geschehen. Dafür braucht man heute erstens eine Treuhänder-Instanz, die das überhaupt erst mal so organisiert. Also das Unternehmen Kickstarter. Und im Konfliktfall muss man da noch einen weiteren Dritten hinzuziehen und das ist dann ein Richter, der nämlich dann entscheidet, wie wir das Geld zurück verteilt, fallen hier noch Gebühren an, keine Ahnung wie und so. Und das kann man jetzt einfach automatisieren, indem man einfach sagt, wir holen in dieses Geschäftsgefüge aus zwei Vertragspartnern einen Smart-Contract als eigenen Akteur dazu. Der kann also Geld speichern, Vertragsbedingungen aufsetzen und so weiter. Und es ist aber nicht mehr Person und auch nicht mehr Institution, sondern das ist jetzt einfach Internet. Das ist dann einfach Blockchain.
Und so sind hier auch schon Ehen geschlossen worden. Da hat man gesagt, wir brauchen eigentlich keinen Standesbeamten. Wir können das über Smart-Contracts machen. Und das ist schon vor einigen Jahren mal thematisiert worden. Ich habe das gerade hier aus dem Bücherregal gezogen. Die Blockchain-Revolution von Don Tapscott und Alex Tapscott, das ist bei Plassen erschienen, 2016. Und da gibt es solche Ideen schon, wie diese Smart-Contracts zu nutzen sind. Und dann war das aber vollkommen wieder aus der Öffentlichkeit verschwunden. Das war mal mit diesem ersten Bitcoins-Hype ein bisschen da. Und dann hat man jetzt eigentlich nur noch geschaut, was macht der Bitcoin, was machen andere Coins. Und jetzt durch die NFTs sieht man mal das konkret angewendet. Was heißt denn das eigentlich? Und jetzt könnten vielleicht auch manche Notare zittern und denken, oh Gott, was ist das, wenn ich nicht mehr gebraucht werde?
Genau, es gibt nämlich erstaunlich viele, also klar, wir reden hier von rein digitalen Prozessen. Aber welche Prozesse sind ja schon rein digital? Na ja, schon ziemlich viele. Also wann benutzen wir nach Bargeld zum Beispiel? Dieses Geld könnte man ja alles, und das ist die Bedingung, es müsste halt in Ether ablaufen. Das Smart-Contract spielt sich in Ethereum ab, und da kann halt die Währung Ether verarbeitet werden. Aber da jetzt selbst Paypal überlegt, ob man Bitcoin einfach als eine Währung unter vielen aufnimmt, und dann kann man halt einfach klicken auf der Seite, ich möchte meine 10 Euro, die ich hier habe, gerne in Bitcoin übersetzt haben, dann wird das so umgerechnet, als würde man in Dollar tauschen. Also das ist ja jetzt schon angelegt.
Und in der EU hat man doch auch Pläne für europäische Blockchain-Technologien.
Genau, die Europäische Zentralbank, da haben wir die Texte auch getwittert, gelesen im Salon hier vom Bankenverband, der zittert ja auch. Es wird einen digitalen Euro geben und die Frage ist, wird er allein von der Zentralbank gemacht oder haben da auch noch private Banken ihre Hand mit im Spiel? Also wird es erst einmal eine private Währung sein? Das sind ja alles so Fragen. Und diese Smart-Contract-Realität, von der sind wir jetzt gar nicht so weit entfernt, glaube ich. Wenn man sich überlegt, vor ein paar Jahren kam Ethereum auf und jetzt 2021 wurde der Kunstmarkt damals so richtig aufgemöbelt. Wie weit sind wir eigentlich von Smart-Contracts noch weg? Und nicht besonders weit, denn beispielsweise ist immer noch mein Lieblings-Podcast, mein Lieblingsthema, nämlich der Podcast. Wir nutzen ja für den Salon zum Beispiel auch eine Institution. Die organisieren für uns die Zahlungsabwicklung, die Bereitstellung des Downloads und so weiter. Man könnte ja auch den Podcast einfach verschlüsseln in der Blockchain. Dann lädt man den sich runter, aber man kann nichts damit anfangen, bis man ihn mit Ether, also bis man den, ich drücke auf Play, tatsächlich mit einer Überweisung von Ether. Das könnte so ein Smart-Contract einfach abbilden. Und es gibt jetzt keinen technischen Grund, warum man das nicht macht. Denn so, wie man Bilder einfach kryptographisch einbindet, und klar, bei NFT erst mal nur sagt, das gehört zu dieser Adresse, das ist dann der Käufer, kann man da genauso gut einfach die Datei selbst verschlüsseln und sagen, ja, diesen Schlüssel, der wird erst generiert, wenn da eben eine Zahlung mit verknüpft ist. Und dann legt man den Preis einfach fest und sagt, das ist der Preis. Und das ist das Interessante, kann man es wirklich runterbrechen auf Mikro, Mikro, Nano, Nano-Ebene. Man könnte auch sagen, man bezahlt genauso viel, wie man hört. Also man fängt den Podcast an, nach einer Stunde hat man keine Lust mehr, hat man genau diese eine Stunde bezahlt. In höherer Geschwindigkeit spart man Geld oder was auch immer. Also man kann alles Mögliche da einbauen. Technisch sind wirklich keine Grenzen gesetzt, solange es rein digitale Prozesse sind. Und wir haben es mit sehr vielen rein digitalen Prozessen. Die ganze Influenzerei zum Beispiel, das sind alles rein digitale Prozesse. Diese Bilder werden digital erstellt, sie werden digital transferiert, sie werden digital konsumiert. Das könnte man alles mit Smart-Contracts, die alles Mögliche aussagen könnten, aber, und das kennen wir eben von Bitcoin, das Geld ist da schon einprogrammiert, könnte man alles so umsetzen. Also in deren Sicht ist das schon ganz schön interessant. Sie sind, und das ist das Besondere, weshalb man auch dann keine Richter mehr braucht. Diese Smart-Contracts sind transparent.
Warum sollten wir Smart-Contracts überhaupt vertrauen? Dies liegt an den besonderen Eigenschaften dieser Verträge. Sobald ein Smart-Contract erstellt wurde, ist dieser unveränderbar. Eine Partei kann also nicht im Nachhinein eine Änderung zu deren Gunsten bewirken. Außerdem sind Smart-Contracts dezentralisiert und open source. Das heißt, dass man die Vertragsbedingungen jederzeit einsehen kann und die Blockchain die korrekte Umsetzung sicherstellt. Probleme können jedoch dann entstehen, wenn die genutzte Plattform Bugs hat oder sonstige Probleme bei der Umsetzung. Und auch wenn die Smart-Contracts einfach einsehbar sind, so sind diese selbst für Programmierer nur schwer verständlich, da es viel Zeit erfordert, um den Source Code zu lesen, zu verstehen und Schwachstellen zu erkennen.
Genau, es gibt natürlich Hürden, so wie immer. Wer kennt schon die Verwaltungsverfahren und wer weiß, wie es vor Gericht zugeht und trotzdem lässt man sich darauf ein.
Aber man kann sich da an jemanden wenden. Also hier ist es ja auch so, wenn du dein Passwort nicht hast, dann hast du es halt nicht.
Genau.
Da hatten wir jetzt ja Fälle, da waren Leute, die haben gesagt, ich bin nicht mehr an meine Bitcoins rangekommen. Das kann auch hier passieren. Das heißt also, diese Eigenverantwortung, die damit verbunden ist, die ist nicht zu unterschätzen. Also da ist dann nicht der Anruf beim Notar möglich. Können Sie mir das Dokument noch mal geben? Oder ich glaube, hier müssen wir noch mal was ändern. Sagen die ja, das ist ja ganz bei Ihnen. Da ist nicht irgendwie noch mal ein Backup. Ich habe meine E-Mail-Adresse vergessen. Geben Sie mal ein Passwort ein oder wie heißt Ihre Mutter?
Also in der Hinsicht gibt es immer noch Hürden, kleine Probleme. Man muss dann darauf achten, dass man seine eigene Identität nicht verliert oder von jemand anderem eingesetzt wird. Aber das sind ja alles Probleme.
Das ist ein bisschen wie in Departed. Kennst du den Scorsese-Film mit Leonardo DiCaprio, wo er am Ende bettelt, er möchte seine Identität wieder haben? Das scheint mir eher ein Film über die Digitalisierung zu sein, als über etwas anderes.
Also hier ist doch jetzt einiges möglich. Und so wie wir die NFTs, über die wir gleich sprechen, fürs Eigentum haben, könnten wir also demnächst dann auch Smart-Contracts für Verfahren unseres Alltags haben, die wir dann einfach, und da ist dann auch der Finanzialisierung Tor und Tor geöffnet, einmal etabliert, kann sie wirklich an alles im Preisstil dranhängen. Bei Vitalik, Bouterin, klingt es so.
Ein Beispiel dafür könnte sein, dass ein NFT Video-Games-Assets sein kann. Dann kann das Programm, das diese Regeln ausbaut, direkt in die Kontrolle von den Aspekten, die die Organisation kontrollieren soll.
Ja, also so wie man vor einem Jahr noch über NFTs dachte, was ist denn das für ein komisches Konzept, ist ja Quatsch. So denkt man heute vielleicht noch über Smart-Contracts, aber wer weiß.
Ja, Hauskauf ist dann auch ein bisschen einfacher. Also da muss man ja auch sehr viel bezahlen dann für den Notar und solche Sachen. Das ist also alles darüber möglich. Man kann sich aber jetzt, weil wir eben über Kräfteverhältnisse gesprochen haben, gut vorstellen, dass nicht alle davon begeistert sein werden, sondern da gibt es auch wieder Interessen, die sagen, um Gottes Willen, was ist, wenn das kommt? Und was wir vielleicht jetzt auch gleich noch sehen werden, wenn wir uns um die NFTs kümmern, diese Disintermediation ist das eine und das stimmt erst mal. Und dann sehen wir ja doch, wie auch im Podcast-Business, wie wieder neue Plattformen, wieder neue Mittler sofort entstehen, auch wo eigentlich keine von Nöten sind. Das kann natürlich hier auch wieder sein, dass irgendjemand diese Smart-Contracts verwaltet für uns und was zahlen wir dem dafür? Und ist es am Ende eine Summe, die wir auch dem Notar einfach zahlen könnten?
Also es wird auf jeden Fall Services geben, die dir den Smart-Contract sozusagen klickbar machen, dass du nicht selber wirklich programmieren musst, sondern einfach sagst so und so und so. Dann wird er da kurz rauskompiliert und steht dann zur Verfügung, ist dann in der Blockchain verfügbar. Aber das sind Serviceleistungen, die sind sehr viel billiger und die sind auch sehr viel schlechter teurer zu machen als jetzt ein echter Notar mit einem Termin vor Ort und so weiter.
Wir werden sehen. Also ich meine, ich denke dabei an die proprietären Märkte. Man zahlt auch, wenn man eine App entwickelt hat, 30 Prozent an Apple. Das ist ja auch nicht vonnöten, aber die können diese Preise dann setzen. Also da bin ich immer sehr vorsichtig, wenn so viel auf das Intermediation gesetzt wird, wie weit das wirklich ist. Jedenfalls ist es, glaube ich, jetzt noch die Möglichkeit. Eigentlich wäre das jetzt sofort der Punkt, wo die EU einschreiten muss, eine Möglichkeit zu bieten für alle EU-Bürger, dass diese Smart-Contracts kostenlos funktionieren können. Also dass man jetzt nicht darauf wartet, bis sich ein paar große Konzerne drauf gesetzt haben. Und die werden natürlich versuchen, den größten Anteil für sich rauszuholen, sondern hier wäre jetzt mal wieder die Möglichkeit, öffentliche Infrastruktur herzustellen.
Tja, nee, das wird leider nicht so verstanden. So wie soziale Netzwerke, weißt du ja, keine öffentliche Infrastruktur sind, sondern rein privat organisiert werden. Auch ein großer Fehler.
Ja, sollen wir auf die NFTs schauen?
Na los.
Am 11. März hat dann in der Kunstgeschichte etwas Historisches stattgefunden. Im Auktionshaus Christie's wurde eine NFT-Datei, also Non-Functional-Tokens, eine Datei mit 5.000 digitalen Bildern des Künstlers Beeple, verkauft für 69 Millionen US-Dollar. Und der Startpreis lag bei 100 Euro. Es ist also ordentlich nach oben gegangen. Ein Bieter aus Singapur hat bekommen dieses Werk. Und damit ist dieser Beeple, der auch Grafiker ist, der jetzt nicht vorher so ein Riesennamen der Kunstszene war, der dritteuerste lebende Künstler, also gleich hinter David Hockney und Jeff Koons. So, diese Non-Functional-Tokens, das sind also Sachen, die erst einmal unser Denken über das Digitale in Frage stellen. Nämlich haben wir immer gesagt, na ja, im Netz gibt es keine Originalität. Es ist alles copy-paste. Also vor dem Originalitätsgedanken müssen wir uns mal komplett lossagen. Das war diese große Erzählung der Neunziger und auch Nuller Jahre. Oder denken wir auch an solche Plagiatsgeschichten dann wie Helene Hegemann. Das war dann in der Literatur, da sagte man, ja sowieso ist das doch ein Zeichen der digitalen Welt, dass man nicht mehr auf Originalität sitzen kann. Außerdem ist doch der Urheber als Autor eigentlich tot und all das. Und jetzt plötzlich haben wir mit diesen NFTs die Möglichkeit, ein Werk zu authentifizieren, nicht nur, sondern ihm auch damit eine Originalität, ja Einmaligkeit zu geben. Das heißt, diese, diese NFT ist zwar kopierbar in der Form, dass man jetzt von diesem Bild Screenshots machen kann. Man kann sich das überall ansehen, was auch immer. Aber es gibt nur diesen einen Schlüssel dazu. Und den hat der Mensch da aus Singapur jetzt bekommen, diesen Schlüssel. Und der ist auch nicht duplizierbar. Und diese Einmaligkeit ist eigentlich noch viel radikaler als eine Einmaligkeit bei einem Gemälde. Denn das kann man immer noch ziemlich gut fälschen, sodass dann die Kunstwissenschaftler sich schon unsicher sind. Ist das jetzt wirklich da Vinci bei der Vinci gibt's ja ganz große Anstrengungen, irgendeine Zeichnung mal wirklich zu authentifizieren. Das bedeutet aber immer, dass dann 100 damit fragwürdig werden. Also ist man da auch vorsichtig und hier kann man das einfach sagen. Hier ist dieser Schlüssel und den hat dieser Mensch jetzt für 69 Millionen bekommen. Ein einziges Kunstwerk 69 Millionen für einen einzigen Menschen, wenngleich wir das jetzt alle sehen können. Mich hat das erst mal an Wolf von Dracheck erinnert, den deutschen Schriftsteller. Der hat im Jahr 2015 einen Roman geschrieben und wir hatten diesen Roman zu lesen bekommen. Ein einziger Mann, ein mehr zehn, der hat nämlich dem von Dracheck gesagt, schreiben sie mir einen Roman. Ich zahle ihnen 40.000 Euro. Und da hat von Dracheck gesagt, ja, das ist in etwa so viel, wie ich mit einem Buch vielleicht verdienen kann, wenn es gut läuft, wenn es sich gut verkauft. Aber dieser Roman liegt jetzt nur bei diesem einen Mann und den hat sonst niemand gelesen. Bei den NFTs ist es in der Regel anders. Dort kann man sich sehr wohl diese NFTs ansehen. Man kann sie auch vervielfältigen. Das ist alles gar kein Problem. Das ist auch nicht strafbar. Aber man kann ja eben nicht diesen Code vervielfältigen. So, und jetzt gehen wir erstmal noch mal weg aus Amerika, gucken nach Deutschland. Da ist Finn Kliemann, den kennen wahrscheinlich alle. Das ist dieser, ja, Heimwerker wäre doch zu wenig gesagt. Also auch Grafiker und Lebenskünstler, der da seinen eigenen Hof betreibt und Social-Media-Star ist. Und der hat jetzt sich auch mit NFTs beschäftigt, hat auch welche rausgebracht, dazu kommen wir gleich. Aber er stellt sich erstmal so eine grundsätzliche Frage bei den NFTs.
Also die große Frage immer so, wem gehört denn eigentlich ein GIF? Also wem gehört ein JPEG oder in meinem Fall dann eben auch Musik? Alles, was nicht physisch ist, ist ja schwierig zu verpacken. Da gab es diesen Beweis, wie ein Fahrzeugschein oder so, nicht so richtig. Und den gibt es jetzt mit NFTs.
Ja, so ein bisschen, also diese Frage, wem gehört, ne? Bei digitalen Sachen, es gibt ja auch in Deutschland diesen Unterschied zwischen Eigentum und Besitz. Eigentum meint tatsächlich, es gehört dir im Sinne von, du hast den Titel, den juristischen Titel, du darfst es zu Geld machen. Wenn man allerdings einen Mietwagen sich holt für zwei Tage, dann besitzt man den für diese zwei Tage und kann ihn benutzen, als wäre es der eigene. Also da macht es keinen Unterschied. Und in der Ansicht ist das bei so digitalen Sachen hier, digitale Kunst, also Film, Bild, Musik, eh immer so eine Frage, muss man es besitzen? Wir haben ja alle akzeptiert, dass wir nur noch Lizenznehmer sind von unseren Kindes.
Und man Eigentümer sein meint es.
Von unserer Spotify-Musik, genau, wir müssen ja gar nicht Eigentümer sein. Das macht ja gar keinen Unterschied, ob wir jetzt wirklich Eigentum über dieses Stück haben oder es einfach uns nicht verwehrt wird, es zu konsumieren. Und deswegen stellt sich diese Frage eigentlich gar nicht so sehr.
Aber für ihn ist das scheinbar wichtig und er ist nicht der Einzige. Jetzt springen wir noch mal über den großen Teich zu Logan Paul. Das ist ein Schauspieler, eher so dritte Garde, würde ich sagen. Ist aber auch Influencer, ist auch Boxer, macht alles mögliche und ist jetzt bei den NFTs dabei. Macht einen sehr erfolgreichen Podcast. Der ist, glaube ich, ein ziemlicher Idiot. Also ich habe mir diesen Podcast angehört. Ich bin richtig rammdösig dadurch geworden, was die da schwätzen. Aber jedenfalls auch er hat diesen Eigentumsgedanken.
Und die Idee, dass du deine Flagge in die Sache platzt und sagt, das ist meine. Amerika.
Und die Frage der Wohne-Wohnheit.
Weil es Deko ist, würde ich sagen.
Aber lassen wir das mal noch so stehen. Also man will da irgendetwas unbedingt haben, sagen die jetzt. Und das ist jetzt dieser Reiz der NFTs. Und bei Fynn Kliemann wird das aber jetzt noch größer. Er ist da in einem Podcast zu Gast von Julian Hobbs oder beziehungsweise beim YouTube-Kanal, der sich mit Kryptowährungen beschäftigt und erzählt jetzt mal, was ihnen doch umgetrieben hat und was jetzt diese NFTs so grundsätzlich doch ermöglichen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, wir brauchen das. Also wir brauchen digitalen Ownership, der irgendwas beweist und das mal überträgt. Und irgendwie, wir bestehen alle zu 50 Prozent aus einer digitalen und 50 Prozent nur noch aus einer physischen Person. Und die eine digitale Person, die hat faktisch nichts. Die hat keine Beweise, die hat keine Rechte, die hat keine gar nichts.
Also ich habe ja auch Fynn Kliemanns komische Doku angeguckt im Sinne von die ersten 20 Minuten von diesem Bootding. Und mittlerweile glaube ich, die wollen wirklich alles einfach nur noch zu Geld machen. Also das ist so das Kalkül hier im Hintergrund.
Aber man erzählt immer, dass in so einer merkwürdigen Art, also der redet ja, ich meine, der Mann ist ja über 30, der redet aber mit mir, als wären wir 14-jährige Kumpels, die noch im Zelt gleich unser Lager aufschlagen. Und es ist interessant, dass das so funktioniert. Also ich würde ja jetzt als erwachsener Mensch denken, gut, warum redet der so komisch und was wird er da eigentlich mit? Ja, wir haben im Digitalen keine Rechte. Ne, wir haben ganz viele Rechte. Ich habe mich ja kürzlich hier noch beklagt. Jetzt muss ich überall noch dreimal mehr anklicken, ob ich jetzt irgendwo ein Cookie haben will oder nicht. Das heißt, das ist ja gar kein rechtsfreier Raum. Außerdem hat man ganz viele Rechte, die man einhalten muss oder auch man hat Möglichkeiten, gegen Dinge vorzugehen. Es ist also eine Fantasie, als sei das irgendwie so ein rechtsfreier Raum. Das hätte man jetzt 1992 bestimmt sagen können. Heute ist das reichlich spät und ich weiß auch nicht, was diese Ownership-Sache jetzt mir irgendwie bringt.
Genau, nicht hier, in diesem Rahmen. Ich meine, der Kevin Roos, von dem wir das Buch lesen im Salon, der hat zum Beispiel eine Kolumne von sich, also einen Screenshot von einer Kolumne für 560.000 Dollar per NFT verkauft. Das ging nah an so Charity-mäßig und so weiter und so fort. Bei diesem Metier, wo wir über Beeple, Everydays, über den Screenshot von einer Kolumne reden, oder über alles, was Finn Kliemann hier beschäftigt, da geht es ja darum, das kann man ja auch einfach juristisch absichern. Dafür braucht man keine Blockchain. Da könnte man einfach zu einem Richter gehen. Ich bin der Urheber dieser Musik und ich möchte jetzt dieser Person die Rechte so und so weit übertragen. Er darf ab jetzt sagen, es ist seins. Und damit ist das eindeutig geregelt. Da kann auch niemand alles im Internet kommen und sagen, ich habe es mir aber auch unterkopiert, es ist jetzt auch meins. Also da macht das NFT-Ding keinen Zusatz, außer es ist eine Einnahmequelle für den Emittenten, also in dem Falle dann für den Kliemann. Man sehen, was er demnächst so verkauft. Oder Logan Paul mit seiner komischen Baseballkarte. Es ergibt aber dann Sinn, diese Eindeutigkeit in Blockchains abzubilden, wenn man digitale Güter hat, die in Spielen zum Beispiel einen echten funktionalen Wert haben, eine besondere Rüstung, eine besondere Waffe oder so, die man dann auch über die Spiele hinweg verwenden kann, weil genau da braucht man diese Authentifizierung. Also es gibt sozusagen einen hohen funktionellen sinnvollen Charakter für NFTs, aber jetzt gerade, wo sich das einspielt, sehen wir es auf so einem Metier, wo man sich so ein bisschen fragt, na, biegen die da nicht auch ein bisschen falsch ab? Wollen die sozusagen, und deswegen vorhin auch, wollen die jetzt so diese Pioniere sein, die Ersten, die diesen großen Aufschlag machen? Denn wenn man das verpasst, interessiert sich schon im halben Jahr vielleicht keiner mehr dafür. Und das hört man dann auch so ein bisschen raus. Finn will hier einfach wieder Pionier werden und auch Geld verdienen an der Stelle. Aber mehr interessiert ihn das, glaube ich, da eigentlich nicht.
Genau. Und dazu braucht er aber dann auch eine Galerie. Und da gibt es dann Online-Galerien, wo man diese Online-Kunst, diese NFT-Kunst kaufen kann. Und da hören wir mal rein in den Kanal Diffus. Die haben das ein bisschen erklärt.
Wie kann man sich ein NFT kaufen? Dafür gibt es dann so Plattformen wie Rarible.
Das ist sowas wie Ebay zum Beispiel. Kann man sich das vorstellen?
Die Käufer kaufen dann direkt vom Verkäufer und man kann sich ihre Besitztümer dann auch auf dem Profil ansehen. Das ist am Ende wie eine digitale Galerie. Da drin steckt dann nämlich auch wieder großes Potenzial, weil man kann sich vorstellen, du gehst zu jemandem hin, kaufst etwas aus einer digitalen Galerie und führst es in deine eigene digitale Galerie über. Das heißt, Leute können sich die Kunst dann trotzdem angucken oder die Musik trotzdem anhören, aber sehen, okay, das ist jetzt von Person A zu Person B in die Galerie übergegangen.
Ja, Stefan, ich kann dann in deine Galerie gehen und kann schauen, was du da alles hast, darfst aber auch bewundern. Du kannst dann bei mir gucken und dann können wir irgendwie schauen, wer den besseren Geschmack hat oder was weiß ich. Also ich weiß nicht, was sollen diese Spielereien?
Ja, vor allem hört man hier noch, wie abhängig die noch von Institutionen sind. Das Ziel ist ja eigentlich, sich von denen zu lösen und sagen, die Blockchain regelt. Nur Beeple braucht halt Christie's und die brauchen jetzt ihre komischen Galerien, die nochmal die Instagramartige App schreiben, mit der man das dann begutachten kann. Also das digitale Museum sozusagen.
Und das ist richtig teuer. Das hören wir jetzt nochmal bei Diffuse.
Aber die Preise sind nicht nur aus Käufersicht so hoch, sondern auch bei der Erstellung. Also Fynn Kliemann hat das dargelegt. Allein die Erstellung seiner Collection auf Rarible hat ihn fast 2000 Dollar gekostet und jedes weitere NFT lag dann zwischen 50 und 200 Dollar.
Eigentlich ging es genau darum, diese Kosten zu vermeiden.
Ganz genau. Und Fynn Kliemann hat Jingles angefertigt mit Emotionen, zu Emotionen. Er hat dann gesagt, für jedes Gefühl mache ich einen Jingle und diesen Jingle verpacke ich dann als NFT und dann kann man diese Jingles kaufen. Und natürlich ging es darum, dass man da irgendwie der Erste ist, aber das erkläre ich jetzt bei Diffuse auch. Bei Fynn Kliemann ist es nicht so, dass man das sich jetzt einmalig nur gekauft hat. Und jetzt ist Fynn Kliemann ganz aus der Sache raus.
Halt die Streams so, man könnte den Fans sagen, hey, du besitzt jetzt Musik wieder und für Musiker ist wichtig, dass die auch an einem Weiterverkauf von einem NFT verdienen könnten. Das heißt bei Fynn Kliemann, der jetzt diese 100 Jingles verkauft hat, ist es so gewesen oder ist es weiterhin so, dass er an den Weiterverkäufen auch verdient? Das heißt, er wird immer prozentual daran beteiligt. Wenn ich jetzt von Fynn Kliemann einen Jingle gekauft hätte, hätte er davon keine Ahnung, 10 Prozent verdient. Und wenn ich dir das jetzt verkaufe, verdient er daran wieder.
Ja, also da kann man zumindest Schwarzmarkt austrocknen, denn die kann man bisher einfach so weiter verhökern. Das könnte man dann unterbinden, indem man sagt, die Übertragung kann ja nur per Smart-Contract abschlaufen. Also könnte man das machen. Was man auch machen könnte, fällt mir gerade ein. Man könnte sagen, man verkauft sein Buch digital und jeder Käufer, für jeden Käufer ist es immer 0, 01 Cent teurer. Also das ist den Early Bird besonders gefälter. Irgendwie sowas, also alles möglich jetzt eigentlich.
Ja, und Fynn Kliemann rechtfertigt das auch nochmal, warum er da jetzt eine Lizenz kassiert.
Das ist ein riesengeiles Teil, wenn du dir anguckst, Leute wie Basquiat oder so, die großen Künstler unserer Zeit, wenn du so willst, die haben ihre Bilder für 1000, 2000 Dollar verkauft und danach sind die halt auf der Auktion für 1, 2, 5, 20, 40 Millionen weiterverkauft worden. Und davon hat der Maler ja nie was abbekommen. Und bei NFTs soll genau das eben durch relativ vieles geändert werden. Das ist einer der größten Changes überhaupt, dass du sagst, okay, pass mal auf, wenn das abgeht, dann möchte ich aber auch was davon. Dann machen wir das schön fair durch alle.
Tja, ein guter Geschäftsmann, würde ich sagen, und ein guter Verkäufer tatsächlich. Und jetzt hören wir mal ganz kurz bei Deutschlandradio Deutschlandfunk Kultur. Da hat Dennis Kugel Anita Posch interviewt, die ist Krypto-Expertin. Und die schätzt mal ein, wie wichtig das für die Musikbranche sein könnte, mit diesen NFTs zu arbeiten.
Ja, es ist ja im Gegensatz zu einem anderen digitalen Pfeil, das man unendlich weiter kopieren kann, weiter verbreiten kann, ist das einzigartig.
Aber ist das wirklich einzigartig?
Weil letztendlich kann ich ja dann dieses Finn-Kliman-Jingle nehmen und dann davon einfach Kopien davon machen und dann davon NFTs machen.
Und dann ist es ja wieder unendlich.
Aber die NFTs machen ja dann sie davon. Sie haben die digitale Kopie angelegt und machen dann eine NFT. Das ist ja nicht dasselbe NFT wie die vom originalen Künstler. Der originale Künstler, der jetzt die Musik oder das digitale Kunstwerk ausgibt und den Token anlegt, ist der einzige, der den privaten Schlüssel zu diesem Token besitzt.
Ich glaube, das ist immer noch für uns so eine absurde Vorstellung, weil es immer noch um einen digitalen Inhalt handelt, wo man ja trotzdem immer noch dieses, das kann ja trotzdem unendlich viel vervielfältigt werden.
Aber natürlich kann ich auch einen Kunstdruck unendlich oft vervielfältigen.
Ich sehe eher die positiven Effekte, die das mittel- und langfristig haben wird. Im Moment ist es ja so, dass Content-Creator und Künstlerinnen online kaum Geld verdienen können, außer über zentrale Plattformen wie Facebook und Google etc. Das heißt, wir sind alle sehr, sehr abhängig von diesen Plattformen. Und über NFTs oder Micro-Payments, über das Lightning-Netzwerk, können diese Abhängigkeiten eigentlich abgeschafft werden.
Wenn sie etabliert sind, genau. Das haben wir im Fernsehpodcast auch schon so besprochen. Es ist ja beispielsweise Netflix. Die hatten ja lange Sorgen. Wie vertreiben wir eigentlich unsere Filme? Wir haben ja keine eigene Hardware. Dass die Leute da eben nicht einfach eine Kopie anlegen und das dann ihre Freunde weitergeben. Also wurde im Browser Digital Rights Management Software hinterlegt, die man dann anspricht. Das heißt, man kann nicht einfach durch jedes HDMI-Kabel durch oder so. Das sieht man dann manchmal auch bei Amazon. Filme, die man so per HDMI-Kabel rumruten lassen will, steht dann da. Nee, kann nicht in HD übertragen werden, weil das Kabel macht das nicht mit. Also man kann diese Art der Authentifizierung Hardware- und Softwareseitig so nachrüsten, dass man tatsächlich das ganze Internet verfügbar macht, um Smart-Contracts auszuführen, so wie heute in den Browsern das schon drin ist. Und das ist aber noch ein Schritt in die Zukunft. Da sind wir noch nicht so weit, aber es wäre durchaus denkbar, dass man Musik eben nicht monatsweise abrechnet pauschal, sondern dass man einfach sagt, ich habe das jetzt von dem Künstler gehört. Und während des Abspielens, also des Play-Button drücken, löst sozusagen diese Zahlung aus.
Aber da sind wir wirklich noch ganz am Anfang, denn noch ist das alles auch sehr, sehr energieaufwendig. Also da gibt es ja dann so Berechnungen darüber, was das eigentlich kostet, die Umwelt, wenn man das macht. Und da würde ich sagen, es ist doch sinnvoller, mit dem SUV durchgegeben zu fahren, als in das Spiel zu fahren. Also das ist einfach so. Nun haben aber schon Musiker auch jetzt darauf gesetzt, und nicht nur Finn Kliemann, sondern auch Kings of Lean. Das ist eine afrikanische Truppe, glaube ich, oder? Ich kannte die.
Können auch britisch sein, wie immer.
Ja, ich kenne die junge Musik ja heute nicht mehr. Na ja, jedenfalls warten die bei James Corden zu Gast. Und James Corden fragt dann ein Bandmitglied, ja, was ist denn das jetzt nur mit dem NFT? Erklär das mal. Und vielleicht ist das schon ganz gut erklärt gerade.
Ja, das glaube ich eben auch. Das ist Merchandise, Künstler unterstützen. Also es steckt auch wie so ein Spendencharakter drin.
Ja, und man hat auch diese Idee des Einmaligen. Also das ist glaube ich etwas, was diese Fantasie anstarrt. Denn man könnte ja auch sagen, dann überweist doch so Geld. Aber nein, man hat dann was Einmaliges. Also niemand sonst hat diesen einen digitalen Schlüssel, der da geformt wurde.
Genau, und Beeple hätte ja das Ding auch zehnmal verkaufen können und dann aber durchnummeriert zum Beispiel.
Die Durchnummerierung findet schon woanders statt. Erst mal blicken wir mal ganz kurz noch, du hattest es kurz angesprochen, auf die Games, also in Computerspielen kann das auch eine Rolle spielen. Hier ist mal im Interview Yasha Zamadi, der ist auch so ein NFT-Pionier, der war im OMR Podcast zu Gast.
Yield generating oder interest bearing NFTs, das sind vor allem in-game Assets. Also das sind NFTs, die dann zum Beispiel einen Charakter in einem Blockchain-basierten Game verkörpern oder ein Stück Land in einer digitalen Welt, die sozusagen auf der Chain lebt, wo du dann, wenn du mit diesem NFT, also diesem Charakter oder diesem Stück Land in dem Spiel irgendetwas tust, dass dir dieses Asset gehört. Ich kaufe nicht irgendwelche Virtual Items bei irgendeinem iPhone-Game, aber mir gehört eigentlich gar nichts. Und wenn das Game morgen seine Regeln ändert oder irgendwie zumacht, dann...
Das glaube ich nämlich auch, dass wir in den sowieso schon absolut durchdigitalisierten Welten davon wegkommen, dass wir abhängig sind weiter von denjenigen, die die Spiele gestalten, dass die einfach den Katalog führen und dir dann die Lizenz für diesen jenes Schwert geben, sondern dass du von so bestimmten Spieleherstellern, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Assets kriegst, die du dann tatsächlich verwenden kannst, vielleicht sogar über die Spiele hinaus und so weiter. Dass man da so richtig sich von denen unabhängig macht. Weil da liegt auch so ein ideeller Eigenwert drin, den diese Spielebranche nochmal, also die Gamer, besonders leicht akzeptieren. Dass sie bereit sind zu zahlen, ist eh schon klar.
Schauen wir noch auf ein anderes Spektrum, und zwar Panini-Bilder kennt man noch. Also ich hab die nie gesammelt, aber es gibt diese Fußball-Bildchen. Das ist immer noch ganz wichtig, übrigens auch, weil wir schon Logan Paul angesprochen haben. Der hat nicht nur so eine eigene Baseball-Karte da entwickelt, NFT, sondern der macht auch noch Analog-Furore dadurch, dass er irgendwelche alten Pokémon-Karten in Originalverpackungen hat, die dann aufschneidet im Livestream und dann werden die versteigert, diese einzelnen Karten an irgendwelche Pokémon-Fans. Das scheint ein Riesen-Business zu sein. Es gibt ja nicht nur Börsen für Sneaker, wie wir hier auch schon besprochen hatten, sondern auch diese Karten sind wichtig. Im Übrigen gibt es auch NFT-Sneaker. Das will ich nur der Vollständigkeit halber sagen. Also das sind Designs, NFT-Designs, die es also dann einmalig nun gibt. Jeder kann sich natürlich ansehen, Screenshotten, aber das sind einfach digitale Sneaker, die auch für viele tausend Euro mitunter gehandelt werden.
Stell dir mal vor, NFT-Filter bei Instagram. Und dann wird in jedem Bild eingeblendet, dass das dein Filter ist, wenn er verwendet wurde.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Ja, Panini-Bilder, also das gibt es jetzt auch im digitalen Raum. Und da ist jetzt ein YouTuber, Mike Hager, der sich auch mit Kryptosachen beschäftigt. Und der erzählt jetzt mal, wie so eine Plattform zu nutzen wäre.
David Beckham. Bei SoRare. Jetzt können wir mal hier schauen, wie es momentan auf dem Transfermarkt mit David Beckham aussieht, wie der gerade so gehandelt wird. Beckham werden vier Stück zum Verkauf angeboten. Es werden, es wird die blaue, also die SuperRare, von denen es nur zehn gibt, wird angeboten für 77.000 Euro. Und die hier für 146.000 Euro, auch interessant.
Ja, das ist also eine Plattform SoRare, da kann man die dann kaufen und dann kann man diese Karten nehmen und sie einsetzen. Dann hat man Spieltage, also wie das dann bei den Spielen ist, jetzt zum Beispiel bei der Bundesliga. Und dann kann man sich so ein Team aufstellen, mit denen die man gekauft hat. Und je nachdem, wie viel Tore die dann schießen oder was weiß ich, alles richtig machen, steigt dann die Karte, die man gekauft hat, im Preis. Und dann kann man die wieder verkaufen und dadurch ein Geschäft machen. Und das ist etwas, was wohl sehr stark jetzt schon genutzt wird. Ich meine, der Glücksspieltrieb ist ja sehr hoch. Diese ganzen Wettgeschichten, wenn man sich das nur ansieht, wie wichtig das inzwischen bei der Bildzeitung geworden ist, Bild online, wie groß da diese Fußballwetten gemacht werden, dass es da extra jemanden gibt, der glaube ich der Wettoper heißt, der das dann immer erzählt. Also auch hier im digitalen Raum ist das nochmal vertreten. Und jetzt gibt dieser Hager nochmal eine Idee mit auf den Weg, wie man jetzt da vorgehen könnte.
Für das Spiel an sich ist es wichtig, dass du Spieler hast, die oft spielen und die selten verletzt sind. Weil du wirklich, wenn du dir dein Team zusammenstellst und dort in diesem So-Rare-Spiel spielst, kannst du dir sehr, sehr gute Punkte erspielen. Und mit diesen Punkten kannst du tatsächlich Geldpreise gewinnen. Was mega interessant ist, ist, junge Spieler zu kaufen, die eine große Karriere vor sich haben.
Also Stefan, jetzt investieren, early bird sein und später richtig reich werden.
Na ja, es ist schon alles ein bisschen irre.
Es ist extrem irre und man schaut da in eine Welt rein und kann sich gar nicht vorstellen, dass das alles auch Teile dieser Welt ist, in der wir leben. Und deswegen jetzt zum Abschluss nochmal Gary Vaynerchuk. Das ist auch ein Unternehmer, Motivationscoach, was weiß ich, Hans Dampfen allen Gassen. Sehr merkwürdig dieser Typ, aber unglaublich beliebt, wie das er oft so ist bei so eigenartig charismatischen Figuren, die natürlich jetzt auch sagen, NFT, das ist das, was man jetzt dringend braucht. Und es ist auch wieder bezeichnet, dass diese ursprünglichen Fantasien vom Internet der Freiheit, der Selbstverwirklichung mit jeder neuen Technik eigentlich nochmal so neu ganz schnell durchgespielt werden. Also das wird immer kürzer, habe ich den Eindruck. Man macht das immer nur noch so 14 Tage und dann ist es auch wieder, ach nee, doch nicht, ist ja Internet, ist ja doch noch mit anderen Dingen verbunden. Aber man hatte immer nochmal einmal so diesen Traum, als wäre 1996 hier auch.
Das wird ein Haus sein und ein Haus, das mir eine andere Seite zeigen wird, von einem Kreativität-Stand-Point her, das ich immer dort war. Ich denke, ich habe viele Augen auf mich, ich habe einen Kommunikationsstil, der für bestimmte Menschen landet, und ich denke, jemand wird sagen, warte mal, bin ich auch ein Künstler? Und ich denke, die Infrastruktur der NFTs wird jemanden erlauben, der ein Künstler ist, jetzt ein Künstler zu sein. Jemand, der ein Sportagent ist, jetzt ein Künstler zu sein.
Dann will man das machen. Und es ist doch ganz eigenartig, dass man wieder einmal eine Technologie hat, die auch es ermöglicht, dass Dinge, die das Netz einmal uns dargebracht hat, nämlich dass wir nicht mehr mit Knappheit es zu tun haben, dass alles kopierbar ist, jetzt wieder diese Idee von Verknappung haben, damit man dadurch einen Wert generieren kann. Denn nur das, was knapp ist, ist auch wertvoll. Und deshalb gibt es Limited Editions von allen möglichen Sachen. Und so hat man das hier auch mit diesen Panini-Karten. Es ist ja nochmal sehr schön, dass man die Karten hat, die im Prinzip dieselben Karten sind, nur dann mit den entsprechenden Einschränkungen. Die gibt es zehnmal, die gibt es nur einmal, die hundertmal. Und jetzt sagte aber dieser Gary Vaynerchuk nochmal, was er so faszinierend an NFT findet, an dieser Idee, dass man ganz früh dabei ist und er versucht, das jetzt auch nochmal anthropologisch herzuleiten. Und damit kommen wir quasi so zum Anfang, wem gehört was und da muss doch irgendwas sein. Da muss doch irgendwo eine Flagge eingestoßen werden. Da ist doch der Beginn und so sind wir Menschen.
Und es ist sehr wichtig, weil ich ein sehr langsames Beispiel benutze, das jeder verstehen kann. Ich bin dir sehr ernst. Und ich kann dir 47 andere Trillionen Beispiele an die Frage stellen, warum das so funktioniert, die folgende ist. Als ich in 1999 mit allen anderen Leuten eine online Date gemacht habe, haben meine Freunde mich so schwer gefreut.
Ja, das kann man so beschreiben. Also das ist so amerikanische Klugheit, sag ich mal.
Ja, oder Cleverness ist, glaube ich, das bessere.
Ja, diese pragmatische Herangehensweise, einfach zu sagen. Wir sind doch eh alles Selbstdarsteller. Wir leben doch in einer Gesellschaft, wir interessieren uns, welchen Platz haben wir denn? Und dann deswegen, wie er gesagt, vor 20 Jahren haben die Leute gesagt, ich bin ja verrückt geworden, wenn ich sage, die Leute werden sich alle online kennenlernen. Ich würde sagen, die deutsche Herangehensweise, so ein bisschen soziologisch-philosophisch, ist ja tatsächlich mal festzustellen, naja, diese Dichotomie online-offline hat sich halt überlebt. Menschen lernen sich kennen in der Gesellschaft. Da gibt es Online-Anteile und Offline-Anteile. Noch kann man die immer gut unterscheiden, weil das eine hat so mit Elektrizität und dem sichtbaren Bildschirm zu tun. Aber so langsam verschwindet das eben auch. Irgendwelche Geräte fangen an zu reden. Manche Menschen stellen gar nicht fest, dass das ja gar kein Mensch ist, der da am Telefon mit einem spricht und so weiter. Ja, und diese Verschränkung sehen wir jetzt. Und ich würde als abschließenden Gedanken dazu sagen, diese NFTs sind die Verlockung, jetzt wirklich den letzten Rest noch zu finanzialisieren. Das, was man offline niemals, wo man nicht dran gedacht hätte, das noch, ja, das kriegt man jetzt mit irgendwelchen in die Nano-Partikularinteressen aufgebrochenen Smart-Contracts, die sich da überall einschleichen könnten, kriegt man da noch rein. So, und jetzt kann man einfach überall ein Preisschild drankleben. Und ja, man könnte ja auch, wenn man, wenn man zwischendurch auf die Spitze treibt, das Dating findet auf dem gleichen Smartphone statt, wie danach der Restaurantbesuch und die Fahrt dahin und so weiter. Und da könnte man ja wirklich sagen, ja, dann haben wir jetzt halt so eine Art WeChat oder so. Die haben einfach alles unter Kontrolle und die sagen dann, du kannst hier daten, wie du willst. Wir berechnen dann den Erfolg. Ein erfolgreicher Abend beim Date kostet dann so und so viel. Und dann will ichst du da ein und dann behandelt sich so was an und dann stellt das Handy irgendwann fest, na, du bist ja jetzt wirklich zum Restaurant gefahren und da haben sich die beiden getroffen, die sich vorher nur digital miteinander zu tun hatten. Also stellen wir das jetzt mal in Rechnung. Die Smart-Contracts, dafür wurden alle vorher geschrieben. Da braucht es keine dritte Instanz, kein Richter, der das noch mal begutachtet, sondern darauf hat man sich verständigt. Und wenn man da nicht bereit ist zu zahlen, hört das Handy auf, in Betrieb zu sein. Und dann muss man halt gucken, ob man es auch ohne Handy weiter schafft. Ja, das ist dann sozusagen die Sanktion. Aber es werden jetzt, es sind jetzt alles Szenarien denkbar. Also jetzt könnte noch mal so richtig science fictionmäßig losgetreten werden. Bei Westworld geht es ja schon ziemlich weit, ne. Da hat man ja schon diese App, wo man so Smart-Contract-mäßig miteinander, klar, da geht es um dieses illegale Zeug, wer ermogste eigentlich wen und so weiter. Welche illegalen Jobs werden hier weiter verteilt. Aber das lässt sich ja über Smart-Contracts, fernab von Rechtsstaat, Juristen, Leute, die und so. Sondern da lässt sich ja alles regeln. Also wird da erst mal das illegale Leben geregelt damit.
Ja, das ist immer das, was zuerst kommt. Denn das muss erst mal außerhalb des Staates sein. Und wenn man sich diese ganzen Leute so ansieht, anhört, mal ist es deutlich, mal weniger deutlich, sind das doch alles Leute, die eigentlich von so einer libertären Idee besessen sind und eigentlich ein großes Misstrauen gegenüber dem Staat haben und dann sagen, ich bau da jetzt mal mein eigenes Reich irgendwo. Und dazu brauche ich aber ein eigenes Geld und auch eigene Verträge und muss mich irgendwie da rauslösen. Und das ist ja nicht nur in den USA immer beliebter, sondern das erleben wir ja auch in Deutschland. Und deswegen kommt das gerade zur rechten Zeit und ist für Leute, die ohnehin da sehr, sagen wir, staatsskeptisch sind, die Technologie, auf die sie gewartet haben. Und zugleich ist das jetzt die große Möglichkeit, auf einen Hype aufzuspringen. Denn sicher wird doch sein, das war ja auch etwas, was du schon mal angesprochen hattest. Eben reden wir bei den Bürgeräten über was, was bald passé ist. Und dann reden wir nicht mehr drüber, wenn der vierte Bürgerrat stattfindet. Hier würde ich auch sagen, jetzt hat man mal eine Kolumne, ein Bild, Jingles, das hat man mal alles gemacht. Es werden noch so ein paar Dinge kommen, die man vielleicht noch DNA auch mal noch mal verbunden mit NFT. Da wird es noch mal so ein paar Extreme in die eine oder andere Richtung geht. Da wird man noch mal kurz aufschrecken, aber eher nur noch auf der Panorama-Seite. Und dann wird, glaube ich, diese Internetkunst sehr bald nichts mehr wert sein, sondern da heißt es dann früh aussteigen. Gewinn mit Name schadet nie.
Vor allem hier werden Passwörter verkauft am Ende. Das bedeutet ja auch, üblicherweise kaufst du ja Kunst, um die dann in dein Wohnzimmer zu hängen. Und jeder, der durch dieses Wohnzimmer läuft, wird darauf aufmerksam. Und du kannst dann wieder die tolle Geschichte erzählen, die dich mit dem Kunstwerk verbindet. Passwörter heißt, du musst es vor jedem verstecken. Und wehe, du verlierst es. Dann ist sozusagen, ja. Und da muss man sich auch die Anreize noch mal, also es sind halt wirklich jetzt die Pionierleistungen, die da irgendwie abgeleistet werden. Aber welche Anreize stecken da dahinter, als Passwörter zu kaufen und zu sagen, ich habe aber hier 70.000 Passwörter. Wie gesagt, beim Gaming ist was anderes. Da haben die NFTs wirklich funktionalen Charakter. Da kann man mit denen was machen. Mit diesem Kunstmarktzeug ist das nicht so. Und bei Finn Kliemann würde ich sagen, ich habe das ja auch damals verfolgt, wie das so losging bei ihm mit seinem YouTube-Kanal, wo er einfach nur diese GoPro-Videos gemacht hat, wie er da irgendwas aufräumt. Und mittlerweile ist ja so eine Welt angekommen, wo man wirklich sagen muss, Geld korrumpiert. Denn mehr als 5000 Euro im Monat braucht niemand zum Leben. Und da gehe ich mal davon aus, die hat er. Und jetzt macht er irgendwelche Verträge mit Netflix, wo wir gleich wissen, das ist immer so gleich sechsstellig und so weiter. Und Finn Kliemann wirklich jetzt bei sich zu Hause überlegt, wie könnte ich denn das jetzt noch monetarisieren? Wie könnte ich denn das jetzt noch finanzialisieren? Da muss man sich ja wirklich Gedanken machen langsam, hat er überhaupt noch Lust, irgendwas zu machen, wenn er nicht ein Preisschild dranhängen kann?
Ja, man sieht doch auch da seine ganze Lagerhalle irgendwo mit den ganzen Merch-Kram schon.
Also damals, als es losging bei ihm, war richtig klar, der Typ macht das aus purer Lust. Der gräbt jetzt seinen Garten um, baut sich einen Pool, baut sich einen Hühnerstall, weil er einfach Lust drauf hat. Und dann konnte man da richtig teilnehmen, sagen ich habe jetzt Lust, mir das anzugucken. Und wenn man sich jetzt nach diesen Jahren diese Doku mit Olli Schulz anguckt, kriegt man eine Gänsehaut.
Du musst das kurz sagen, was da los ist. Die haben das Hausbrot von Gunter Gabriel. Hey, hey, baust du dich, ich brauche mehr Geld.
Genau, und der hat da seit 40 Jahren nichts mehr drin gemacht. Das Ding ist total verrottet, also mussten sie jetzt komplett aufbauen. Also was heißt, sie mussten, sie wollten es halt. Und diese Herangehensweise, also wir zeigen drei Minuten lang, was sie machen und dann kommt eine Minute lang, sie sitzen vor der Kamera und erzählen, was sie da machen. Und diese Herangehensweise, jung 14-Jährigen nochmal tief schnaufend und ausatmet und stöhne zu erzählen, da haben wir uns ja ganz schön was eingebrockt hier. Und den Olli Schulz, den habe ich ja auch gerade erst kennengelernt. Das war voll die spontane Idee. Und jetzt machen wir das hier halt. Oder du denkst, mach es halt nicht irgendwie. Das macht echt keinen Spaß, dir bei dem Scheiß jetzt zuzugucken, wie du uns jetzt Schauspielerst.
Ja, wie so Produktionen in Planung sind und alles. Das ist ja wirklich, wenn ich jetzt eine Home-Story machen würde und überrascht wäre, wenn das Kamerateam vor der Tür steht. Oh, ah, Besuch. Das ist super schön. Kommen Sie doch rein.
Wenn man nur ein bisschen weiß, wie es im Medienbusiness abgeht, dann kriegt man wirklich den Ekel, weil die das nicht mehr verstecken können, was wie eine riesige Manufaktur dahintersteckt, dann plötzlich ganz spontan da irgendwas zu machen. Das ist wirklich schlimm.
Ich muss wirklich an der Medienkompetenz zweifeln so sehr, denn wir müssen jetzt gerade darüber sprechen, weil du das so schön da hinleitest. Es gibt diese NDR-Doku Lovemobil. Und da wird gerade diskutiert, oh, das ist ja alles insiniert, wie kann denn das sein? Und wir hatten gedacht, das sei authentisch. Also es geht um eine Dokumentation. Viele werden sie vielleicht gesehen haben, preisgekrönt, jetzt wäre die Preis wieder zurückgegeben. Da geht es um Prostituierte, die in solchen Wohnmobilen sind, die zu sehr prekären Bedingungen und unsicheren Bedingungen arbeiten. Für wenig Geld dann dort sexuelle Dienste. Dann gibt es eine Dokumentation darüber. Da hat sich im Nachhinein herausgestellt, das meiste, was dort zu sehen ist, die meisten Frauen, wie auch die Szenen mit den Freiern, sind gestellt von Schauspielern. Das hat die Regisseurin nicht transparent gemacht. Das ist auch der große Fehler. Auch hat sie mit den Leuten, die sie engagiert, nicht von Anfang an gesagt, was sie davor hat, sondern die glaubten, sie spielen in einem Spielfilm an sich. Es war aber eine Dokumentation, wie auch immer. Jetzt ist man aber dazu gekommen und hat gesagt, das ist also alles gefaked. Dann gab es eine merkwürdige SDRGF-Doku, die das jetzt aufgerollt hat, die auch in höchstem Maße fictionalisiert ist. Dass man dringend aus einem Auto fahrt, anruft, ich stehe jetzt hier, jetzt werden wir den und den treffen. Man weiß einfach, wie kamerativ die funktionieren. Da wird dann noch gesagt, kannst du noch mal die Straße runterfahren und noch mal sagen, mach doch lieber so. Also jede Dokumentation hat einen fiktionalen Anteil. Naja, jedenfalls ist das so interessant, dass man hier natürlich hätte sagen müssen, man musste Dinge nachstellen und hätte das auch transparent machen können. Aber der Glaube, man kommt an was Authentisches, ich mach jetzt so ein Faktencheck-Doku als Faktencheck, da du hattest das auch gepostet, da gab es ein ganz gutes Interview mit Sabine Rollberg. Genau, und die Rollberg sagt ja als Dokumentarfilm-Expertin, nein, das ist eine unglaublich verkürzte Weise, und das sieht man schon daran, dass die Leute immer Dokumentation sagen, sie meinen einfach, das ist Wirklichkeit. Aber natürlich ist Dokumentarfilm immer die Inszenierung von Wirklichkeiten, sie sagt dann, was glauben sie denn, wie das bei anderen Redaktionen ist, und dann erzählt sie, sie hat bei Monitor, war das glaube ich, gearbeitet.
Ja, sie hat damals ganz früh bei Monitor, und sie sagt dann, sie ist vom Glauben abgefallen, wie sehr die Kamerateams ihre Protagonisten striezen, bis sie dann genau das Zitat bekommen, das sie für ihren 3-Sekunden-Einblender in ihrem Film dann brauchen. Und das betrifft alle, und das ist ganz interessant, also bei Übermedien, Holger ruft an, Nummer 21, die Sabine Rollberg dreht das dann so, dass ihr die Regisseurin dieses kleinen Filmchens wirklich leidtut. Weil der Sender gibt das erste in Auftrag, wenn du minutiös, sekundengenau dargelegt hast, was passiert in diesem Film, dann nicken die das ab, und dann musst du das abliefern. Und wenn dir das nicht gelingt, sind deine Verträge alle futsch. Also hat sie gedacht, bevor ich jetzt hier, was weiß ich, 30.000 Euro und so weiter, das war mein Halbjahresplan, dann fake ich halt lieber irgendwas. Weil am Ende ist ja eh egal. Die haben es halt so bestellt. Irgendwer muss es jetzt so sagen. Also hat sie sich dann Freunde beholt, die das dann einfach mal so sagen. Und das ist halt, also in diesem Gespräch...
Und ich glaube, der Film, ich habe ihn jetzt nur in Auszügen gesehen, ist trotzdem wahrscheinlich ein guter Film. Und sie hat ja dann irgendwo gesagt, dass sie da zwar auf Schauspieler gesetzt hat, aber dass ihre Fiktion näher an der Realität ist, als die Realität. Weil sie natürlich diese Frauen aufgrund von verschiedenen Dingen nicht einfach so filmen kann, die nicht gefilmt werden wollten. Und natürlich ganz problematisch wird es, wenn man jetzt sagt, da kommen Freier und man sagt, guten Tag, wir sind hier ein Kamerateam, können wir mal dabei sein, wenn sie schon mal das Hemd ausziehen? Natürlich nicht. Und man sieht es auch diesen Szenen an. Das muss ja eigentlich jeder erkennen, dass das nicht so sein kann. Und da fand ich das auch nochmal so toll, wie sich so ein Jan Böhmer-Mann darüber dann auch aufregte, über diesen Satz, dass diese fiktionale Sache näher an der Realität dran ist. Und da würde ich mal sagen, ja, genau, das ist nämlich Film. Deswegen gehe ich zum Beispiel ins Kino, weil das so ist. Also Slavoj Zizek hat das immer so schön auf den Punkt gebracht. Es ist nicht so, dass man sich vor der Wirklichkeit flüchtet ins Kino. Man geht, man hält die Wirklichkeit nicht aus, dann geht man ins Kino und erfährt. Da ist die Wirklichkeit noch viel wirklicher. Und dann flüchtet man sich zurück in die profane Realität. Insofern wird das einfach nicht verstanden. Also da wäre auch einfach mal angesagt, das Buch, das wir besprochen haben, von Bruno Marquez mal zu lesen über Fiktionalisierung.
Wir stellen uns jetzt zum Abschluss, zumindest von meiner Seite, noch eine große Frage. Wieso haben die Amerikaner so wahnsinnig viel Geld? Und mit wahnsinnig viel Geld meine ich mehr Geld als denkbar ist, mehr Geld als man ausgeben kann, mehr Geld als man braucht. Sie haben so unfassbar viel Geld, dass sich beispielsweise die Moderatoren bei CBS This Morning schon nochmal darüber verständigen müssen, vor ihr Publikum das Trillion tatsächlich mit T geschrieben.
Jetzt kommt ein massiver, potenzieller neuen Spendenpush aus der Biden-Administration.
So, drei Trillionen, also auf Deutsch Billionen. In Deutschland hat man sich ja darauf verständigt, Millionen und Milliarden mit der gleichen Buchstaben beginnen zu lassen. Die Amerikaner waren nicht so blöd. Die sagen, können einfach unterscheiden zwischen million, billion, trillion. Jetzt sind es mittlerweile bei trillion angekommen. Als ich diesen Podcast hier geplant habe, ich, wir liegen am Ende des Monats, dachte ich mir am Anfang des Monats, da kommen die 1, 9 Trillionen Billionen von beiden, die er da schon durchs Parlament gewunken hat. Die mache ich schnell im Fernsehpodcast weg. Da ist Thomas da, da können wir amerikanisches Fernsehen gucken. Habe ich das Thema eigentlich für mich abgehakt. Wache ich am nächsten Morgen auf und lese 1, 9 Millionen durch, jetzt stehen 3 Trillionen hier auf dem, das ist wirklich unglaublich. Also die Amerikaner wollen, nachdem sie jetzt, und Biden ist noch keine 200 Tage, oder was, wie lange ist er jetzt im Amt? Also es ist im Januar, ja, und es ist jetzt März. Im Januar kam Biden ins Amt, und zwar Ende Januar, und jetzt haben wir Ende März, und 1, 9 Billionen Dollar sind fast schon ausgeliefert. Biden hat jetzt in seiner ersten Pressekonferenz noch mal dargelegt, ja, ja, so und so viele Millionen Menschen haben jetzt ihre 1.400 Dollar pro Person nicht. Kinder einbezogen, also fünf Haushalte haben jetzt einfach mal 7.000 Dollar bekommen und so, ne? Also da ist jetzt doch einiges in Bewegung, und jetzt stellt sich plötzlich raus, aha, 3 Trillionen, sie wollen noch mal nachlegen, die 1, 9 Billionen haben nicht gereicht. Und wir beginnen mal bei der Frage, was ist das für Geld? Wo kommt denn das eigentlich her? Und das erfahren wir hier bei Fox Business.
Und wir sagen, so ganz stimmt es nicht.
So, wenn das bei Fox Business kommt, ist das als Warnung zu verstehen, weil da schauen ergeblich nur die Reichen und die Unternehmer zu. So, drei Trillionen und dann übersteuern. Ach, so große Scheiße. Also wenn das wahr wäre, müsste Biden, kann es Amerika privatisieren. Denn es ist so viel Geld, wie auch die Amerikaner nicht einfach so aus ihrem laufenden Cashflow rausziehen können. Und sagen wir, wir schöpfen mal absteuern.
Da müsste man schon heftig enteignen. Also da wäre aber möglich kein Stein auf dem anderen.
Und es wird nicht enteignet. Und die Steuern werden wahrscheinlich auch erst mal nicht erhöht. Über Steuern reden wir nachher. Denn wir wissen, das ist hier ein Lieblingsthema. Wir haben letztens im Mai 2020 schon darüber gesprochen. Das ist natürlich Geld, das einfach über Schulden geschöpft wird. Das wird einfach in den Prozess hinzugeführt, addiert. Das wird niemanden vorher weggenommen. Das ist einfach neu da. Das Prinzip kennen wir ja. Modern Monetary Theory war lange eine Theory. Jetzt ist es aber 100 Prozent Praxis. Also jetzt ist das einfach so.
Wann mit einer Entscheidung über den Antrag zu rechnen ist, ist derzeit offen. Es ist im Moment auch nicht klar, warum das Bundesverfassungsgericht es für notwendig hielt, Steinmeier explizit zu untersagen, seine Unterschrift unter das Deutsche Zustimmungsgesetz zu setzen. Eine solche Anordnung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts ist jedenfalls äußerst ungewöhnlich. Eine Begründung für den Beschluss veröffentlichte das Gericht zunächst nicht. Sie soll später nachgereicht werden. Die Kläger meinen, dass eine gemeinschaftliche Verschuldung auf EU-Ebene nicht zulässig ist und gegen das Grundgesetz verstößt. Die EU, so argumentieren sie, dürfe keine Kredite aufnehmen. Nach den europäischen Verträgen sei die EU vielmehr verpflichtet, ihren Haushalt vollständig aus Eigenmitteln zu finanzieren. Schulden seien aber keine Eigenmittel, sondern Fremdkapital. Im Übrigen ginge Deutschland sollte der EU-Corona-Fonds Wirklichkeit werden. Es gibt unkalkulierbare finanzielle Risiken ein. Weiterer Kritikpunkt der Kläger, wer das Geld anderer Staaten ausgeben, dürfe der Neige zu Verschwendung und Ineffizienz. Dies führe letztlich zu einer Vergemeinschaftung der Schulden und damit zu einer Schuldenunion.
So klingt das beim Deutschlandfunk.
Die Schuldenunion.
Oh, böse, böse, böse. Im Mai war es, glaube ich, dass wir darüber gesprochen hatten, dass zum einen Frankfurter Steinmeier Draghi, dem ehemaligen EZB-Chef, das Bundesverdienstkreuz dafür gibt, dass er standgehalten hat, als die Märkte, also die 3000 reichen Leuten, die hier die Maßgebenden sind, sagten nur, wenn ihr das mit dem Euro so und so macht, dann witten wir dagegen und dann setzen wir euch unter Druck. Und dann meinte Draghi, ne, wenn ihr jemand Geld braucht, also wenn ein Staat in Europa Geld braucht, ruft in Frankfurt an, wir schicken es euch. Genau.
Und Güter hat er dann zitiert, ne?
Er hat dann nochmal in seiner Dankssagung die deutsche Literatur rausgeholt, genau. Und der Hinweis war immer, 2008 war ein großer Fehler, nämlich Griechenland zum Beispiel nicht mit Geld zu unterstützen, weil dann sagen die Märkte einfach, ach so, auf Staatsanleihen gibt es dort 17 Prozent, na dann investieren wir doch mal da rein. Aber eben nur für 17 Prozent, also gegen diese Zinsen immer höher. Und dann hat man irgendwie umgeschwenkt und gesagt, nee, das ist irgendwie nicht sinnvoll, dass jetzt alle griechischen Flughäfen plötzlich Fraport in Frankfurt gehören, nur weil irgendwer meint, wir geben euch mal kein Geld, es ist doch Geld da. Also hat die EZB dann umgeschwenkt und gesagt, wir geben euch Geld. Dann kam Lagarde ins Amt, dann kam Corona und dann hieß es, wir machen jetzt hier mal Rettungspakete, ja, Pandemic, Emergency und so weiter. Wir pumpen jetzt mal richtig Geld rein. Und dann hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht in einem schon gar nicht mehr relevanten Fall gesagt, das war falsch, das Geld muss jetzt zurückgezahlt werden. Es ging um 500 Milliarden. Und dann haben wir uns noch drüber lustig gemacht, dass Herr Gauweiler Angst davor hatte, dass er als Steuerzahler dafür gerade stehen muss, wenn die EZB von Deutschland 500 Milliarden, wir haben damals schon keinen Begriff gefunden, Rückzahlung, Schuldentilgung, wie auch immer. Weil die EZB hat das jetzt allein gekauft.
Gauweiler hätte es, glaube ich, fast privat auch stemmen können. So viel, wie der nebenher verdient.
Gauweiler hat sich diese Arbeit, die er da beim Bundesverfassungsgericht geleistet hat, gut bezahlen lassen. Professor Schachtschneider hat ihm irgendwelche Texte geschrieben. Die hat er dann in Rechnung gestellt, bei irgendeinem Milliardär. Und dann war er plötzlich 10 Millionen Euro reicher und wie auch immer.
Hans-Werner Sinn, ihr auch mit von der Partie, habt ihr gelesen. Er hat auch einen Gutachten geschrieben. Also man stellt sich das so vor, Hans-Werner Sinn klappt den Laptop auf, schreibt mal was nieder, was er so von der ganzen Sache hält und vor sich Schulden. Und was bekommt er dafür? 59.500 Euro.
Genau, da hat Ole ein sehr lustigen Tweet zugeschrieben. Das fand ich auch witzig. Also Hans-Werner Sinn. Das ist unglaublich. Jedenfalls dieser kleine Clip, den wir gerade gehört haben, der verbietet, das Bundesverfassungsgericht ohne Angabe von Gründen unterbietet dem Bundespräsidenten, das Gesetz zu unterschreiben, das der Bundestag schon verabschiedet hat und das Merkel letzten Sommer in Europa vereinbart hat, nämlich, dass die Europäische Kommission erstmals selber Schulden aufnimmt, und zwar 750 Milliarden Euro, Next Generation EU, Corona-Hilfe usw. Da gab es ja dann viel Streit, weil die Ungarn da irgendwie ihren Rechtsstaatsmechanismus abwehren wollten, indem sie das nochmal mit Veto blockiert haben usw. Jetzt ist das Gesetz fertig. Und jetzt kann dieses Geld nicht ausgezahlt werden, was ganz konkret bedeutet, Italien kann gerade keine Kurzarbeitgelder zahlen, weil da einfach 39 Milliarden fehlen in der Rechnung usw. Uns in Deutschland betrifft es nicht allzu sehr, weil wir können ja alles selber stemmen, toll, aber Europa eben nicht. Und dem Bundespräsidenten wurde jetzt verboten, dieses Gesetz zu unterschreiben. Das heißt, bis auf weiteres erstmals, das Bundesverfassungsgericht wird dann noch nachliefern, darf die EU-Kommission keine eigenen Schulden machen. Wir haben also jetzt einen Widerspruch zwischen der europäischen und der amerikanischen Herangehensweise an die Herausforderungen der nächsten Jahre. Und der könnte nicht krasser sein. In Amerika sagt die neue amerikanische Regierung, Corona hat hier so ein paar Probleme verursacht. Wir lösen jetzt einfach mal alle über Corona hinaus. Wir gehen jetzt mal richtig all in. Wir investieren jetzt einfach 5 Trillionen, also Billionen Dollar. Ich weiß noch, im Wahlkampf war es total krass, dass Bernie Sanders meinte, wir bräuchten ein richtig krasses Konjunkturprogramm. Wir sollten die nächsten 10 Jahre eine Billion ausgeben, nämlich jedes Jahr 100 Milliarden in Infrastruktur investieren. Neue Straßen, neue Kabel, damit es nicht in Texas zu Stromausfällen kommt und so. Und alle so, jedes Jahr 100 Milliarden. Hast du eine Meise, wie soll das denn funktionieren? Jetzt haben sie es einfach mal 5 genommen und die Jahre ein bisschen zusammengedampft. Also wir sind jetzt so im Faktor 10 ist die Realpolitik jetzt angekommen. Und in Europa, wo wir mehr politischen, mehr ökonomische Probleme haben durch Corona, ist jetzt gerade gar nichts erlaubt. Die Europäische Union steht still und die nationalen Länder, also die Mitgliedstaaten, die es brauchen, können sich gerade nicht verschulden. Weil es ja nicht ihre Zentralbank, die können ja nicht einfach da anrufen und sagen, schickt mal Geld, sondern die sind darauf angewiesen, dass es die Programme gibt. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt mal darüber reden, warum. Also heute legen wir den Grundstein dafür, warum wir in neun Jahren die Bilanz ziehen. Amerika, bestes Land der Welt, da wollen wir alle hin. Das ist die neue Traumfabrik. Go West wieder reinstitutionalisiert. China alt geworden, hat den Reichtum dann doch nicht geschafft, den Sprung in den Reichtum gekommen, alt wurde. Amerika ist das Land, wo wir alle unsere Kinder hinstiegen wollen. Europa wird da niederliegen, wenn sich nichts ändert an der jetzigen Lage. Das erklären wir jetzt anhand von Stephanie Kelton. Unter anderem eine Wirtschaftsprofessorin, ganz bekannte in Amerika, absolute Vorreiterin. Genau, bei MMT, sie ist da ganz vorn drin. Und sie berät nicht einfach nur Joe Biden, sondern sie schreibt ihm sozusagen. Wir sind jetzt richtig mittendrin. Das sind die Leute, die in Amerika diese Programme entwickeln.
Und Kelton hat vorher auch für AOC und Sanders gearbeitet, hat dort beraten. Und die haben ja viel von ihrem Green Deal mit aufgenommen von der MMT. Und da sieht man auf dieser Beraterebene, dass da doch von dem linken Flügel sehr viel rübergegangen ist. Und vielleicht ist das sogar noch entscheidender als jetzt was für Posten an wen genau gehen. Denn ich erinnere mich noch sehr gut an irgend so einen merkwürdigen Auftritt von Hillary Clinton. Bei Howard Stern, wo sie dann sich lustig machte über Senders, der Forderungen hatte, wie Infrastruktur, wie kostenlose Bildung, ha ha ha, chocolate milk for everyone und so. Und hier sieht man aber, naja, diese Botschaft ist angekommen, indem man überhaupt Stephanie Kelton vorlässt, mit beiden zu sprechen.
Genau, es ist ganz verrückt. Vor zwei Jahren haben wir noch gelitten darunter, dass Bernie Sanders mal wieder keine Chance hat. Ich habe sehr Elizabeth Warrens nicht genutzten Chancen nachgetrauert. Keiner von denen hätte so ein Programm jetzt durchsetzen können, wie das Joe Biden jetzt gerade macht. Denn er kommt eben nicht mit dieser Attitüde, ich krempel hier alles auf links und so weiter, sondern da läuft es einfach so unter der Hand jetzt irgendwie. Das, was wir jetzt hier erleben, sind Programme, also ich kenne, es gibt ja kein Szenario, dass das anders möglich gewesen wäre. Mit dem Vorschlaghammer ging es jedenfalls nicht, sondern hier musste jetzt, glaube ich, so ein Sleepy Joe irgendwie ran, dem man das eigentlich nicht zutraut und dann unter der Hand, ich könnte mir vorstellen, AOC und so weiter, die könnten nicht glücklicher sein mit der Lage gerade, denn da werden einfach politische Wünsche erfüllt. Und diese Stephanie Kelton ist hier bei David McWilliams zugeschaltet, in der 119. Ausgabe, die sich sehr lohnt, nochmal nachzuhören für alle Interessierten. Und sie schlägt uns gleich zu Beginn erstmal die Begriffe Staatsschuld und Leihen, also Geld leihen aus der Hand.
Also sehen wir die Regierung, die Bonds ausüben, und wir sagen, oh, das ist Begriffe. Und dann sehen wir die Bonds und sagen, oh, das ist Leiden. Und dann denken wir darüber, was es für uns bedeuten würde, wenn wir auf Leiden steigen würden und es in den Zukunft zurückbekommen hätten. Während der Zeit, in der die Stücke verkauft werden, ist die Spende bereits in der Hand.
Zwischen ich glaube, Felbermaier und Südekommen eine Diskussion im Handelsblatt und Felbermaier hat dann auch nochmal direkt Venezuela gesagt und dann sagte Südekommen, naja, sie kommen aber jetzt gleich mit dem Totschlagargument daher. Ja, vielleicht ist ja Venezuela auch sonst nicht das stabilste Land der Welt. Könnte man ja mal kurz darüber nachdenken. Und warum ist das jetzt in den USA ein bisschen leichter mit einem stabilen System, mit einer Wirtschaft, die auch noch was produziert, die innovativ ist und all das. Das heißt, dieses Tischlein deckt dich, ist selbstverständlich an was geknüpft, aber das wäre ja ohne weiteres auch auf die EU übertragbar.
Genau, da können wir ja gleich mal vorausgreifen. Also am 24.3. gab es im Handelsblatt dieses Streitgespräch. Das ist ganz interessant, dass mittlerweile der Felbermaier da nicht einfach so Texte schreiben kann, sondern wenn diese Seite noch, also die Hans-Werder-Sinn, Felbermaier-Füßt, keine Ahnung, die müssen sich immer in einem Streitgespräch stellen. Da steht dann einfach darüber, du kommst gleich mit der Winde zur Elakkeule, wow. Und da wissen wir gleich, dass er Südekum gesagt zu ihm, während Südekum da durchaus Kolumnen schreibt, ohne Gegenrede. Also mittlerweile ist ja beim Handelsblatt auch einiges los. Im Handelsblatt gab es am 29.3. und das macht diesen Unterschied aus, den du genannt hast, einen Text vom Präsidenten der griechischen Zentralbank, Yannis Stourananaras, oder irgendwie so, mit der Überschrift, jetzt ist die Zeit für noch mutigere fiskalische Maßnahmen der EU. Also, in den USA war die fiskalische Reaktion viel ausgeprägter als in der EU, als Anteil am Protoinlandsprodukt bisher mehr als doppelt so groß, obwohl der Rückgang der US-Produktion im vergangenen Jahr geringer war als in der EU. Wenn die Europäische Union, also wie die Amerikaner jetzt reagieren würden, würden sie 4 Trillionen auf den Schuldenstand schreiben. Weiter hier ein Zitat, in Anbetracht der derzeitigen Komplementarität zwischen Geld- und Fiskalpolitik ist jetzt die Zeit für noch mutigere fiskalische Maßnahmen in der EU, bis eine Dauer-After-Erholung eintritt. Was fiskalisch bedeutet, klären wir gleich anhand der Clips. Und seine Pointe unten ist, der Weg in die Zukunft besteht darin, gleichzeitig die Maßnahmen zur Risikoteilung und Minderung zu verstärken und, jetzt ganz wichtig, schrittweise zu einer zentralisierten Finanzpolitik überzugehen, um eine ausgewogene Wirtschaftsentwicklung im Euro-Raum zu erreichen. Also er wünscht sich mehr europäisches Geld und mehr europäische Politik, die mit diesem Geld etwas macht. Das meint fiskalisch. Und das klären wir jetzt mal anhand dieser Clips von Kelton. Was, wenn wir jetzt nicht mehr von Schulden sprechen, wovon eigentlich dann? Sie hat ja eben schon von Währungen genannt. Staatsanleihen sind auch eine Währung. Das sind gar keine Schuldscheine, sondern das sind eine Währung. Was ist denn das für eine Idee? Sie führt es hier mal aus.
Und das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel.
Das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, das ist ein Zettel, Man könnte man vielleicht sogar ein Haus kaufen, ne?
Man muss sich nur mit dem Verkäufer einig sein, dass man auch Staatsanleihen akzeptiert. Aber warum nicht?
Stell einfach drauf, dass es so ein Stück wert ist. Das heißt, eine Staatsanleihe von Deutschland nimmt man gerne, eine Staatsanleihe von Venezuela eher nicht. Und dann kann man dann vertrauen, denn man muss ja immer einkalkulieren, wenn eine deutsche Staatsanleihe nicht mehr bedient wird, dann heißt das ein bisschen mehr als nur, die wird nicht mehr bedient, sondern dann kam entweder ein Weltkrieg dazwischen oder eine Atombombe oder sonst irgendwas, und dann ist eh egal. Naja, der amerikanischen Staat jedenfalls, und das ist dann die zweite Komponente, einerseits stabile Länder, das ist in Europa soweit gegeben. Und dann ganz wichtig, das zirchlein deckt nicht, also die Zentralbank, die muss in einer eigenen Verfügbarkeit sein. Also die steht einfach im eigenen Keller, nicht beim Nachbarn oder so, sondern steht im eigenen Keller. Das ist ja in Washington gegeben, und ich sage schon mal gleich, also in Europa nicht. Wir haben die Länder keine Hoheit über die einzige Entität, die Euros rausgeben darf, und das ist die Europäische Zentralbank und nicht die nationalen.
Wie Alan Greenspan gesagt hat, die Wahrscheinlichkeit der Befalt in unserer eigenen Befalt ist zero.
Ja, also Länder wie Amerika können einfach nicht pleite gehen, weil sie ja immer wieder neuen Geldschein, also Staatsanleihe rausholen können. Und sie drucken ja immer gleichzeitig den grünen und den gelben Dollar, also ein echtes Geld und eine Staatsanleihe. Und nun endlich.
Lass uns ganz kurz einhaken, denn erstmal ist das so sehr verständlich und sobald man sich aber dann zwei, drei weitere Fragen stellt, kommt man schon wieder ins Krübeln und denkt, naja, aber wenn das jetzt so leicht ist, dann könnte man doch einfach so viel Geld austeilen, dass alle 2000 Euro mehr haben. Also theoretisch könnten die das natürlich machen, aber dann wird irgendwann ein System auch instabil. Denn natürlich geht es bei dieser Idee, man kann jetzt wieder Geld drucken dafür, dass man Investitionen machen kann. Auch darum, dass man schaut, riskieren wir eine Inflation. Also ein bisschen inflationärer darf es sein. Wir haben ja eher ein Problem der Deflation gehabt, hatten wir auch schon mal gesprochen. Aber selbstverständlich ist das nicht der Freifahrtschein jetzt dafür, dass das jetzt Milch und Honig für alle laufend bedeutet, sondern auch steht da noch ein Faktor Arbeit da. Also das kann jetzt nicht sein, dass wir sagen, wir teilen einfach nur noch Geld aus oder so. Also es geht hier auch immer darum, das an Investitionen zu knüpfen. Und das heißt, man kann auch darüber nachdenken, wie werden denn Steuern eigentlich verwendet und wofür werden sie verwendet? Weil diese Rückzahlung, was ja da bei Fox, du hast es eben eingeblendet, so gesagt wird, die Reichen werden jetzt besteuert, die Unternehmen werden jetzt besteuert, damit wir diese Fantastereien mitmachen können. So ist es ja nicht.
Genau. Wir dröhnen ganz langsam auf. Auf Steuern und Inflation können wir beides noch zu sprechen. Denn vorher ist ja noch die Frage erstmal der akuten Hilfe. Also wir brauchen jetzt, nehmen wir mal den Theaterintendanten und seine Schauspieler, die können gerade nicht Geld verdienen und die brauchen trotzdem Geld. Könnte man denen jetzt einfach Geld geben, ohne Gegenleistung? Und die Antwort ist bis hierher ja, der Staat muss es einfach nur entscheiden. Gibt er einfach Geld und sagt, bitte ausgeben, hier habt ihr es, bringt es in den Kreislauf, versorgt euch vor allem, bleibt am Leben, bis ihr dann wieder selber tätig werden könnt. Genau. Und das könnte man ja, und da ist die Kritik auch völlig berechtigt, aber es gibt eben, das steckt dann alles in der Theorie drin, man könnte sich jetzt durchaus, sagen wir so, aus der deutschen Richtung, der Hans-Werner-Sinn-Füßt-Feldammeier-Dingsrichtung, könnte man sich durchversagen, der aber dann druckt ja der Staat nur noch Geld und keiner arbeitet mehr. Und dann muss man sagen, ja, das stimmt. Also das Szenario ist durchaus denkbar. Das ist jetzt in der Theorie nicht ausgeschlossen, denn wir haben ja eben gesagt, es ist natürlich leicht, denke ich, solange da Geld fließen soll, fließt da Geld. Also Deutschland könnte jetzt durchaus einfach jeden Deutschen 5000 Euro zahlen, dann müsste man 5000 mal 80 Millionen aufrechnen, das als Schulden aufnehmen. Und es ginge.
Ja, hat Effekte dann zwar und darüber muss man sich im Plan sein und deswegen macht man es vielleicht nicht.
Und deswegen hat man ja auch Politik, damit die da, Achtung, steuernd eingreifen kann. Also da kommt auch Begriff Steuer her. Jetzt sind wir aber erstmal bei diesem akuten Problem. Wir haben ja hier was zu lösen und man hat eine Lehre von 2008, nämlich dass es an Geld damals nicht gemangelt hat, sondern...
Und das Problem ist, wie Jerome Powell so wiegt, der currente FED-Chair, die FED kann lenden, aber die FED kann nicht spenden.
Und das betrifft die EZB ganz konkret. Also Christine Lagarde lässt keinen Monat verstreichen, indem sie ihr Presse-Dings da macht und sagt, die Länder sollen jetzt mal das Geld ausgeben. Bitte zahlt Kurzarbeitergeld. Bitte bezahlt den Leuten die Solaranlage auf dem Dach. Die Italiener machen das dann. Da wird einfach deine Solaranlage zu 100 Prozent vom Staat bezahlt. Außer in Deutschland, da verfängt das irgendwie noch nicht so. Weil hier ist ja noch genug. Das Kurzarbeitergeld kommt natürlich aus Berlin. Olaf Scholz hat es verabschiedet und gemacht. Das kommt nicht aus der EZB und so weiter. Und das ist die große Lehre von 2008. Die Zentralbanken hatten genug Geld, aber die Politik wusste nicht so genau, was soll man jetzt damit machen? Helikoptergeld? Das war ja irgendwie komisch. Dann wird es instabil. Dann werden die Leute faul und so weiter.
Bloß nicht, dass jetzt auch bei diesen Corona-Hilfen irgendwo noch ein Betrug auftaucht. Dann macht man das lieber so bürokratisch, dass jemand davon abgeschreckt ist. Auch das hätte man ja mit dieser MMT ganz anders regeln können. Ich habe das jetzt mitbekommen von einer Bekannten, die hat Corona-Hilfen für ihr Geschäft beantragt. Also es ging jetzt um den ersten Oktober. Die bekommt jetzt den Brief, dass sie es zurückzahlen muss. Sie bekommt gar nicht die Corona-Hilfe. Und wenn sie jetzt mal schaut, wie viel Zeit sie investiert hat, plus ihr Steuerberater, was das wiederum gekostet hat. Und jetzt ging das dann an ein Amt, das hat das auch nochmal alles durchgesehen. Und jetzt sagt man, ne, ne, es gibt jetzt doch nichts. Denn der Umsatz im nächsten Monat war ja wieder da. Also wenn man sich das alles ansieht, dann merkt man schon, wie falsch diese Corona-Politik läuft. Und was damit auch jetzt eigentlich... Da wurden jetzt ganz viele Bullshit-Jobs wieder ausgeführt. In jeder In-Sicht, ja. Und man hat noch alle unzufrieden gemacht, weil es einfach jetzt am Ende kein Geld gibt.
Genau, und das ist einfach, und das ist auch nicht komplexer oder so, das ist politisch dumm. Es demotiviert die Leute, es unterbricht Kreisläufe, finanzielle Kreisläufe, zum Beispiel im Lokalen. Ja, so jemand kann da nicht einkaufen gehen, kann Mieten nicht bezahlen, da hängt da viel dran. Dann muss sich der Vermieter dann wieder da um irgendwas kümmern und so weiter. Das ist einfach dumm. Und die europäische Politik dazu ist dumm. Und die amerikanische eben nicht, sondern da steht dieses Geld einfach zur Verfügung. Da bekommt man es einfach per Post nach Hause geschickt. Da ist einfach ein Check im Briefkasten, den kann man bedingungslos einlösen und der wird auch nicht nochmal revidiert oder so. Da kann sich jeder sicher sein. Wer den im Briefkasten hatte, ist damit durch. So, wie schaffen das die Amerikaner? Jetzt wird hier nochmal abschließend zum Thema Geldschöpfung von Stephanie Kelton gesagt. Wo kommt das Geld jetzt eigentlich her? In Deutschland ist ja immer noch ganz beliebt die Refinanzierung. Ganz beliebter Begriff. Die allererste Frage, als die Grünen ihr Parteiprogramm vorgestellt werden, war zum Thema wie refinanzieren sie das denn? Und da muss man sagen, da muss man den Leuten auf die Finger klopfen und sagen, nee, hör mal zu, so geht das nicht. Wir können es ja mal kurz hören.
Die Frage ist unlauter, muss man nicht sagen.
Die beiden Grünenchefs sitzen auf der Bühne und sagen, wir müssen jetzt mal die Welt retten und wir wollen dafür 50 Milliarden extra. Das ist ja wohl ein Pups.
Und die haben sich ja noch nicht mal von der Schuldenbremse ganz losgelöst. Die wollen die ja ausweiten. Aber das ist ja jetzt, also verglichen mit Amerika, ist das jetzt nochmal ganz vorsichtig.
Genau, und die erste Frage, die die Grünen bekommen, ist die.
Sie haben die Schuldenbremse, Steuererhöhungen da drin und die Bekämpfung der Steuerflucht. Vielleicht können Sie das mal ein bisschen gegenrechnen, wie Sie da dann sozusagen auf eine vernünftige Gegenfinanzierung kommen wollen.
Ja, können Sie das mal gegenfinanzieren? So, und jetzt sagt die Stephanie Kelton, Refinanzieren haben Sie eine Meise?
Findet es, es ist in einem Höhle auf dem Boden. Und das ist sehr gebrochenes Denken. Also dieses 1, 9-Tribe-Dollar-COVID-Releaf-Package. Wie ist das passiert?
Um.
Alle Fonds, die dem Land aufgrund der US-Betreffung entführt werden, um alle Fonds, die dem Land aufgrund der US-Betreffung entführt werden, um alle Fonds, die dem Land aufgrund der US-Betreffung entführt.
Oh Gott. Grundrente infrage stellen und die Rentner sollen später an Rente gehen. Das sagt jetzt da ein junger Mensch, der ja gewählt wird. Also das ist ja jemand, der im Bundestag sitzt, soweit ich weiß. Und der auch wahrscheinlich wiedergewählt wird. Von Idioten gewählt. Anders kann man das ja nicht ausdrücken.
Also finanzfiskalpolitisch sind wir in der Bananenrepublik in Deutschland. Wir machen wirklich genau das Falsche. Und zwar genau von 180 Grad umgedreht. Was vernünftig mehr, machen wir genau das Falsche. Gut, ich will hier eine klare politische Forderung rausentwickeln. Also denkt jetzt nicht, das schwebt hier alles in der Luft oder so. Sondern es gibt hier eine klare politische Forderung für alle Linken hier im Publikum, die auf der Suche sind. Gleich folgt ein richtig hartes Argument. So, jetzt greifen wir die Frage von eben auf. Aber wenn der Staat jetzt das mit dem Geld alles alleine machen kann, braucht er dann eigentlich meine Steuern noch? Wieso braucht er Einnahmen von mir? Und da hören wir jetzt David McWilliams selbst. Der spricht ja, also der rettet mir diese Interviewpartner und redet dann nachher noch mal mit seinem Companion da. Das macht er so einen kleinen Nachtrag zum Gespräch.
Die Idee, dass es eine nationale Balance-Schicht ist total Nuss. Das ist das Schlüssel, was wir nicht haben.
Die Unterschied zwischen dem Anwalt und dem Nutzer hat keinen Unterschied.
So, wir brauchen es erstmal nicht als Einnahmequelle. Aber, und das ist jetzt der neue Dreh, und deswegen ist das ein politisches Konzept.
Der Unterschied, was Stephanie sagt, ist, dass die Leute sagen, ob ein Politiker überhaupt. Eine Anwalt ist, und wenn wir Inflation sehen, dann erhöhen wir die Kosten. Das macht, dass das Geld aus dem System kommt.
Sie sagt, dass die Anwalt-Deficit ein Verlust von jemand anderem ist.
Das ist die einfache Idee.
Wenn es wirklich reiche Leute sind, wie es so war, wenn Donald Trump die Kosten bezahlt hat, dann haben sie einen Vorteil.
Und die Mandate sind ja weiter die Primären. Sowohl bei der Incent B, da ist das Einzige, die dürfen ja gar nicht groß einmischen, und in Amerika ist immer noch das Inflationsziel 2% maßgebend. Dann allerdings auch schnell die Arbeitsmarktpolitik. Also die FED hat auch den Auftrag, den Arbeitsmarkt gut zu halten. Und in deren Sicht könnte man ja hier sehen, okay, über die Finanzierung der Staatsausgaben haben wir eine Verschuldung. Also wir geben sehr viel Staatsanleihen aus. Das heißt, es ist sehr viel Geld im System. Wir sehen auch gerade, wo es mündet. Die reichsten Männer der Welt besitzen halt jetzt 200 Milliarden und nicht mehr 50 Milliarden wie damals und so.
Die Reichsten sind 2035 Milliarden reicher geworden.
Genau, also es mündet. Es ist kein Kreislauf, sondern es wird sozusagen auf der einen Seite gegeben. Dann gibt man sozusagen den Armen irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Dann sammelt sich das so an und wie das halt so ist. Am Ende sind es halt nur vier Supermarketten, bei denen man einkauft und so. Und dann mündet das halt bei deren Eigentümern und es sind dann irgendwie drei Leute. Und der Reichste davon hat dann irgendwie 200 Milliarden. Oder Amazon. Alle versorgen sich via Amazon und am Ende mündet alles bei Jeff Bezos. Und da könnte man ja einfach sagen, und diese Idee ist ja wirklich clever, so wie Staatsanleihen nicht als Schulden, sondern als Währung zu sehen, zu sagen, wir erhöhen jetzt nicht Steuern, sondern wir belegen ihn einfach mit einer Inflation. Wir warten nicht auf die sozusagen natürliche Inflation, die im Markt für alle gleich entsteht, sondern wir machen einfach eine spezielle Inflation für ihn. Das kann man dann einfach immer noch Steuern nennen, muss man aber nicht. Das kann man dann nennen, wie man will. Man sagt dann einfach, da muss jetzt abgeschöpft werden. Da brauchen wir mal eine Geldentwertung. Und die findet dann da einfach statt. Und dann schöpft man einfach ab. Ich finde, man sollte es Steuern nennen, weil in Steuern steckt eben dieser Begriff Steuern so schön drin. Da kann man die mal so richtig zur Geltung bringen. Aber so kann man es ja machen. Inflation ist sowieso ein eigenes Thema, denn haben wir überhaupt das Problem mit Inflation? Adam Twoes, hier ja bekannt, wir haben schon häufiger gespielt. Ihr habt ihn auch schon bei euch im Podcast gehabt. Der ist ja beim NDR, jetzt ist NDR in die WDR. Also irgendwo gibt es ja diesen Corona- und die Wirtschaft Podcast, in dem sich Adam Twoes und Marcel Fratsche abwechseln. Also da sieht man auch, in Deutschland findet so langsam ein Shift statt. Und da wird ja auch mal so gefragt, ja Inflation, Inflation ist das nicht ein echtes Problem.
Ehrlich gesagt, vom makroökonomischen Gesichtspunkt her gesehen, würde man sich über eine Inflationsrate von 2% freuen. Sollte man sich freuen. Das wäre ein Indiz dafür, dass die Wirtschaft richtig in Fahrt ist. Und das würde auch bei den Schulden helfen. Davon sind wir aber weit entfernt. Und das EZB strampelt, um die längerfristigen Inflationserwartungen auf dieses Niveau zu heben.
Und mit strampeln ist gemeint, bitte gib das Geld aus, liebe Staaten. Bitte bringt das Geld in den Kreislauf. Macht die Sachen verfügbar.
Während konservative Wirtschaftsjournalisten jetzt warnen. Also ich sehe das hin und wieder in der Börsenzeitung dann auch, dass schon ganz düster in die Zukunft geblickt wird. Also man erlebt ja sowieso, gerade wenn es um die Börse geht, immer nur das große Klagen. Also seit 2008 geht es ja nur bergauf. Fünfzehntausender Marke ist jetzt geknackt. Und dennoch jeden Januar eines Jahres gibt es diese großen Artikel. Geht das noch lange gut? Und da treut die Inflation. Es ist jedes Mal dasselbe. Und jetzt hat man dann natürlich ein bisschen Inflation geschaffen. Dadurch, dass Sachen teurer geworden sind, hinzu kommt ja auch die Mehrwertsteuersenkung und jetzt die Erhöhung wieder. Und dadurch hat das natürlich ein... Und dann ist man bei 0, 4, 0, 8 Prozent ist man da mehr. Und sofort sind dann alle ganz aufgeregt. Wie wird das sein? Und dann noch das ganz große Problem, der nachholende Konsum, der jetzt kommen wird. Das heißt, die Leute haben Geld gespart, konnten nicht in Restaurants gehen. Und was dann jetzt erst mal passieren wird. Also jetzt wird schon wieder die große Angst geschürt. Und deswegen ist man da auch dann ratlos, wenn dieselben Leute das dann einordnen sollen, was gerade dann Amerika passiert.
Genau, also hört euch mal Adam Toos an zum Thema. Das ist ganz lustig. Ich habe ja auch noch so einen Clip, aber der ist zu lang. Wie Adam Toos sich darüber lustig macht, dass in Deutschland missverstanden wird, dass Inflation gerade in diesem ein- zweiprozentigen Niveau ja eigentlich anzeigt. Das ist der Hauptindikator dafür, die Wirtschaft läuft wieder. Leute sind bereit zu bezahlen und so weiter. Die Sachen werden jetzt teurer.
Die Inflation wird mehr produziert, haben aber auch Lust, also Nachfrage ist da.
Genau, das ist, was man eigentlich will. Er beantwortet dann deine Frage, warum wird dann so davor gewarnt? Weil sehr viele Marktteilnehmer sich die letzten fünf Jahre darauf eingestellt haben, dass es keine Inflation gibt. Und die sind jetzt halt falsch positioniert. Also ihre eigenen Profite sind in Gefahr, wenn sich jetzt plötzlich alles wieder in die richtige Richtung dreht. Da muss man sich ja vorstellen, wie der ganze Tanker fährt jetzt plötzlich in die andere Richtung durch den Sueskanal. Und das ist für andere, die die Lieferung, auf die Lieferung warten natürlich ein Problem. Und in deren Sicht ist das wirklich witzig. Hören wir mal zu Ende, die EZB strampelt. Sie kriegt es einfach nicht los, das Geld, das sie ja hat. Die Länder machen nicht mit.
Das heißt, es ist im Moment eigentlich gar kein Grund zur Sorge da?
Würde ich sagen, ja. Ich bin wirklich bei der Inflationsangst ein Skeptiker. Die Situation in der Weltwirtschaft hat sich seit den 70er-Jahren, als das letzte Mal die Inflation in den entwickelten Ländern ein Problem war, radikal verändert. Höchstens langfristig, über Jahrzehnte hinaus, könnte man sich vorstellen, dass zum Beispiel bei der Bevölkerung und im Arbeitsmarkt sich Endpässe ergeben würden, die wiederum zu einer strukturellen Veränderung führen würden. Aber im Moment sind wir in einer Situation, wo tendenziell die strukturellen Faktoren zu einer Deflation neigen. Und dafür ist seit den 90er-Jahren Japan das Paradebeispiel.
Ja, das klappt ja nachher gleich noch mal auf. Es ist jetzt Deflation für immer eigentlich. Die große Gefahr ist die Deflation.
Japan hat das Problem, dass die immer weniger produzieren. Das ist jetzt auch noch mal zurückgegangen. Das heißt, die müssten jetzt eigentlich noch mal versuchen, eigentlich noch mal mehr Schulden. Die haben natürlich schon ganz andere Maße Schulden aufgenommen. Das ist ja auch mal so ein Beispiel für die MMTler, aber die ist noch nicht genug.
Nee, Japan droht genau das Gleiche wie Deutschland. Deutschland droht dasselbe, was wir in Japan schon sehen, dass nämlich jedes Jahr das Erwerbspotenzial um 300.000, 400.000 Personen sinkt über mehrere Jahre, wenn nicht Jahrzehnte. Das erleben wir in Deutschland dann auch. Das heißt, die Produktivität müsste, wenn man den Einzelfall, also die wirkliche Handlung in der Fabrik nimmt, um so krass gesteigert werden, um das aufzufangen, das geht gar nicht. Und irgendwo muss das Geld dann herkommen, um Sachen am Laufen zu halten, beispielsweise den Konsum aufrechtzuerhalten. Die alten Rentner und so weiter, die gehen jetzt, die verdienen jetzt Geld ja nicht konkret in der Woche vorher, das sie dann ausgeben mit einer Arbeitsentlohnung am Monatsende, sondern die müssen einfach ausreichend finanziert werden, um am Konsum teilzunehmen, damit überhaupt jemand was herstellt. Und das müssen die in Japan jetzt schon seit Jahren über Anführungszeichen Schulden finanzieren, was aber keinen weh tut, weil die holen sich das einfach bei ihrer eigenen Zentralbank. Der Betischstein deckt dich im Keller und dann wird es 250 Prozent BIP-Schulden. Und das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Und wir in Deutschland, jammern rum, über die 60-70 Prozent. Naja, jetzt kommen wir mal langsam ins Eingemachte. Was ist die europäische Forderung? Was muss sich jetzt wirklich jeder Linker sofort auf Seite 1, so wie Wolfgang, wenn er Bücher liest, gleich auf die Umschlacht sein können? Was muss da jetzt notiert werden? In Europa gibt es einen Geburtsfehler. David McWilliams selbst ihre kennt sich hier aus und erklärt es uns.
Das ist nur die ECB. Nur die Europäische Zentralbank kann das Kurs ausführen. Es gibt einen Design-Floh.
So und das muss echt gelöst werden. Die Europäische Zentralbank kann nur, und das macht sie ja gerade sehr, auch in hohem Maße, aber sehr zurückhaltend, sie verteilt die Schulden an jeden Staat, ob er sie braucht oder nicht. Mittlerweile sind fast die Hälfte der deutschen Staatsanleihen liegen in der EZB, die hat sie gekauft. Wir brauchen dieses ganze Geld gar nicht. Deutschland braucht dieses ganze Geld gar nicht. Wir haben viel zu viel. Die Griechen brauchen das, die Italiener brauchen das. Und die haben aber zu wenig. Und diese Disbalance kriegt man gar nicht ausklamüsert. Und das kann nur über einen Weg vereinheitlicht werden. Und das haben wir gerade im Handelsblatt von Yannis Stourdanas gelesen. Es braucht eine gemeinsame europäische Geldausgabenpolitik. Es kann nur Brüssel entscheiden. Es kann nicht anders gehen.
Es sei denn, man sagt, man geht jetzt zurück in den Nationalstaaten. Aber dann ist auch das Konzept EU zu Ende. Dann ist natürlich auch die EU eigentlich begraben. Dann würde man auch ganz klar sehen, dann sind die Länder die stärksten, die eine starke Wirtschaft haben. Dann kommt Deutschland an der Spitze, dann kommt Frankreich und so. Aber das wäre überhaupt nicht wünschenswert, das so zu tun. Nur müssten dann die Deutschen mal ein bisschen verstehen, dass sie zurück schalten müssen in Gang. Und dass jetzt nicht ständig geklagt wird beim Bundesverfassungsgericht, was die jetzt mit unserem guten Geld da tun. Und das ist so erstaunlich, dass dieser Konstruktionsfehler, der ja noch weiter reicht, Heiner Flassbeck ist ja auch immer jemand, der darauf hingewiesen hat, wenn er kein MMTler ist, aber doch auf diese Fehlkonstruktion hingewiesen hat, ist das doch sehr erstaunlich, dass man einfach mal gesagt hat, wir machen das jetzt mal gerade so und müsste das schon viel früher gelöst haben. Denn diese Idee, man könnte sagen, ach ja, die Bundesbank, das war ja damals, wann ist das gewesen? In den 50er Jahren so eine Idee, die machen jetzt unabhängig von der Politik, damit da nicht so eine Staatsfinanzierung stattfindet. Also da hat man ja eigentlich schon so ein kernneoliberales Element untergebracht. Und dass man sagt dann noch mal Jahrzehnte später, wenn man den Euro-Raum konstruiert mit der EZB, toll, da haben wir doch dieses herrliche Konstrukt aus Deutschland mit der Bundesbank, das übertragen wir auf die EZB und so machen wir das jetzt auch dies jetzt unabhängig. Und jetzt sehen wir aber irgendwie für eine ganz unabhängige Bank, verhält die sich jetzt gerade merkwürdig. Da müssen wir dringend jetzt mal klagen, damit die jetzt nicht machen, was sie wollen.
Und das ist jetzt der große Unterschied. In Amerika platzt jetzt wirklich gerade der Knoten. Da finanziert die Zentralbank jetzt ganz konkrete Politik. Ja, der Kongress entscheidet. Wir zahlen jetzt an jeden, der weniger als 80.000 Dollar im Jahr verdient, 1.400 Dollar. Das Geld wird direkt von der FED ausgezahlt. Das ist, wie soll man sagen, so eine Einkörperideologie, die dahintersteckt. Linke Hand Gesetzgebung, rechte Hand Geldzahlung. Wirklich eins zu eins. Der eine lennnt, der andere spendt. Die schönen Worte hat Kelton ja gerade gegenübergebracht. In Europa ist das natürlich ganz anders. Wir hören ja Adam Toos, die Europäische Zentralbank verwahrt sich ja gegen jeden Eindruck, auf Politik Einfluss zu nehmen, weil das ist ihr verboten. Sie darf die Staaten nicht direkt finanzieren.
Das EZB erfüllt im Grunde einfach nur sein Mandat, indem es alle Mittel verwendet, um diese Inflationserwartungen längerfristig gegen zwei Prozent in diese Richtung zu schieben. Das ist also für sie relativ unproblematisch. Wogegen sie sich sträuben, ist jede Interpretation ihres Handelns, die dahingeht, dass sie im Grunde der Fiskalpolitik unter den Armen greifen. Das wollen sie überhaupt nicht akzeptieren als Argument, als Interpretation. Es hat diesen Effekt und alle wissen es.
Das haben wir im Mai so behandelt. Na klar finanziert die Europäische Natralbank die Staaten, wenn die Hälfte aller Schulden schon bei der EZB liegen. Aber es darf offiziell nicht so heißen, weil ansonsten kommt Peter Gauweiler mit einem von irgendeinem milliardären finanzierten Text von Hans Werner Sehn und Schacht Schneider. Und das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt, ja stimmt, das müssen wir jetzt sofort unterbinden. Jetzt ein kurzes Gedankensszenario. Angenommen, die EZB dürfte das Klima retten, den Arbeitsmarkt ordentlich organisieren, da eingreifen, Kurzarbeitergeld zahlen in Italien, einfach mal direkt und so weiter und so fort. Was wäre denn so möglich, Edentus umrahmt es hier kurz.
Ja, es gibt immer, man sollte Zentralbanken nie attestieren, dass sie keine Mittel mehr haben. Das ist eine Ausrede. Sicherlich gibt es da noch Möglichkeiten. Die Angriffe könnten gesteigert werden. Sie sind immer noch nicht am Maximum in diesem Punkt, denke ich. Vor allem geht es auch darum, gewisserweise Langfristigkeit zu signalisieren und die Ausmaße des Programms auch langfristig anzulegen. Es geht immer um Erwartungen, gerade bei Finanzmärkten. Und die Längerfristigkeit des Programms zu signalisieren, ist sehr wichtig. Es werden Fragen auftauchen in absehbarer Zukunft über die Nachhaltigkeit des Programms. Und das ECB sollte sich da wirklich festnageln. Und dann könnte man wirklich an innovative Techniken denken. Und man könnte die Zinsen noch tiefer in den negativen Bereich verschieben. Also gewisserweise eine gespaltene Zinspolitik betreiben, wo man die Positen, also Sparer, noch positive Zinsen anbietet. Und die Leute, die sich Geld borgen, negative. Das wäre also eine wirklich radikale Politik der Stimulierung, die das ECB angedeutet hat. Sie haben sich ein bisschen in diese Richtung verschoben, aber man könnte da noch viel aktiver werden.
Ich meine, die ECB wird da zum Handeln gezwungen. Das, was die Politik nicht entscheiden will, wenn das jetzt so bleibt, dass die Europäische Kommission nicht mal dann, wenn sie sich das Mandat geholt hat, von allen Mitgliedszentren, weil irgendein Verfassungsgericht meinte, nee, das ist aber mit unseren lokalen Gegebenheiten ja nicht vereinbar, das blockiert. Die ECB wird das ja weiter machen.
Sie wird nicht dazuschauen und warten, bis das irgendwann explodiert. Nur jetzt mal gerade eine Zwischenfrage von mir. Wir haben eben schon über Anne Wilde zurechtgelästert und wir merken jetzt gerade gut, das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen stärker im Diskurs vertreten und nicht so wie in den USA mit Stephanie Kelton und anderen prominenten MMT-Lern und Politikern, die es dann auch ausführen wollen. Aber wir haben das dann mit einem Adam Tooth im Podcast, mit Syrekum im Handelsblatt. Wann glaubst du, ist der Zeitpunkt, bei dem Anne Wilde oder so oder Plasberg irgendeinem Politiker sagen werden, ja, aber das ist ja gar nicht, die schulden das ja gar nicht der nächsten Generation auf. Mit den Schulden ist das ja ganz anders. Das ist doch so und so. Wann glaubst du, wird das passieren, dass ein Moderator dieses MMT-Wissen zur Kenntnis genommen hat, vielleicht so weit internalisiert hat, dass man damit mal jemanden herauskitzelt und nicht immer nur sagt, ja, glauben sie denn, dass Laschet Kanzler kann?
Also wenn Südekum zumindest mal als Gast eingeladen wird, da muss aber erst Corona akut besiegt sein und man muss dann wirklich in die zweite Pandemie Effekte, nämlich dass man dann wirklich sieht, ach so, die Läden machen gar nicht wieder auf. Ich dachte, wenn Corona vorbei ist, machen die Restaurants wieder auf. Ach so, die gibt es gar nicht mehr. Scheiße, die ganzen Innenstädte sind entvölkert oder will auch keiner mehr mieten. Und plötzlich geht dieser ganze 15 Billionen Mietmarkt in Deutschland ein bisschen in die Knie, weil niemand für 40 Euro pro Quadratmeter einen Innenstadtladen mehr mieten wird, weil diese Umsatzerwartungen gar nicht da sind. Die Leute kaufen ja alles bei Amazon. Dann könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass wir hier in Südekum da haben und das ist dann durchaus so rein explodiert, dass es dann so ganz unvogue ist, anders darüber zu sprechen. Es kommt aber sehr auf den Druck an und der wird glaube ich in Deutschland groß sein. Man macht sich noch keine Vorstellung, wie sehr Corona hier durch die Innenstädte gepflügt ist.
Und man ist hier nochmal ganz klar, wie man sehen kann, wie hegemonial eigentlich dieser Diskurs ist. Also hegemonial im Sinne davon, dass ja auch Redaktionen nicht auf die Idee kommen, solche Positionen in Talkshows zuzulassen. Diese Talkshows sind ja auch, wenn ich sie nicht gucke, sehr, sehr einflussreich, weil sie Millionen Zuschauer haben. Aber man kann durchaus heute noch 80 Shows abfahren, Lockdown, Light, jetzt noch strikterer Lockdown, Lockdown oder Shutdown, was sagt man eigentlich? Da gibt es ja dann dieses ganze Wortgeklingeltrum herum, Wellenbrecher, welche Welle, dritte, vierte, fünfte. Aber es ist schon interessant, dass diese Redaktionen auch so arbeiten, dass sie versuchen, erst mal das Neue nicht zuzulassen. In Klammern außer, es sind irgendwelche Extrempositionen von rechts. Da hat man sich immer sehr viel offener gezeigt. Da hat man gesagt, na ja, da hat zwar eigentlich schon fast den Hitlergruß gemacht, aber können wir trotzdem hier nochmal einladen.
Also ich glaube, sie lassen sich schon davon beeindrucken, wenn das denn in Amerika richtig losgeht. Und Amerika gibt jetzt, man kann sich nicht vorstellen, wie viel Geld da jetzt einfach rausgegeben wird. Also man kann sich ja einfach mal 5 Billionen runtergebrochen auf 300 Millionen Menschen. Wie viel ist denn das eigentlich pro Nase? Und da sieht man, oh je, das ist ja ganz schön viel. Also es sind ja ein paar Nullen pro Person. Hier reden wir ja im Zehntausenderbereich. Und das ist schon, das wird, glaube ich, Wirkung entfalten. Und man wird sich dann noch fragen, wieso können die Amerikaner das? Und dann wird man sich fragen, warum können wir das nicht? Und vielleicht sehen wir dann Adam Tewes hier nur im Podcast, aber dann wirklich mal auf etwas größere Bühne, beispielsweise mit so kleinen Sprechakten hier.
Viel besser wäre es, wenn wir eine neue Runde fiskalpolitischer Maßnahmen in den Augen nehmen würden. Man jubelt endlos dieses Next-Gen-EU-Paket. Und es ist eine wirklich erstaunliche Leistung.
Das sind die 750 Milliarden, die jetzt gerade weggeblockt wurden vom Bundesverfassungsgericht.
politische Leistung. Aber seine makroökonomischen Größenordnung lassen noch zu wünschen übrig. Also man könnte noch mehr Geld ausgeben. Die Frage ist natürlich, ob man dafür die Institutionen hat, ob die italienische Regierung in der Lage ist, noch mehr Geld positiv anzulegen, dafür Projekte zu finden. Aber von der makroökonomischen Balance her zu urteilen, gibt es da noch noch Raum, um mit der Fiskalpolitik aktiv zu werden.
Ja, ich meine, Anne Will kommt nicht umhin, auch heute mal darauf hinzuweisen, dass es in Deutschland einen Reformstau gibt, einen Investitionsstau von mehreren 100 Milliarden. Es mangelt ja nun mal wirklich nicht an Projekten. Also die muss man nicht krampfhaft finden. In deren Sicht ist ja doch einiges möglich. Wir gucken kurz, amerikanische Nachrichten. Das wird hier bei PPS am 4. März so ganz nebenbei mal eingefädelt.
Die Kongressional Budget Office ist vorgehalten, dass das Föderale Geld in den nächsten 30 Jahren zerstören wird. Und so wird das Spenden auf Social Security und Medicare.
Die Vorlage betrifft nicht die Covid-Releaf-Pakete, die jetzt in Bezug auf die Situation sind.
Tja, wo ist das Problem? Denken sich alle, die jetzt gucken, verdoppelt sich das Hals, ist mir doch egal.
Ja, das wird doch fast so angesagt wie eine Wettervorhersage. Ja, so wird es auch gar nicht kommen, aber es ist doch noch nicht alles drin. Mal schauen.
Genau, wir gehen kurz nach Deutschland. Olaf Scholz macht eine Bundespressekonferenz zum Thema Haushalt, wo auch Corona-Hilfen mit Inbegriffen sind. Und naja, was soll man sagen? Wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen runterdampfen. Eben haben wir über drei Trillionen zusammen fünf Trillionen gesprochen. Jetzt kommen wir nach Deutschland.
Da ist es auch im Jahr 2022 unumgänglich, erneut die Ausnahmeregel von der Schuldenregel in Anspruch zu nehmen. Insgesamt plant der Bund zur Finanzierung seiner Mindereinnahmen und Mehrausgaben für das kommende Jahr 81, 5 Milliarden Euro an Krediten aufzunehmen. Auch da wird der Bundestag die notwendigen Entscheidungen hoffentlich treffen. In den weiteren Finanzjahren, ab 2023, wird das Niveau der Neutverschuldung stark zurückgehen.
Die 750 Milliarden Euro für die EU, das lässt schon zu wünschen übrig. Da ist noch Spielraum. Und dann eher hier mit 81 Millionen für Deutschland, also ein Fünftel von der EU, mit 81, ein Zehntel von diesem EU-Schuldenstand. Für ein Fünftel der EU. Und dann entschuldigt das sich aber gleich. Ich hoffe, der Bundestag macht mit. Und es wird aber nächstes Jahr dann auch zurückgefahren. Ja, und das ist die Beutraten.
81 Milliarden, 83 Milliarden, ich hatte gerade gesagt, die 35 reichsten Familien haben im vergangenen Jahr 35 Milliarden dazuverdient. Da kann man das machen.
35 Milliarden oder 35 Prozent? Wahrscheinlich beides.
Ich glaube 35 Milliarden. Also es ist die Hälfte fast, was da jetzt mal so richtig ausgegeben wird, das hat man mal gerade so dazuverdient und ist gut gelagert wahrscheinlich jetzt offshore.
Ja, genau. Also der Neuverschuldigungswunsch von Olaf Scholz ließe sich sogar durch Abschöpfen noch finanzieren.
Also man könnte hier tatsächlich noch dieser, man könnte hier mal mit dieser Refinanzierungslogik sogar kommen und es würde funktionieren, ja.
Ja und Olaf Scholz nennt das einen Wumms.
Und all denen, die fragen, wo ist eigentlich der Wumms, kann man nur sagen, das ist der Wumms. Wir haben es geschafft, dass wir eine bessere wirtschaftliche Entwicklung haben als ohne die Maßnahmen, die hier auf den Weg gebracht worden sind.
Die aber gehen ordentlich ins Geld. Die Neuverschuldung des Bundes steigt durch den Nachtragshaushalt dieses Jahr um weitere 60 auf dann 240 Milliarden Euro. Und nächstes Jahr sollen weitere 81 Milliarden hinzukommen.
Ja, also im Spiegel Online Podcast haben sie dargestellt, wenn der Kongress entscheidet, dass man beidens Programm mitmacht, was sie bei den 1, 9 Trillionen her gemacht haben, dann fahren am nächsten Tag die Bagger. Dann haben die Bauarbeiter was zu tun, dann haben die Schüler eine bessere Schule und alles ist gut. Und dass irgendwo ein Schuldenstand geschrieben wird, ist auch egal.
Das ist übrigens auch Refinanzierung. Also wenn nicht alle Geschäfte pleite gehen, wenn nicht alle arbeitslos werden, dann wird wieder konsumiert, dann wird produziert. Und das wäre quasi Refinanzierung. Da werden ja auch wieder Steuern. Also selbst wenn man in dieser alten Logik mal eine Zeit noch bleiben möchte, weil man sich nicht so schnell umstellen kann, selbst auf dieser Ebene ist es vollkommen sinnlos, weiterhin so zu agieren. Aber man sieht ja schon in der Tonalität, wie das hier nochmal vorgetragen wird von dem Offsprecher, wie dramatisch das ist. Also hier, das ist ja so kurz davor, dass man, also in diesem Ton werden ja auch die Anzahl der Corona-Toten verkündigt.
Das stimmt. Und Redelsführer dieser Idiotokratie ist Ecker Drehberg, haushaltspolitischer Streifgang, glaube ich, von der CDU. Nein, das ist so Nachbarwahlkreis, Philipp Amthor. Deswegen musste er auch Philipp Amthor verteidigen und so. Also wir sind hier mitten im Marost, Morast, sozusagen. Und hören mal Ecker Drehberg.
Wir sind mit einer großen Rücklage gestartet und ich glaube gerade immer wieder zu sagen, wumms, Bazooka, es ist genügend Geld vorhanden, das weckt natürlich Begehrlichkeiten. Und ich glaube, als Bundesfinanzminister sollte man auch ein bisschen auf der Ausgabenbremse stehen.
Weshalb Olaf Scholz auch auf der Ausgabenbremse steht? Hier wird mal der deutsche Schuldenstand kurz eingehegt.
Wir rechnen damit, dass die Staatsverschuldung am Ende diesen Jahres auf 75 Prozent gestiegen sein wird der Wirtschaftsleistung. Und das ist dann immer noch weniger als am Ende der letzten Wirtschafts- und Finanzkrise. Damals lag sie bei über 80 Prozent, genau bei 82, 3 Prozent der Wirtschaftsleistung. Das ist etwas, was wir im Blick haben müssen, wenn wir über die Frage sprechen, haben wir die Kraft, das zu tun, was erforderlich ist, um wirtschaftlich die Krise zu bekämpfen. Und die Antwort dazu lautet ja.
Heißt damals hat man also mehr Schulden riskiert, weil man ja ganz große Vermögen retten musste, reichere Muster, während man jetzt, wo ganz viele Leute verschuldet sind, kein Geschäft vielleicht öffnen können in den nächsten Monaten. Jetzt sagt man, wir bleiben aber mal deutlich unter dem, was wir damals ausgegeben haben, beziehungsweise was wir leisten könnten an Verschuldung. Also es ist ein Himmelsschrein, das Skandal. Noch ein Beispiel von einer Bar, die ich, wenn keine Pandemie ist, besucht habe. Ja, da wurde ganz neu eine Bar eingerichtet. Da hat sich jemand, der Besitzer, nämlich verschuldet und hat natürlich gehofft, dass sich diese Investition von, ich glaube, 150, 200.000 Euro lohnt. Und dann muss er zumachen. Jetzt hat er wieder ein Kredit aufgenommen, um das irgendwie zu tragen. Von 80.000 hat seine privaten Mittel, die für die Altersvorsorge zurechtgelegt waren, schon verbraucht und sagt, bis August gibt er sich noch Zeit. Und sonst ist nur noch Insolvenz möglich. Das ist die Realität, die jemand wie Olaf Scholz vollkommen ausblendet mit dieser, man kann es nicht anders sagen, asozialen Politik.
Absolut. Also hier werden wirklich Leben zerstört, wenn nicht dann sogar vernichtet. Und man kann ja noch mal kurz aufs Jahr 2020 blicken, als die Amerikaner diese Rekordarbeitslosenzahlen plötzlich vermeldet haben, April, Mai. Und in Deutschland immer hieß, wir bauen hier Brücken. Wir haben Kurzarbeitergeld. Wir lassen die Leute nicht in die Arbeitslosigkeit, weil das auch für die Unternehmen blöd ist, danach wieder nur zu rekrutieren, kostet ja alles Geld und so weiter. Jetzt haben die Amerikaner das aber 2020 so gemacht, sind jetzt durchgeimpft. Also heute ist der 31.3. am 1.Mai kriegt der letzte Amerikaner sein Impfangebot, wenn er es annehmen möchte. Danach gibt es nur noch Impferweigerer, die nicht geimpft sind. Aber der Staat hat sozusagen sein Angebot gemacht, seine Schuldigkeit getan. Danach wird geöffnet. Und danach brummt der Laden wieder, während wir dann feststellen, dass die Brücke nicht funktioniert hat. Wenn die Amerikaner im Herbst feststellen, man kann die Wirtschaft so richtig aufpumpen, man muss nur einfach mal 1, 9 Trillionen den Leuten nach Hause schicken, die geben das dann schon aus, weil die wissen, ich muss das jetzt nicht anlegen für später, denn das Geld fließt jetzt wieder. Und die Unternehmen suchen auch wieder Mitarbeiter. Dann ist da einfach Bewegung, dann zirkuliert es dort. Und das ist der Moment, wo wir hier feststellen, dass wir einem Fehler aufgesessen sind, nämlich dass die Innenstädte nicht wieder aufmachen und dass die Kurzarbeitergelder klar 2020 gut geklappt haben, aber alles, was über Kurzarbeitergeld für große Unternehmen, die dann in Dividenden ausgeschüttet wurden, ja, später, dass es da eine Umverteilung gab, dass die anderen Hilfen nicht funktioniert haben, sondern dass die einfach nur die Leute auch sozusagen bei der Stange gehalten haben, obwohl dann viele denken werden, ich hätte mich vor einem Jahr schon umentschieden sollen, ob ich den Laden jetzt zumache oder vor einem Jahr, diese Rettung hat nicht funktioniert. Also es ist eine ganz große Gefahr in Deutschland. Und ich will mal zum Abschluss drei Clips spielen. Das eine ist die amerikanische Finanzministerin, die neue Janet Yellen, die ja vorher EZB-Chefin war. Und in Amerika muss ja eine Niederlage eingesteckt werden, nämlich kein 15 Dollar Mindestlohn landesweit. Es gibt weiterhin die Bundesstaatenregelung. Also viele haben einen höheren Mindestlohn als 7 Dollar. Amazon z.B. bezahlt überall einfach 15 Dollar, egal wo. Und die Janet Yellen stellt jetzt noch mal dar, dass man, und man ist ja noch dreieinhalb Jahre Präsident dort, man hätte ja noch ein bisschen Zeit bis zur Kongresswahl, in zwei Jahren ist es auch noch ein bisschen, dass man an dem Ziel festhält. Und jetzt können wir mal in diese Diskussion rein. Das ist nämlich ganz interessant. Der republikanische Senator John Thune ist jetzt zugeschaltet und artikuliert seinen Widerstand gegen 15 Dollar Mindestlohn. Wir kennen das Partikularinteresse wie bei der CDU. Wir sind die Partei der Unternehmer und wir wollen nicht, dass die die hohen Kosten haben. Das gesamtgesellschaftliche Argument, das verfängt da eben nicht so. Und dann kriegt er eine ganz interessante Nachfrage von der Journalistin zu seinem eigenen Mindestlohn als Teenager.
Was ich mir vorgeschlagen habe, ist, dass in Süddeutschland, zum Beispiel, wir setzten uns selbst. Es sind 9, 45 Dollar pro Stunde. Und ich denke, dass es viele Leute in meinem Staat gibt, und wahrscheinlich viele Leute hier, die Republikaner im Senat, es wäre okay, wenn es um 10 Dollar pro Stunde ging.
Aber du sagst, mehr als die Doppelung, zu 15 Dollar pro Stunde.
Es gibt viele Unternehmen in meinem Staat, die in der Reiseindustrie, die eine der schwierigsten Industrien unter der Pandemie ist, dass sie an 15 Dollar pro Stunde aus dem Geschäft gehen.
So, also wir haben jetzt beide Argumente. Zum einen die Unternehmer können ja dann das Geld nicht zahlen und ich bin für sie verantwortlich. Ich will ja von ihnen probiert werden und so weiter. Und ich habe ja selber damals 6 Dollar verdient. Das sind ja heute 20 Dollar. Das ist ungefähr 30 Jahre her. Und jetzt könnte man ja das projizieren mit so einer ganz einfache Mathematik, wie Merkel das gemacht hat. 6 Dollar, einmal verdoppelt sind 12 Dollar und dann nochmal 6 Dollar drauf sind 18 Dollar und dann nochmal ein bisschen und dann sind wir ungefähr bei den heutigen 20 Dollar. Da kann man ja jetzt nach vorne rechnen. Wir haben jetzt 2021, dann kommt 2030, 40, 50, also 2050 haben wir eigentlich das Ziel, dass der Mindestlohn oder sagen wir mal so nach fünf Jahren Studentenjob irgendwie, dass man dann 70 Dollar, 70 Euro verdient. Also das müsste eigentlich das Ziel sein. Dann muss man sich in Europa überlegen, wie schaffen wir das denn? Wie sieht denn der politische Plan aus, um zu sagen, wer fünf Jahre lang einen Minijob als Student nebenher macht, braucht dann 70 Euro Stunden? Und das sind die Inflationserwartungen, die wir eigentlich haben. Das verdeutlicht man sich immer nicht so, was das eigentlich bedeutet, dass man, wenn man diese zwei Prozent pro Jahr dann wirklich mal hochrechnet, dass man dann halt die bisherige Entwicklung der letzten 30 Jahre einfach nach vorne führt und dann sagt, ja, also 70 Euro pro Stunde ist nicht zu viel. Das sollten wir einem Studenten mal zahlen.
Ja, ja, diese Inflation wird ja gar nicht so mit reingerechnet, also die wir ohnehin haben. Also wir haben ja eine gewisse Inflation haben wir und deswegen steigen auch die Preise. Deswegen ist heute die Cola im Automaten wesentlich teurer als die Cola, die wir 1980 gekauft haben im Automaten. Und das wird aber auch nicht so gesehen, wenn diese starke Fokussierung auf die Zinsen kommt, dass man sagt, man hat früher diese hohen Zinsen gehabt. Wenn man das aber dann doch mal so durchrechnet, was waren 1000 Euro 1980, dann hat man darauf die Zinsen bekommen bis 2000 etwa bis zu der Zeit, als das mit den Zinsen zu Ende war. Wie war aber dann auch die Preisentwicklung? Und ist das dann wirklich so wahnsinnig viel mehr geworden, das Geld, oder wurde da nicht eher ausgeglichen? Und das ist gar nicht so ein großer Betrag, der dann da gerade kommt. Und das wird jetzt hier deutlich, wenn man das mal auf die Löhne überträgt. Und man kann sagen, in allen anderen Branchen, erst mal in der Politikerkaste, dann aber auch all diese Unternehmer, die er vertritt, die sind nicht auf irgendeinem Lohnniveau von damals stehengeblieben. Bei denen hat sich das viel stärker entwickelt. Bei denen ist das, was damals vielleicht 100 Euro war, dann heute hat sich das verachtfacht, nicht nur verzweieinhalbfacht.
So, die Grünen haben jetzt ihr Programm vorgelegt, für Deutschland zumindest. Sie wollen 50 Milliarden Euro jährlich. Ich zitiere ein bisschen aus der FAZ, 50 Milliarden Euro jährlich. Das ganze laufende Jahrzehnt für eine, Zitat, sozial-ökologische Transformation. Besteuerung von Vermögen ab 2 Millionen Euro mit 1 Prozent. Also dieses Elizabeth Warren-Mendel so ein bisschen. Und neue Höchststeuergrenzen, also die Einkommenssteuer, nochmal eine neue Stufe bei 100.000 Euro für alleinstehende 200.000 für Paare und 250.000 und 500.000 Euro. Soll nochmal extra berücksichtigt werden. 500.000 Euro macht dann 48 Prozent, immer noch nicht über 50, finde ich skandalös. Man kann durchaus mal die 50 mutig ran. Hartz IV soll ersetzt werden durch eine sanktionsbefreite Grundsicht, Garantiesicherung. Also niemand soll mehr noch was weggekürzt werden. Und außerdem der Regelsatz von 432 auf 603 Euro. Und jetzt kommt ein Clip von Robert Habeck. Und er, es gibt viel Zynismus in der linken Blase. Man denkt über nichts nach, interessiert sich für nichts, hat keinen Plan für nichts, sieht dann Robert Habeck, wie er irgendwas sagt und sagt, das ist aber scheiße, das ist ja viel zu wenig. Und ich würde das System gerne mal umdrehen, dass man nämlich Robert Habeck jetzt aus der linken Blase heraus ermächtigt, mit der Suffisanz, mit der wir Adam Toos vorhin gehört haben, auf einem Podium sitzen zu können. Das geht aber nur, wenn das Feld entsprechend bereitet ist. Wenn Robert Habeck der einzige ist, der die ganze Zeit kämpft und strampelt mit Baerbock und wir alle nur daneben stehen und sagen, das ist aber jetzt zu wenig jetzt, wo du es sagst. Nein, das Feld muss natürlich vorbereitet werden. Also solche Argumentationen wie eben hier, wir brauchen einen Umbau der Europäischen Union, wir brauchen eine Entmächtigung der Bundesregierung, wir brauchen einen eigenen politischen Haushalt der Europäischen Kommission, die nicht von Berlin aus gesteuert, darüber entscheidet, was fiskalpolitisch mit dem Geld passiert, dass ihr eins zu eins von der EZB zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Das muss alles vorbereitet werden, damit, und es tut mir nämlich ein bisschen leid, wie zaghaft Robert Habeck hier genau das Richtige sagt. Also es liegt nicht an Robert Habeck, es liegt an uns, dass das politische Wahlprogramm der Grünen hier entsprechend ausfällt und er auf der Bühne eben auch so agiert, wie er agiert. Und ich finde, wir sollten ihm und den Grünen jetzt alle helfen und den Linken, die Linke, die denkt man schon gar nicht mehr, das künftig anders zu machen. Robert Habeck muss jetzt munitioniert werden.
Die verschiedenen Projekte, die Ausgaben für Klimaschutz, die Investitionen in Infrastruktur, das Arbeiten für Bildung und Forschung, die Ausgaben im sozialen Bereich, für eine gute Krankenhausinfrastruktur beispielsweise. Sie kulminieren in einem großen Investitionsprogramm, das wir auflegen wollen. Es überschreitet die Investition, die die bisherige Bundesregierung vornimmt, etwa um das Doppelte. Die 50 Milliarden, die wir mehr ausgeben wollen, ist eine Verdoppelung der Investitionen, fast eine Verdoppelung der Investitionen in Deutschland. Und sie ist dringend notwendig. Das reiche Deutschland investiert in seine Zukunft unterdurchschnittlich im europäischen Vergleich. Ganz zu schweigen davon von den Ländern, die gesellschaftliche Wohlfahrt am stärksten nach vorne bringen, die skandinavischen Länder. Aber auch wenn sie schauen, was in der USA, in Japan los ist. Wir geben zu wenig Geld für unsere Zukunft aus. Wir stellen also der Verschuldung in den Büchern, eine Verschuldung in der Wirklichkeit gegenüber, die wir jetzt in der Pandemie aber insgesamt so stark gesehen haben. Schlechtes Internet, schlechte Schulen, wenig Ausgaben in Bildung und Forschung und zurückbleiben beim Klimaschutz. All das läuft darauf hinaus, dass wir zu wenig investieren in unser Land, in Deutschland, in die Zukunft. Wir wollen also die Schuldenregel um eine Investitionsregel ergänzen, eine Investitionsregel, die festlegt, dass die öffentliche Hand eine Aufgabe hat, die die Leben der Menschen reicher und besser macht.
Ich glaube auch. Ich befürchte, es ist so. Also man braucht jetzt da vielleicht so aus der zweiten Reihe die einen oder anderen, die auch mal einfach sagen, wir haben ja Geld, wir könnten ja ausgeben ohne Ende. Also das muss, das muss glaube ich jetzt mal passieren und da braucht es Mutige, die es aussprechen und das wäre eigentlich für alle drei Parteien ganz gut. Da kann man sich positionieren, ist am Ende auch langfristiger in der Wirkung mehr mit geholfen und ist nicht so eine Symbol Handlung nur reicht halt dann am Ende doch nicht, wenn man lange Zeit langfristig Politik machen will, mal einen Blumenstrauß geworfen zu haben, sondern ich glaube, da geht es dann schon darum, dass man ein bisschen mehr Stachel im System ist.
Manchmal denke ich, die klügsten politischen Beiträge kommen von meinem Vierjährigen im Kindergarten kursieren manchmal so Sprüche. Irgendwer hat irgendwas im Fernsehen gesehen, weil große Brüder und so und dann schaukelt sich das so auf und es gibt zwei Sprüche. Das eine ist What the heck, Alter? Und das ist Are you mad? Und genau so muss man reagieren, wenn Robert Harding kommt und nicht weiterkommt, weil ihm Eckhard Rehberg im Weg steht, dann muss man, wenn Eckhard Rehberg sagt, nee, das ist ganz gut, dass der deutsche Finanzminister hier nochmal die Züge zaubert und so weiter und so fort, dann muss man so, are you mad? Das muss man dann nicht weiter inhaltlich, das muss einfach nur, what the heck, Alter? So muss das in Deutschland mal argumentiert werden. Naja, hier ist jedenfalls jetzt genug Angebot gemacht, die Welt besser zu machen und die Grünen und die Linken, wenn sie mal aus dem Schoß kommen, zu unterstützen.
Ja, den Rest tun wir im Salon, da schauen wir uns mal an, wie die Arbeit aussieht in Zukunft oder wie sie auch gegenwärtig aussieht. Wir lesen ja das Buch Working Class von Julia Friedrichs. Ich hab's schon ganz gelesen. Das ist hochinteressant, auf welche Berufsfelde sie da blickt, vor allem auf ein Berufsfeld, das man gar nicht im Blick hat oder das ich gar nicht im Blick habe, nämlich jemand, der dafür zuständig ist, dass die U-Bahn gereinigt sind. Also auch da ein Portrait zu schreiben, ja, sehr interessant.
Aber ihr habt auch keine U-Bahn in Koblenz, oder?
Nein, aber ich bin natürlich auch schon mal in meinem Leben mit einer U-Bahn gefahren und gerade auch mit der in Berlin. Und ja, dann gibt es da ein sehr interessantes Kapitel über die 80er Jahre und die Serien, die es da im deutschen Fernsehen gab, denn es gibt ja immer mal wieder so diese Nostalgie. Können wir nicht mal wieder dahin zurück, als es noch wohlig war in der Bundesrepublik. Und da zeigt uns Julia Friedrichs aber auch, nee, das ist nicht mehr möglich und das ist vielleicht auch gut. Also interessant. Und dann blicken wir ja mit einem anderen Buch ein bisschen in die Zukunft der Automatisierung und was Arbeit dann bedeuten könnte.
Genau, wir haben uns einfach für beide entschieden. Das eine heißt Future Proof. Wie sichern wir uns gegen die Gefahr der Automatisierung ab? Und das andere Working Class. Wo haben die Automaten erstmal keine Chance und wo müssen wir weiter auf die Menschen achten? Ich glaube auch, das wird super interessant. Die restlichen Texte mal gucken. Ich habe jetzt noch nichts ausgewählt. Mache ich zu Ostern, wenn ich auf dem Sofa sitze, während die Kinder im Garten spielen. Und dann machen wir hier nächste Woche Salon. Wir freuen uns. Es sind 2040 Salonmitglieder, glaube ich.
Ja, ich werde noch ein Buch lesen zum Thema Triage. Da ist was Neues erschienen. Jetzt bei Reclam von Adriano Manino. Das werde ich vorstellen. Und sehr wahrscheinlich das neue Buch von Josef Vogel, Kapital und Ressentiment, der den digitalen Kapitalismus dort sich zu Brust nimmt und er lässt nicht viel Hoffnung.
Gut, wenn ich es dann noch schaffe, gibt es nächste Woche noch eine kleine Einschätzung innerlicher Art von mir zu influencer natürlich. Wenn ich es lese, werde ich natürlich auch was dazu sagen. Aber ich glaube, ich bin gut beladen erstmal mit den beiden und lese es dann. Je nachdem, wie weit ich auf Papier so komme, wie schnell. Dann haut rein.
Bis zum Salon.
Genau. Achtet auf eure politischen Argumente. Übertreibt es nicht mit euren Lockdown-Forderungen und genießt das Leben. Die Sonne kommt jetzt wieder raus. Lasst euch nicht die frische Luft verbieten von niemandem.
Genau.
Dieser Podcast darf nur im Freien gehört werden. Haut rein.